es ist der zweite tag des fdp
parteitages in kalkar am niederrhein
eintreffen von hu gut 500 delegierten so
war es gestern am samstag noch ist der
saal ist voll meine damen und herren und
sie sehen auch dass die tische
voneinander weg gerückt sind der
parteitag findet nämlich unter streng
sind coruna auflagen statt gestern hat
die partei ihr erstes sozialpolitisches
konzept beschlossen darin enthalten auch
insbesondere ein rentenpapier und hat
dann am späteren abend auch vakante
posten besetzt mit den gemäßigten
partei-mitgliedern heute könnt ihr es
oder wird es mit sicherheit noch einmal
spannend denn der co-parteichef york
wollten hatte gestern eine rede gehalten
die für gesprächsstoff gesorgt hat und
über die heute gesprochen wird jörg
nolte hat der partei die leviten gelesen
und gesagt so geht das nicht weiter
manche empfinden das als spalterisch und
damit meine damen und herren
guten morgen herzlich willkommen zu
diesem zweiten tag des parteitags wieder
mit mir im studio hier in berlin ist
professor wolfgang schröder von der uni
kassel ja gut nur schön und nehmen
wir ordnen das heute im laufe des tages
allen aber meine damen und herren und
damit sie wissen was stand der dinge ist
was genau passiert ist an diesem
denkwürdigen parteitag an diesem präsenz
parteitag eine kurze zusammenfassung
wer dachte das aufregendste hier könnte
die frage sein ob 600 delegierte es
tatsächlich schaffen den ganzen tag mit
maske am platz zu sitzen
der wird enttäuscht sein ja das schaffen
sie die maske fällt dann ganz woanders
in einer rede von parteichef mitten in
der er all jenen parteifreunden
sorgfältig geplant und mit voller wucht
fonds schienbein tritt die nur allzu
gerne rum krakeelen und rump rollen oder
auch andere dazu einladen wie wir das
vergangene woche leider im bundestag
erleben mussten weil sie sich in der
rolle des provokateurs gefallen wie
pubertierende schulung alle wissen wer
gemeint ist als meuten anprangert es sei
nicht klug im bundestag von corona
diktatur zu sprechen
afg funktionäre dürften sich nicht
weiter kritiklos gemein machen mit der
quer denken bewegung das kann und darf
so keinesfalls weiter geht entweder wir
kriegen hier die kurve und zwar sehr
entschlossen und sehr bald oder wer
werden
als parteien keine zukunft die ganz ganz
schwere see geraten und gegebenenfalls
scheitern der riss verläuft gut sichtbar
quer durch den bundesvorstand genau wie
quer durch die gesamte partei beifall
und buhrufe leuten bekommt beides
der gescholtene ehrenvorsitzende nennt
die rede spalterisch ich verstehe
wirklich nicht warum jemand der nicht
dabei war
die fraktion eingreift obwohl wir
verwalten und ich und der ganze
fraktionsvorstand das problem gelöst
haben
auch bestrafungen ausgesprochen haben
da muss ich jetzt keine belehrungen des
bundes sprechers entgegennehmen die afg
ist im umfragetief kann bisher nicht von
der korona krise profitieren und muss
zudem als gesamtpartei eine beobachtung
durch den verfassungsschutz fürchten
etwas das läuten um jeden preis
verhindern will
ich finde es wichtig dass in unserer
partei auch bestimmte sachen
ausgesprochen werden die einige leute
nicht passen
und das hat er gemacht und das ist
richtig deuten und sein co-vorsitzender
kubala sie sind kein echtes team mehr
seit dem rauswurf des rechtsaußen
kalbitz den der eine wollte und der
andere nicht
es freut sich ein dritter da gibt es den
dissens in der partei es gibt den
dissens auch in den personen der
bundessprecher das sehe ich auch und die
partei wird sich sicherlich irgendwann
auch entscheiden müssen was der richtige
weg ist trotz allem schafft es die afg
ihrem leitantrag zur renten und
sozialpolitik mit großer mehrheit zu
verabschieden
auch vorstandsposten welt sie nach ja
und für uns er ist alexander keller beim
parteitag vor ort alexander sie sind ja
ein bisschen am rande
ist denn eigentlich ein parteitag zu
verfolgen bei dem sie da sind aber auch
nicht so ganz in der halle drin sind wie
empfinden sie das ja gut wir bekommen
natürlich auch wie alle anderen die
bilder aus der halle
es ist ein präsenz parteitag der afd den
wollte sie unbedingt haben und muss man
fairerweise sagen und das ist ja in
diesem beitrag gerade angeklungen es ist
eben nicht diese super sprit im event
geworden wo es hier mehr als zwei viren
gibt als delegierten ein alle fast alle
delegierte waren diszipliniert haben die
maske getragen so dass dass dieser
parteitag in der hinsicht ganz korrekt
verlaufen ist
die mitarbeiter des ordnungsamtes hier
in kalkar hatten wenig zu tun und die
befürchtung der parteitag müsse
abgebrochen werden wegen massiven
verstoßes gegen die massen pflicht der
war also völlig abwegig bzw
es hat nicht stattgefunden ansonsten ist
der partie in der hinsicht entspannt
gewesen weniger entspannt war ja auch
dass es schon gerade angesprochen worden
durch die rede des parteivorsitzenden
jörg leuten da gibt es jetzt viele
diskussionen es gibt ja noch einen
antrag heute in dem dem
parteivorsitzenden jörg neunten jahr
spalterische gebaren vorgeworfen wird
das bezog sich nicht auf den gestrigen
auftritt sondern auf diskussionen auch
auf den rausschmiss des früheren
brandenburgischen landeschefs andreas
kalbitz da muss ich ja mitten in der
partei viele angriffe erwehren dass wir
heute noch diskutiert und das ist
natürlich noch verschärft worden
durch die rede gestern aber in gestern
wurde auch wurden ja auch personalien
bestimmte eben
in die nachrückerin für andreas kalbitz
wurde gewählt
eine gemäßigte ja es wurden insgesamt
drei politische relevante posten neu
gewählt der posten des bundes
schatzmeisters und seines
stellvertreters und im falle wie gesagt
der nachwahl auf den beisitzerposten
nachfolge für andreas kalbitz müssen wir
hier das generische feminin und bedienen
und wollen das ja auch gerne obwohl das
in der parteien nicht so besonders
beliebt es ist eine beisitzerin johanna
cotta digital politische sprecherin im
bundestag und ist jetzt auch bei uns zum
interview zu gast frau k vielleicht noch
ganz kurz sie haben jetzt einen posten
geerbt von andreas kalbitz der aus der
partei ausgeschlossen worden ist weil er
beim eintritt in diese parteien die afg
nicht angegeben hat dass er verbindungen
zur rechtsextremistischen organisationen
hatte finden sie diesen rausschmiss von
dem sie jetzt profitieren als neues
mitglied des bundesvorstandes korrekt
war das richtig das liebt den
bundesvorstand gar keine andere wahl als
disney schmiss zu beschließen
wer die wahrheit nicht sagt wenn man die
partei einsetzt und dinge verschweigt
die wirklich wichtig sind
er hat leider verloren und da muss
leider die partei verlassen so sind die
regeln und das stift auf jeden zu egal
ob das bundesvorstandsmitglied ist oder
ein einfaches mitglied gut sie haben ja
gemeinsam mit 99 anderen an den brief
der 100 unterschrieben in der afg der
richtete sich gegen die politische linie
von görke und von andreas kalbitz den so
genannten früheren flügel dafür dass sie
da als gemäßigt gelten weil sie den
unterschrieben haben in der partei haben
sie gestern eine ziemlich deftige
bewerbungsrede gehalten muss man denn
die stimmungskanone sein um in seinem
vorstand gewählt zu werden nein also die
rede wie kann wirklich aus dem herzen
das ist das was ich denke auch wenn man
gegen gewisse parteiströmungen ja
bedenken hat oder sagt man muss ein
bisschen vorsichtiger sein mit dem was
man sagt wie man auftritt man dafür
keine vorlagen liefern man muss wer
fakultäten vernünftige positionen heißt
das nicht dass man politisch gesehen vom
programm abweicht oder anders tickt als
die partei ganz im gegenteil ich halte
mich steigern das programm
ich stehe hinter allem was in unserem
programm stehen
und das habe ich das dann auch zum
ausdruck gebracht im bundesvorstand
hängt der haussegen schief und zwar
nicht nur seit erst seit der gestrigen
rede des parteivorsitzenden
wie wollen sie denn da agieren wo es da
eher integrativ wirken brücken bauen
oder werden sie eine klare politische
linie dafür folgen
ich würde so gerne so ein bisschen
machen wie in hessen in hessen sind wir
glaube ich auf einem guten weg nach der
auflösung des flügels gehen die
konstruktiven kräfte aufeinander zu
möchten miteinander arbeiten möchten
diese partei nach vorne bringen ich habe
es gestern in meiner rede erwähnt wir
müssen die kinderkrankheiten loswerden
wir müssen da wachsen werden weniger bei
uns selber reden wir über uns ein inhalt
und die themen nach vorne stellen und
das wäre schön wenn das auch im
bundesvorstand gelegt wenn wir noch mal
auf die rede von jörg butt von gestern
schauen dass wir ein donnerschlag der
richtete sich auch gegen teile der
partei aber auch gegen teile der
bundestagsfraktion blass sind sie ja nun
mitglied dann wie haben sie das
empfunden das war ja gardinen predigt
ist eigentlich zu schwach es gibt das
war im prinzip war das eine eine art
massiver kritik des parteivorsitzenden
anteilen von partei und fraktion wie
haben sie das empfunden
das ist in teilen des publikums hier
nicht gut angekommen bei anderen teilen
die haben die akuten gefahr gefeiert ich
denke wir werden darüber intern im
bundesvorstand diskutieren sowohl über
die räder als auch über die reaktion von
herrn bauland und das werden wir ganz in
ruhe klären das weiß ich nicht ob das
gerade eine freudsche versprecher von
ihnen war mit dem feiern und feuern
gut dann fahre ich jetzt trotzdem ist
der posten oder ist die erneuten durch
diese räte gefährdet als vorsitzender
denn es gab ja jede menge
unmutsäußerungen also so viele haben
nicht geklatscht bei dieser weg ist ja
die unmutsäußerung waren laut aber es
gab genau so viele die geklatscht haben
die dann über das fernsehen vielleicht
nicht so gut rüber gekommen sind aber
ich glaube nicht dass unser
parteivorsitzender gefährdet ist sie hat
trotzdem eine gefahr der spaltung in der
partei durch die also nicht nur durch
diese rede sondern dass es eben doch
massive unterschiede gibt zum beispiel
auch in der sozialpolitik zwischen höcke
und leuten die frage wie ist die
politische die inhaltliche ausrichtung
auch die frage wie gehen wir mit
politischen institutionen um es gab ja
gestern sogar einen beschluss dass die
fdp sich jetzt besonders zu
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
bekennen will das grundgesetz beachten
möchte sind ja eigentlich
selbstverständlichkeiten
aber da gibt es ja möglicherweise auch
in der partei ganz unterschiedliche
meinungen wie man mit diesen
institutionen die ja auch von wie sie es
immer sagen altparteien geprägt wird
also ich glaube nicht dass es eine
partei unterschiedliche auffassungen
gibt auch für uns als grundgesetz halten
auf gar keinen fall aber warum dann
dieser beschluss der war doch sehr
auffällig das wurde ja so noch mal
bewusst hier in der partei
implementiertes gestellt man dass wir
schon das betonen muss für mich ist das
eine absolute selbstverständlichkeit
aber gerade weil sie das soziale
angesprochen haben wir haben gestern
ihren parteitag gezeigt dass wir sehr
konstruktiven miteinander arbeiten
können
und auch wenn wir von ganz
unterschiedlichen positionen starten von
dem neuen konzept gehört zum konzept und
sind damit zu erfüllen können und sagen
können okay damit können wir alle leben
und ich bin überzeugt davon dass uns das
auch in vielen anderen gebieten gelingen
wird es wird ja auch in diesem beschluss
des bundesvorstandes von vorgestern
abend da waren sie wahrscheinlich noch
nicht dabei weil noch nicht mitglied
wird ja auch noch mal gesagt also wenn
es streitigkeiten über äußerungen von
mitgliedern der partei gibt oder auch
von beschlüssen der partei um das
bundesverfassungsgericht würde die
sozusagen bei einem buy in einem
gerichtlichen streitfall dann sozusagen
als verfassungswidrig bezeichnet würde
man sich da auch daran halten
die frage es wird jetzt sozusagen die
afg in zukunft alle ihre politischen
streitfragen dem verfassungsgericht
vorlegen ob die dann verfassungsgemäß
sind damit ganz sicher nicht also werden
uns hier keinen maulkorb aufzwingen
lassen wir werden politik nach wie vor
so machen wie wir es machen und wie das
richtig halten und wir werden die
wahrheiten die wir kennen auch
tatsächlich offen ansprechen und dann
werden wir schauen wie der
verfassungsschutz reagiert wir müssen es
das ein oder andere verkneifen absolut
da bin ich bei ihnen fiel das war
unnötig was gesagt worden ist wir sind
eine partei die auf dem grundrecht
basiert die die freiheit in deutschland
verteidigt und das müssen wir in zukunft
genauso darstellen
wie werden sie in zukunft mit anderen
parteien umgehen die haben ja gestern
gesagt das sind gegner ist nicht
irgendwie das wort feind auch mal
gefallen konfrontativ konfrontation im
bundestag ist klar das sind politische
auseinandersetzungen aber sehen sie auch
politische bündnisse mittelfristig für
die afd
naja also sieht die feindschaft die
kommt ja erst mal von den alt bat uns
gegenüber gerade was der bundestag
angeht da kann ich ja manchmal gar nicht
glauben was da passiert da hilft die
aber manchmal richtig nach damit man sie
angreift im bundestag naja aber wir
legen konstruktive vorschläge vor gute
anzüge die abgelehnt werden und die
nachher die altparteien übernehmen und
unter eigenem logo wieder ein primat
jetzt auch die vorgänge da geht es dahin
will ja aber glauben sie nicht dass die
alv die manchmal die munition an die den
politischen gegner liefert mit der man
dann werde ich froh dass ich gesagt ja
ein oder eine äußerung hätte ich mir
persönlich verkniffen ja das ist nicht
nötig wir müssen nicht auf dem
silbertablett servieren
weil wir das auch gar nicht nötig haben
wir sind wir haben ein gute struktur und
wenn wir das sachlich vortragen
dann denke ich werden wir auch weiterhin
erfolgreich sein gut soweit johanna
total digital politische sprecherin der
partei im bundestag und das neueste
mitglied im bundesvorstand an geschehen
dass ich hier war für die zuschauer und
wir gehen jetzt bevor sie im parteitag
richtig los geht erstmal zu doris müller
die erzählt uns was am zweiten tag
dieses als die parteitag ist hier in
kalkar alles geplant ist er vielen dank
alexander keller her unter dem motto das
beste kommt zum schluss würde ich den
zweiten tag subsumieren denn den antrag
über den sie gerade ja auch mit der
neuen beisitzerinnen bundesvorstand
geredet haben der kommt wirklich als
allerletzten tagesordnungspunkt dran
da geht es eben um die spalterischen
gefahren und es spalterische gefahren
und die haltung von jörg nolte
all das wird aber am ende des
parteitages debattiert was kommt heute
noch also wir erwarten den
rechenschaftsbericht 2009 10 der sich
auf die parteiarbeit 2018 bezieht und
auf die drucksache des bundestages da
können die parteimitglieder ganz
zufrieden sein
23 millionen barvermögen hat die partei
da ist also jede menge ich sag jetzt mal
ganz entspanntes anhören
nichtsdestotrotz wird mit sicherheit die
zahlung der strafen ein thema sein
über die heute morgen im
rechenschaftsbericht geredet werden muss
denn
der bundestag hat ja insgesamt rund
400.000 euro strafe an die partei
gestellt weil es unerlaubte spenden gab
die keine zweifelsfreie und zweifelsohne
keine saubere zuordnung gegeben hat
diese zahlungsbescheid sind raus die
partei klagt dagegen
wie das aussehen wird muss man abwarten
aber da die partei genügend geld hat
es gibt bundesligavereine die würden
sich über 23 millionen euro barvermögen
sehr sehr sehr freuen
also das ist das eine was gibt es noch
es gibt satzungsfragen von den
mitgliedern sie sehen hier etliche
tische übrigens noch leer
das hängt damit zusammen dass vorne an
den akkreditierungs büros sowie der
julian fleig der versammlungsleiter das
gerade erzählte und erläuterte noch
lange schlangen sind die sind etwas
länger und es dauert alles etwas länger
weil natürlich die abstands und
hygieneregeln eingehalten werden müssen
und deswegen ist das etwas langsamer als
sonst und der parteitag beginnt auch
deswegen ein bisschen später so dann
gibt es noch fragen zur satzung da ziehe
ich mal zwei raus die glaube ich unter
der ägide stehen dass sie als konsequenz
aus dem rausschmiss von andreas kalbitz
zu verstehen sind es gibt zwei satzungs
anträge in denen es um die
unvereinbarkeit liste geht die die
partner hat also wenn es verbände und
vereine gegeben hat die auf dieser liste
stehen dann können die parteimitglieder
die neu aufgenommen werden sollen
nichtmitglieder der afc werden das soll
neu geregelt werden und zwar in einer
kommission die das ständig überwachen
soll dies ist ein antrag der ist gar
nicht so uninteressant dann gibt es
einen anderen antrag in dem die regeln
zur mitglieder aufnahme die jetzt jeder
landesvorstand selber für sich bestimmen
kann und detaillierter und präzise
ausformulieren kann zukünftig vom
bundesparteitag beschlossen werden also
das soll das gremium sein zukünftig laut
antrag dass regeln zur mitglieder
aufnahme bestimmt sodann habe ich wie
gesagt die beiden anträge
es gibt nämlich zwei anträge die
sich gegen jörg neu einrichten ich habe
immer nur den einen erwähnt weil er in
der abfolge den namen jörg leuten auch
erwähnt es gibt einen zweiten antrag der
sich mit dem verfassungsschutz befasst
in dem es aber unter anderem in den
erläuterungen heißt dass der parteitag
beschließen müsse ich lese ihnen das mal
vor dass er sich strikt dagegen wendet
dass unsere partei oder einzelne
parteimitglieder bewertungen des
verfassungsschutzes automatisch
übernehmen und für die innerparteiliche
auseinandersetzung verwenden
sobald dies nützlich zu sein scheint
dies ist sicherlich auch gegen jörg neu
eingerichtet ohne dass der name genannt
wird in diesem verfassungsschutz antrag
wird der verfassungsschutz als
machtinstrument welches gegen
parteipolitische konkurrenten eingesetzt
wird definiert und soll grundlegend
reformiert werden sollte er nicht
reformiert werden können dann soll er
grundsätzlich auch abgeschafft werden so
weit der kurze inhalt dieses antrages
der ebenfalls ganz am schluss befasst
wird und das ganze wie gesagt wird in
ein paar minuten losgehen bis dahin
haben wir aber nochmal zeit um zu
konstanzer abramsky zu schalten
ja danke doris müller und professor
wolfgang stunde wir haben auch zeit noch
mal auf dem parteitag zurück aber auch
voraus zu schauen was gestern sicherlich
das außerdem inhaltlich wichtigsten war
warten weil die rede von jungen leuten
schnell ist ja schon mehrfach angetestet
wurde
was mich total verwundert hat ist warum
diese partei nicht sofort darüber
gestritten hatten dass ich ausgesprochen
hat das ist ja eigentlich das war so ein
kräftiger ansage
[Musik]
das hat man gemerkt ich glaube aber die
partei war richtig geschockt gewesen
weil das thema der partei soll der
sozialpolitik antrag seien die frage ob
man corona demonstrativ so handhaben
kann dass ein gros parteitag stattfinden
kann und dann kommt der vorsitzende und
hält nicht nur eine basta und wut rede
sondern richtet seine kritik direkt
gegen die fraktionsspitze und toupiert
damit den menschen der in den letzten
drei jahren für sich in anspruch nimmt
den laden zusammengehalten zu haben und
das hat natürlich eine gewisse
schockstarre hervorgerufen und in den
interviews die dann stattgefunden haben
wird sehr deutlich wie stark diese
resonanz war der wird von spaltung
gesprochen da wird von einem
unangemessenen verhalten gesprochen
also das wird heute noch ein nachspiel
haben das ist ganz sicher und deshalb
auch der antrag dass man heute die
diskussion nach holt die gestern
eigentlich hätte stattgefunden haben
müssen
aber es ist nicht ungewöhnlich für
solche großveranstaltungen dass man da
doch schwierigkeiten hat auf
unangemessene und unerwartete ereignisse
so zu reagieren wie es eigentlich
notwendig
die spontanität dass man sich einfach
nicht und da ist es dann natürlich auch
so ein bisschen schade dass wir uns auch
nicht in dem parteitag wie das sonst
üblich ist wenn nicht corona wäre dass
wir uns da als journalisten nicht nicht
bewegen können also wir sitzen jetzt ja
auch entfernt davon gut dann schauen wir
mal wie das heute wird das wird bestimmt
eine spannende geschichte erst muss der
antrag hier angenommen werden darüber zu
sprechen das ist ja noch im antrags
stadium gestellt hatte ihn ja ein 1 1
ein parteimitglied aus baden württemberg
freiburg genau handelt der auch ganz
klar sagen also ich würde sagen ein
agenda hat und absolut kennen wollten
freut sich erst um das ganz höflich aus
nein es ist ein flügel vertreter der
auch den antrag gestellt hat dass das
spalterische verhalten von leuten in
anderen fragen hier besprochen werden
müsse bezüglich andreas carl bildt aber
auch andere dinge also die beiden liegen
schon seit 23 jahren im dauerclinch also
insofern ist das relativ erwacht mal
gewesen dass hier so ein aufschlag kommt
und auch von dieser personen der hat
hier übrigens gestern auch einen
aufschlag gemacht wurde die presse
ausgeladen haben wollt also die müssen
hier raus weil die tragen nur dazu bei
dass wir hier vorgeführt werden und das
ist natürlich unglaublich nah weil
parteitage sind öffentliche
veranstaltungen und als solche muss die
presse dabei sein und wenn dann jemand
kommt und sagt die presse muss raus dann
wird auch noch mal ein anderer
spannungsbogen deutlich dass nämlich die
afg von anfang an ja eine partei gewesen
ist die sich aufgestellt hat gegen den
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk gegen
die medien und die fake news und lügen
presse zum thema ihrer politischen
mobilisierung gemacht das findet diese
dieses thema findet hier auch gerade um
die erhöhung des rundfunkbeitrags stadt
in sachsen-anhalt wo die fdp dagegen
gestimmt und die die cdu noch nicht
entschieden ist wie sich denn oder
vielleicht mit stimme dass wir noch ein
anderer spannender fall seien ja also
das war ein wirklich interessanter
antrag da gestern abend trotzdem wie
stark sind denn die flügel vertreter
kann man das sagen kann man das auch
daraus ablesen wenn wir jetzt die drei
nachbarn uns anschauen also der
bundesschatzmeister sein stellvertreter
und auch die neue beisitzerin die er
gemäss ich gehe so wenn man jetzt die
wahlen nehmen muss man ganz klar sagen
dass man seine position stabilisieren
konnte die mehrheit die eh schon vorher
im bundesvorstand vorhanden war und die
auch die basis für den ausschluss von
kalbitz war das hat sich stabilisiert
durch die wahlen von gestern abend weil
da muss man immer sehen
diejenigen die besonders im öffentlichen
scheinwerferlicht sind sind ja in den
letzten jahren die ostdeutschen
landesverbände und der führung von röcke
gewesen
die stellen aber nur etwa 15 prozent der
gesamten mitgliedschaft des laut aber
nicht so laut aber mitglieder mäßig
schwach und insofern ist klar die
westdeutschen verbände haben eigentlich
das sagen und in westdeutschland sind
die mehrheit der verbände er
interessiert so eine rechts der union
etablierte partei zu werden die
perspektivisch auch koalitionsfähig sein
kann mit den anderen parteien
da kann man sich ja trotzdem die frage
stellen wie kann auf diese diametralen
gegen polen die man ja eigentlich zieht
wie kann denn da weiter eine partei
passieren und weiter weiter reduzieren
wenn dann ein gaul an zum beispiel
wegfallen sollte das ist weg die
entscheidende frage weil das
erfolgsrezept der afg in der
vergangenheit war genau dass diese
gemäßigten und diese radikaleren teile
zusammen gefunden haben und damit
aufmerksamkeit auf der einen seite und
dann doch sein bemühen um eine gewisse
solidität auf der anderen seite und das
war auch die klare abgrenzung zu allen
rechtspopulistischen parteien die vorher
in deutschland versucht haben in die
parlamente zu kommen und wenn diese
erfolgsformel radikal und gemäßigt
aufgebrochen werden würde ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass die afd ihren
kurs so weiterfahren kann nicht ganz so
hoch aber das ist ja genau das wenn ich
das richtig verstanden habe was jack
morton gestern angekündigt hat was die
politik die er verfolgen würde ja das
sah so aus aber das wissen wir nicht so
genau was wirklich dahinter steht auf
welche bataillone er da setzen kann
weil nach unseren berechnungen würde
eine moderate partei arbeiten nicht mehr
auf 5 bis 7 prozent kommen und das
könnte nach seiner einschätzung
natürlich reichen um weiterhin
parlaments fähig zu sein und dann auch
an einzelnen positionen sogar das
zünglein an der waage werden zu können
[Musik]
die derzeitigen umfragen
die partei ja wirklich als es gibt eine
die sie bei 7 prozent andere bei neuen
oder elf prozent aber entfernt weit
entfernt von dem vorigen erfolgen und
dieser es um pragmatismus der der partei
dem vorstand die absolute sorgenfalten
erst gesichts raum absolut sie haben
jetzt in der korona krise etwa 30 40
prozent ihre zustimmung verloren
verglichen mit dem letzten jahr
und insofern ist eigentlich der job
eines parteivorsitzenden dass er
führungsstärke beweist das hat er
gestern versucht ob das die strategische
formel ist die den erfolg wieder
herbeiführt die erde ins feld geführt
dass wissen wir natürlich nicht das ist
offen es kann ja auch im koffer setzen
das macht das ganze mit der führung
unter umständen schwierig und dann gibts
auch die vor dem bundestag also die
fraktionsführung alice weidl alexander
gauland also das ist ja so triumvirat
also es ist wie bei allen parteien so es
gibt unterschiedliche flügel und
parteien sind koalitionen um in diesem
sinne müssen auch die führungspositionen
ausgewogen besetzt sein aber bei dieser
partei hat man schon den eindruck dass
sie nicht nur ausgewogen besetzt sind
sondern dass sie blockieren besetzt sind
dh die jeweils polaren positionen sind
nicht so dass sie wirklich innovativ
zusammenfinden sondern sie verharren
sehr in ihren ausgangspositionen und das
ist natürlich ein problem wenn man
vorankommen will wenn man auf neue
situationen reagieren möchte und die
korona situation ist ja eine neue
situation
anfangs war man auf seiten der regierung
dann hat man den kurs radikal gewechselt
und sieht sich jetzt mit einer neuen
lage konfrontiert dass nämlich die
mehrheit der eigenen mitglieder durchaus
gewillt sind die regierungsmaßnahmen für
angemessen zu halten und wenn man dann
den kurs weiter so scharf gegen korona
entwickelt kann das durchaus dazu führen
dass man nicht den rückenwind bekommt
den man sich erhofft wobei sich bei
krone da bewegt sich ja auch einiges
jetzt eben wieder so die neuen maßnahmen
die
die treiben auch wieder mehr die
kritiker nach vorne da muss man halt
schauen die partei herzlicher gestern
auch in sachen corona positioniert und
hat eben noch mal klar gesagt was wir
wollen und was wir nicht wollen wir
wollen natürlich keine eu corona bonns
das ist eigentlich zu erwarten von einer
partei wie der afd
aber ist auch nicht und vielleicht ist
das auch der der wirtschaftliche teil
dann ja auch nicht einverstanden damit
dass eben massive finanzielle hilfen
gezahlt werden auch sorge um die zukunft
deutschlands
aber das ist dass es nicht für jedes für
jede elf die sympathisanten oder wären
so eine gute anlage genau wenn man die
wählerschaft nimmt dann würde man ja
sagen die brauchen dringend
unterstützung weil die nicht zum besser
begüterten teil der gesellschaft zählen
und in dem chor ohne antrag war
eigentlich eine klare absage an einen
lastenausgleich und das würde man ja
eigentlich als sozial gerecht erwarten
wenn also in einer krise ist gewinner
und verlierer gibt dass man am ende dann
versucht die unterschiedlichen teile so
auszubalancieren dass es für die gesamte
gesellschaft eine faire lastenverteilung
gibt und da hat man sich gestern
dezidiert dagegen ausgesprochen das war
für uns als beobachter schon sehr
erstaunlich ja spannend für alle eine
partei die wie tilo kummer zum auftakt
gesagt hat die sich als partei der
arbeiter auch positionieren würde und
verstehen wenn also da ist noch viel
musik und findungsphase für die afd drin
und auch noch viel gesprächsstoff für
uns beide ärzte vielen dank professor
wieder an dieser stelle ich schaue
zurück zum parteitag noch ist er nicht
wirklich vollständig also wird sich
akkreditiert aber alexander keller hat
ein gesprächspartner ja der veranstalter
hat uns jetzt mitgeteilt es dauert noch
etwas weil corona bedingt noch nicht
alle durch die sicherheitskontrollen
also den crooner bedingt verschärften
sicherheitskontrollen gekommen sind
einer der die sicherheitskontrollen hin
kalkar bereits erfolgreich überwunden
hat ist jetzt bei uns jungen leuten der
parteivorsitzende die auch gestern schon
hier bei phoenix interviewt hatten das
war vor ihrer rede und die rede die sie
gestern gehalt haben gehalten haben die
zwingt uns geradezu sie nochmal zum
interview zu bitten
am morgen sind sie mit dem gestrigen tag
auch mit der reaktion auf ihre rede
zufrieden
ja ich wusste natürlich als ich die rede
geschrieben habe dass die
widersprüchliche und konträre reaktionen
auslösen wird das preist man einmal so
was mir erschien als notwendig und es
kam genau so wie ich es auch erwartet
hatte es gab missfallenskundgebungen es
gab aber deutlich mehr applaus
es gab am ende der rede viele die die
standen und und mehr applaudierten
es gab auch einige hielten ein karten
hoch die sich vielleicht auch getroffen
fühlten dadurch das ist so wenn man eine
rede hält die man vielleicht als als
brandrede einstufen kann
da kann man nicht erwarten dass einem
die ganze versammlung zujubelt das war
einen ordnungsruf an die partei der mehr
notwendig erschienen also hat er wohl
auch den nerv getroffen
teile der partei auch der
bundestagsfraktion sind ja von ihnen war
sie mit einer schimpfkanonade überzogen
worden um gebäude hieß es da
pubertierende schuljungen wäre das wort
corona diktatur in den mund nimmt der
verkennt dass wir keine diktatur haben
sonst gäbe es diesen parteitag gar nicht
dass hingegen alexander gauland der hier
kurz darauf im interview sagte er findet
diesen begriff völlig normal und
verfassungsgemäß haben sie das da
erreicht was wollen sie erreichen jetzt
auch mit den erfahrungen der letzten
woche im bundestag
ich möchte dass wir unsere anliegen in
einem angemessenen ton vorbringen sehr
hart in der sache aber verbindlich im
ton und nicht überdrehen weil ich glaube
dass wir mit dem überdrehen unsere
eigenen sache schaden und das möchte ich
vermeiden ich habe übrigens jetzt nicht
irgendwelche bundestagsabgeordneter
darum prahlerei bezichtigt darin meinte
ich andere die zum beispiel vor
funkhäusern dann drohen sie würden da
die redakteure rausholen oder sowas dann
völlig inakzeptables verhalten
sowas darf nicht sein das schadet
unserem ansehen als partei und wenn ich
da als bundessprecher meiner partei zu
schweigen
dann glaube ich werde ich meine aufgabe
nicht gerecht deswegen muss dann wenn es
eine verbreitete disziplinlosigkeit
gibt auch in ordnungsruf mal sein und
der musste nun mal ein bisschen
kräftiger ausfallen ich habe damit
meinen frieden und halte das für richtig
so gesprochen zu haben
sie haben von inkompatibler wortwahl
gesprochen dass es begriffe da unterwegs
sind die einfach auch mit unserer
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
unvereinbar sind ist der hintergrund
auch der dass sie regelrecht
muffensausen haben von einer beobachtung
durch den verfassungsschutz weil der ist
ja tot ja sozusagen wie ein
damoklesschwert über dem haupt der afd
ich glaube der verfassungsschutz ist das
kann man gar nicht übersehen heute eine
instrumentalisierte behörde die die
feste absicht hat uns unter beobachtung
zu stellen und das völlig unbegründete
maßen
dann dürfen wir aber nicht den fehler
machen den sozusagen noch argumente frei
haus zu liefern das ist das was ich hier
was ich moniere es ist nicht in
offenhausen vor dem verfassungsschutz
sondern ich sage lasst uns korrekt
agieren
lasst uns in der sache hart arbeiten
aber lasst uns im ton so sein dass er
unangreifbar sind dann machen wir unsere
sache gut wäre eine beobachtung ein
kollateralschaden für die afg denn da
werden ja besonders viele
parteimitglieder der afg betroffen
beamte und offiziere die sie ja in
überproportionaler weise auch als
mitglieder haben die ja ihn auch mit
fachlicher expertise in ihrer funktion
und partei aktivität bei stehen wäre das
ein richtiger aderlass das wäre dann ein
problem wenn die menschen die sie
ansprechen
jetzt aus angst weichen würden wenn wir
sagen würden um das ist uns unheimlich
wir gehen wir arbeiten dann natürlich
dagegen
weil wir unsere mitglieder auch
informieren was heißt das eigentlich
wenn es so kommen sollte und wir werden
natürlich mit allen rechtsmitteln
dagegen vorgehen und da wir recht haben
gehen wir auch davon aus dass wir uns da
in kurzer frist durchsetzen können nach
dem rausschmiss von andreas kalbitz hat
björn hatte ihr parteiinterner gegner
gesagt ich lasse mir von ihm also von
leuten noch nicht die partei kaputt
machen ist da nicht irgendwann mal das
finale duell fällig der oder ich also
wir müssen erst mal sehen wer ist björn
rücker
wie ein hecke ist der thüringische
landesvorsitzende und fraktionschef im
thüringischen landtag
er ist ja gar kein bundespolitiker also
solche töne habe ich von anderen
landesvorsitzenden noch nicht vernommen
das heißt ich lasse mir von von leuten
die partei nicht kaputt mein glaube dass
eine überhöhung seiner seiner funktion
ich habe persönlich x-fach aufgefordert
dann kandidiere doch für den
bundesvorstand
neben bundespolitische aufgaben war es
weder im bundesvorstand noch im
bundestag noch im konvent noch in der
bundesprogramm kommission
er engagiert sich nicht in bundes
fachausschüssen kurz ist ein reiner
landespolitiker da sollte er vielleicht
weil dann kein wenig flacher halten ist
aber trotzdem irgendwann mal die
spaltung unvermeidbar weil eben viele
positionen innerhalb der aktuellen afd
unvereinbar sinn da gibt es ja das
sprichwort lieber ein ende mit schrecken
als ein schrecken ohne ende
ich sehe das ganz anders wenn ich solche
reden halt wie gestern dann denken
einige der mann will spalten die
missverstehen mich aber gründlich und
wahrscheinlich wollen sie missverstehen
ich möchte das hier in einheit eine
schlagkräftige partei sind diese eherne
eine vitale oppositionsarbeit macht
gegen die katastrophale politik der
bundesregierung
dazu brauchen wir aber eine
geschlossenheit inhaltlich und auch im
auftritt und das meine ich an
es geht also gar nicht um spaltung sonst
geht darum die reihen zu schließen der
bundesvorstand hat gestern vorgestern
abend einen beschluss gefasst dass die
afg sich jetzt ganz besonders an die
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
halten wir die besonders in den fokus
nimmt ich dachte eigentlich dass das
schon immer grundlage der partei aber
das ist klingt ungefähr so als würde die
römische kurie verkünden sie wolle sich
jetzt besonders streng ans zölibat
halten warum oder welchen hintergrund
hatte gerade dieser beschluss im vorfeld
des parteitags und der
auseinandersetzungen die es gerade gibt
auch um ihre personen
das ist das ist schon eine grußbotschaft
an an verfassungsschutz ich sage es
wieder und wieder und wieder wir sind
rechtsstaatspartei wir stehen fest der
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
da gibt es aber leute die reden davon
und zwar verfassungsschutz leute die
reden von einem von einem verbot der afd
ohne jede grundlage unter tut es schon
mal klar zu machen
ihr lieben leute wir sind hier
rechtsstaatspartei wir haben die
verfassungsbrüche nicht zu verantworten
die verfassungsbrüche gehen von der
regierung aus nehmen sie die dir den
bruch von artikel 16a grundgesetz im
zuge der migrationspolitik nehmen sie
die multiple brüche der fall der der
europäischen verträge
das sind die eigentlichen vertragsbrüche
die wir haben und die haben nicht wir zu
verantworten
da müsste man hinschauen denn das ist
nicht verfassungskonform was da läuft
dann müsste man sich allerdings mit der
regierung beschäftigen und nicht mit uns
aber sie habe ja selbst gesagt dass
vieles was in der afg gerade passiert
eben auch nicht verfassungskonform nein
das habe ich nicht gesagt was würde ich
auch nicht sagen sondern ich sage wir
sollten eine wortwahl an den tag legen
die uns nicht angreifbar macht
und nehmen wir exemplarisch dem begriff
der der diktatur
da meine ich ist es richtig zu sagen wir
leben nicht in einer diktatur ich habe
das auch gestern schon mehrfach gesagt
die rede von herrn bauland im parlament
an frau merkel gerichtet fand ich
ausgezeichnet das war ein kräftiger und
das war ein wohl begründeter widerspruch
ein ausgezeichneter rede nicht auf wenn
man dann den begriff der korona diktatur
benutzt dann schafft man damit eine
durch die überzeichnung die darin liegt
eine angreifbarkeit die wir gar nicht
brauchen weil wir nämlich recht haben in
der sache aber es geht nicht um diktatur
es geht um ermächtigungsgesetz um
unsägliche historische vergleiche die
eben aber auch von funktions und
mandatsträgern der afg in den letzten
tagen und wochen zum besten gegeben
worden sind machen sie sich da nicht
besonders angreifbar nicht war nochmal
in dem falle der verfassungsschutz
beobachtung liefern sie nicht ihren
politischen gegnern die munition mit der
die dann relativ erfolgreich auf die afg
ballern können das ist das genau das was
ich gesagt habe
nehmen wir exemplarisch im begriff
ermächtigungsgesetz wenn sie sich jetzt
dass die neuerungen
infektionsschutzgesetz anschauen dann
kommt ja der begriff ermächtigung x-fach
vor
dann kann man daraus sagen das
historische vergleiche wenn man das aber
tut dann weiß jeder der diesen begriff
verwendet das ist notiert 1933 hitlers
machtergreifung ermächtigungsgesetz 33
und dann kommt dieser schräge zum schlag
daran dass es das problem dass es in der
tat eine ermächtigung ist die die
neuerungen
mit dem infektionsschutzgesetz
bestreitet kein mensch ich würde mit dem
begriff ermächtigungsgesetz wenn weil er
eben historisch so montiert ist und
damit wird ein vergleich dann schräg
denn in der tat bei allem was wir zu
kritisieren haben und ja wir haben
wirklich viel zu kritisieren eine
politik der regierung ist natürlich ein
vergleich mit der nazi zeit völlig
unangemessen und deswegen sollten wir
das auch nicht tun wollen sie mit ihrem
letzte frage wollen sie mit ihrem mit
ihrer strategie die afg koalitionsfähig
machen ich möchte dass wir in unserem
land eine große politische bedeutung
haben um den verhängnisvollen kurs der
regierung zu korrigieren
ich fürchte sehr dass wir im nächsten
jahr eine opposition wir werden absehbar
der bundestagswahl 21 in der opposition
bleiben weil es überhaupt nicht so weit
ist dass man koalieren könnte aber wenn
man politik macht wenn man politik auch
gestalten das geht auch noch
regierungsfunktion natürlich leichter
die frage stellt sich nur der zeitlich
aber wir müssen nun eine korrektur
einleiten denn wir haben nicht ewig zeit
wir werden für meine begriffe 21 eine
schwarz-grüne regierung bekommt dann
wird es noch schwieriger
dieses land wieder auf den vernünftigen
kurs zurückzuführen und da müssen wir
jetzt zunächst als vitaler opposition
gegen arbeiten das thema also
koalitionspartner erst dann wenn zum
beispiel führen hocke nicht mehr da sein
das hat das hat damit gar nichts zu tun
die frage stellt sich im moment auch
nicht wir werden uns nicht irgendwelchen
cdu oder spd oder grünen anbiedern um
irgendwie mitregieren zu können uns geht
es um eine kurskorrektur für dieses land
werden wir partner finden mit denen wir
das machen können und auch die stärke
dafür haben das tun zu können
dann wird sich die frage irgendwann
stellen das wird aber nicht jetzt seien
sogar direkten parteivorsitzender im
phoenix interview
danke dass sie da waren der parteitag
wird jetzt auch gleich beginnen und ich
gebe jetzt zunächst mal zu doris müller
weiter vielen dank alexander keller
wie sie sehen der saal füllt sich jetzt
so langsam ist ist aber immer noch nicht
so uns hätte der versammlungsleiter
sicherlich den parteitag beginnen lassen
dass die beschlussfähigkeit erreicht ist
sie wissen ja das quorum eine
beschlussfähigkeit muss auf jedem
parteitag gewährleistet sein also eine
gewisse
anzahl von mitgliedern muss im saal und
muss sich akkreditiert haben sodass die
beschlussfähigkeit einwandfrei und
zweifelsfrei nachgewiesen werden wird
und nachgewiesen werden kann sonst ist
jeder beschluss und jeder entscheidung
hinfällig weil sie damit anfechtbar ist
so wir haben gerade lange über jörg
mertens rede mit alexander keller und
ihm selbst das fazit und die analyse
hören können
das gibt uns jetzt noch mal die
gelegenheit zurückzublicken und
ausschnitte seiner rede zu zeigen
als wir uns kürzlich im bundesvorstand
gemeinsam darauf verständigten die
vertragsdauer für alle redner auf dem
parteitag recht eng zu begrenzen weil
ich damit sehr einverstanden denn es
gilt die knappe zeit eines parteitages
so effizient wie möglich zu nutzen
erst recht wenn er mit soviel
verspätungen unter so abenteuerlichen
bedingungen zustande kommt wie unser
heutiger sozial parteitag meine
ursprüngliche absicht war dann die die
rede dauer jedenfalls schwerpunktmäßig
für eine inhaltliche hinführung zu einer
befassung mit unserem schwerpunkt thema
dieses parteitages zu nutzen und vor
allem zu unseren ansätzen zu einer
modernisierten und zukunftsfesten
alternative sozialpolitik zu sprechen
das werde ich nun heute aber anders
halten weil dieses thema zwar in der tat
höchst wichtig ist und ich mich auch in
der tat sehr freue dass wir in diesen
tagen
diese noch offene stelle unseres
parteiprogramms endlich werden schließen
können aber es gibt und ich muss sagen
leider noch wichtigeres wie ich meine zu
ihnen sprechen zu müssen
darum hier jetzt nur einführend ganz
kurze anmerkungen zur leitantrag und
ergänzenden anträgen der hier in
nachfolgende tagesordnungspunkte
eingebrachte leitantrag zur
sozialpolitik ist das ergebnis uns sehr
viel vorarbeit in den landes und bundes
fachausschüssen und in der bundes
programmkommission wer dabei war weiß
dass das vorliegende papier
das ergebnis eines langen ringens um die
richtige positionierung ist
alle beteiligten mussten hier über ihren
schatten springen
und die zustimmung zum finalen entwurf
hat mancher nur mit der einen oder
vielleicht sogar mit zwei fäusten in der
tasche machen können aber so ist das
wesen der politik in der demokratie nie
setzt sich die position des einen voll
durch das gibt es nur in diktaturen
es ist immer auch kompromiss und wer
dazu nicht fähig ist der sollte es
gleich lassen
ich würde es kurz machen als wir uns in
der bundesprogramm kommission im februar
final aber doch mit überwältigender
mehrheit geeinigt hat man vielleicht
mancher wunsch offen geblieben
aber wir konnten einander die hände
schütteln und sagen diesen leitantrag
können wir so dem bundesparteitag als
arbeitsergebnis doch gemeinsam
vorschlagen
und das geschieht nun heute mit mehr als
einem halben jahr corona bedingte
verzögerungen
details zum leitantrag wird ihnen
albrecht glaser vorstellen
von meiner seite möchte ich ihnen sagen
dass sich selbst diesen antrag mittragen
und ihnen zur heutigen annahme empfehle
vielleicht noch ergänzt oder verändert
und den einen oder anderen antrag dass
wir die weitere diskussion dieses
parteitages zeigen ich freue mich auch
dies sicherlich lebhafte diskussion auch
mancher weitere anträge
das ist die wertvolle inhaltliche arbeit
die uns weiterbringt was geschieht denn
hier vorne jetzt gerade nun
einen antrag möchte ich mir erlauben
ihrer geschätzten aufmerksamkeit ganz
besonders zu empfehlen ist er wach
antrag l&s 1 eingebracht von einer
ganzen reihe von delegierten
so auch von mir selbst entwickelt von
rené springer der vorstellen wird mit
dem ich zu diesem thema schon etliche
sehr fruchtbarer fachliche gespräche
geführt habe
hier geht es um die schaffung der
möglichkeit einer wohlgemerkt erprobung
eines neuen sozialpolitischen instrument
auf der basis eines bedingten nicht etwa
bedingungslosen grundeinkommens mit dem
zugleich eine lange liste bisheriger
sozialpolitischer und höchst
bürokratische instrumente der
bestehenden sozialgesetzbücher komplett
ersetzt werden könnte ich bin mir sicher
wir werden auch dazu eine sehr
interessante und lebhafte diskussion
führten nun zu dem
nun zu dem was sich für unsere partei in
ihrer derzeitigen phase als sogar noch
gravierender erachte hat sie die
sozialpolitischen reformen überlegungen
liebe freunde seien wir bitte ehrlich
miteinander und legen wir auch darin den
mut so weit an den tag den wir uns doch
aus gutem grund auf die fahnen
geschrieben haben
wenn wir das tun und einmal einen blick
von außen auf unsere partei werfen
dann sind wir nach inzwischen sieben
jahren einer in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik deutschland einmaligen
erfolgsgeschichte nun an einem punkt
angelangt an dem es nicht mehr
automatisch immer weiter nach oben geht
und sich wahlerfolg an war erfolgreich
erstmals müssen wir sogar breitere front
gewahr werden dass alle unsere
bisherigen erfolge mit denen wir die
altparteien aufgemischt haben wie es
niemandem vor uns gelungen ist nun
gefährdet sind wie noch nie ein punkt an
dem wir wenn wir es falsch angehen alle
unsere erfolge virtuellen nicht nur
nicht ausbauen oder wenigen bewahren
können sondern an dem auch noch alles
kaputt gehen kann
und das liegt nun wahrlich nicht an
unseren politischen gegnern
die sind von der merkel union über fdp
und spd bis zu den sogenannten grünen
mindestens so schwach und vor den
problemen unserer zeit erkennbar
versagen wie eh und je im grunde
genommen sogar mehr denn je
in einer solchen phase müssen wir
eigentlich punkten unter zugewinn an
politischem einfluss
stattdessen droht aktuell seien wir
ehrlich eher das gegenteil
wollen wir das abstellen und ändern
wollen wir also zurück auf die
erfolgsspur müssen wir uns die frage
nach den gründen dafür warum es nicht
weiter aufwärtsgeht ehrlich beantworten
tun mir dass liebe freunde
und da sage ich es machen sich einige
vom einfachen mitglied bis in die
führungsriege der zeit leider etwas zu
einfach
die fehlende einheit und geschlossenheit
sei schuld die fehle
und deshalb müssen wir nur alle zusammen
verstehen und dann wäre schwupps das
problem gelöst
klingt plausibel ist aber ich sagen dass
cloud deutlich so einfach einheit in was
denn eine echte nicht nur gespielte
einheit besteht immer in einer
hinlänglich in summe an inhaltlichen
gemeinsamkeiten als elementare
grundvoraussetzung
erstens also
[Applaus]
erstens gemeinsamkeiten in inhaltlichen
positionen die bestehe nicht nur darin
die inhaltlichen positionen der
politischen gegner aus vielerlei sehr
guten gründen für grundfalsch zu halten
sondern eben auch darin was man dem
entgegensetzen will als echte
alternative
und da reicht es nicht sich
wechselseitig zu versichern
man sei konservativ da liege doch
bereits die gemeinsamkeit das ist so
einfach denn das kann im grips
verständnis vieles heißen einige in
unseren reihen scheinen darunter ein
zurück ins gestern zu verstehen
fühlen sich bei bismarck zu hause und
waren geradezu schwärmerisch diese
historische figur wie propagieren dann
sozialpolitisch so eine art bismarck
einen 20 als lösung der heutigen
wirtschafts und sozialpolitischen
probleme des landes
das mag romantisch sein
und es gibt sicher allerlei gründe sich
diese oder jene gute zeit unserer
nationalen vergangenheit zurück zu
wünschen
andere ganz und gar nicht das wissen
gerade wir deutschen
aber es ist vor allem etwas zukunft
blind mit den rezepten von vorgestern
sind die politischen lösungen von morgen
nämlich nicht zu gestalten
[Applaus]
schon gar nicht schon gar nicht
angesichts einer ungeheuren dynamik
einer sich in atemberaubender
geschwindigkeit digitalisieren lebens
und arbeitswelt die afg liebe freunde
ist keine rückwärtsgewandte partei
aber sie darf auch keine solche sein
will wie eine erfolgreiche politische
zukunft haben das gestern ist vergangen
und wird nicht wiederkommen
es geht in der politik allein um die
gestaltung der rahmenbedingungen eines
guten morgen für unsere kinder und enkel
der moderne konservative ist deswegen
niemals reaktionär
er versucht vor allem eines gut und
richtig erkannt das wertesystem wichtige
und elementare gesellschaftliche
tugenden wie fleiß eigenverantwortung
ehrlichkeit anstand respekt und auch
demut auf das um vermeintlich neue zu
übertragen
damit seien sie versichert haben wir
mehr als genug zu tun in all diese
tugenden drohen in dem von mir schon in
stuttgart 2016 als links rot grün für
768 architekten zeitgeist
unwiederbringlich verloren zu gehen
übrigens auch wie sollte es anders sein
in den eigenen reihen
denn letztlich sind auch wenn wir
ehrlich sind auch wir ein spiegelbild
einer sich wandelnden gesellschaft und
dann beginnt es nun schmerzhaft zu
werden und ich wünschte ich müsste
einige der nachfolgenden dinge lieber
nicht ansprechen aber es erscheint mir
zwingend ich halte das für notwendig
gelebte einheit liebe freunde verlangt
zweitens eben nicht nur eine hinreichend
hohe gemeinsamkeit an inhaltlichen
positionen sondern auch an sozialen
verhaltensweisen und gemeinsame oder
jedenfalls kompatiblem sprachgebrauch
und ist das nicht vorhanden dann wird
die forderung nach einheit und
zusammenhalt zur leeren worthülse oder
schlimmer noch geradezu zu einer pseudo
moralischen erpressung
wissen sie wer sich erst in wort oder
handeln tüchtig daneben benimmt um dann
aber sogleich die solidarität der ganzen
partei mit diesem verhalten einzufordern
versucht parteimitglieder in eine
kollektivhaftung für das eigene
fehlverhalten zu nehmen
und ich halte
ich halte es für indiskutabel dass dann
als ein verlangen nach vermeintlich
unabdingbare einheit zu bezeichnen nein
liebe freunde ich will hier ganz
deutlich sein lassen wir ruhig die im
regen stehen die zu einem die nur allzu
gerne rum krakeelen und rump rollen oder
auch andere dazu einladen wie wir das
vergangene woche leider im bundestag
erleben mussten weil sie sich in der
rolle des provokateurs gefallen wie
projektieren de schulung und vor allem
der eigenen überschaubaren blase zeigen
zu wollen was für tolle kerle sie doch
sind verweigern wir diesen leuten die
den geschlossenheit
[Applaus]
wir uns bitte gemeinsam bewusst wegen
solcher vorkommnisse wählen uns scharen
von menschen dann nicht mehr die uns
bislang gewählt haben
das sind menschen die fast schon
verzweifelt nach einer guten alternative
zu den altparteien suchen die sie nur zu
gerne in uns sehen möchten aber wegen
der einen oder anderen entgleisungen
dann eben nicht mehr können wir werden
nicht mehr erfolg erzielen nehmen wir
immer aggressiver immer der aber immer
enthemmte auftreten so geht das nicht
im gegenteil liebe freunde so verlieren
wir die vielen menschen wir uns auf der
suche nach einer vernünftigen
alternativen zum ganzen politischen
irrsinn der merkelschen politik zu gerne
ihr vertrauen schenken würden das genau
deswegen dann aber nicht mehr können was
wir mehr als alles andere brauchen ist
innerparteiliche disziplin
[Applaus]
dazu gehört und tadellos verhalten aller
funktionäre und auch einfache mitglieder
vom parlament bis zum straßenstand dazu
gehört auch eine die probleme glasklaren
ende aber zugleich nicht überzeichnen in
der sache gerecht werden der wortwahl
nehmen wir exemplarisch wie cobit 19
krise und unseren umgang damit
es ist gut richtig und absolut zwingend
notwendig dass wir der gesamten
regierung ihren zu teilen geradezu
unglaublich dilettantischen umgang mit
der krise zum vorwurf machen dass wir
aufzeigen dass merkels söders und
sparpolitik in vielen eben gerade nicht
wie behauptet angemessenen zum gar nicht
verhältnismäßig ist und es ist richtig
wenn wir sagen dass die partielle
außerkraftsetzung von grundrechten nicht
hinnehmbar ist wenn sie eben nicht
zwingend ist
dazu darf man auch kräftige worte der
kritik verwenden verbunden vor allem
auch mit dem konkreten aufzeigen der
fehler und mit eigenen vorschlägen
jemandes stattdessen besser machen
sollte aber ich frage mich ist es
wirklich klug von einer corona diktatur
zu sprechen
wir leben in keiner diktatur sonst
könnten in diesem parteitag heute wohl
nachkommen so abhalten und die
behauptung es sei anders stellt im
grunde die systemfrage und bringt uns
ohne jede not in ein fahrwasser
das ist massiv existenziell gefährdet
und die durch dadurch die darin liegende
maßlosigkeit bei vielen menschen
kopfschütteln auslöst
[Applaus]
und ist es klo geht weiß dass ich damit
dass ich damit auch wieder zur ernte ist
es denn klug wenn sich alle funktionäre
ohne jede kritische distanz mit der
sogenannten querdenker bewegung
kritiklos gemein machen sagen wir
engagieren sich bekanntermaßen und ich
will dass konzedieren neben ganz
normalen besorgten und ihrer besorgnis
ausdruck verleihen wollen den bürgern ja
die sind da aber da engagieren sich auch
nicht ganz wenige zeitgenossen und
skurrile zum teil auch offen system
feindliche positionen und ansicht den
verdacht nahelegen dass bei ihnen
tragischerweise noch nicht mal das
gerade ausdenken richtig funktioniert
geschweige denn echtes querdenken
was was zeichnet denn das für ein bild
von unserer partei wenn einige von uns
da jede distanz vermissen lassen und die
üblichen medien sich begierig in ihrer
einseitigen berichterstattung darauf
stürzen und ist es klug mit der ganz
gezielten verwendung des begriffes
ermächtigungsgesetz in verbindung mit
der natürlich hart zu kritisieren
veränderung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
zu hantieren und damit auch ganz bewusst
assoziationen an die ns-zeit und hitlers
machtergreifung 33 zu wecken sollten
sich sollten sich solche vergleiche
angesichts der allgemein bekannten
monstrosität und in dieser dimension
auch singularität der nazibarbarei nicht
eigentlich von selbst verbieten weil da
nämlich eine implizite verharmlosung der
grauenhaften und daten jener finsteren
zeit liegt ja meine damen und herren und
an dieser stelle verlassen wir die
gestrige rede von jörg leuten und kommen
zu den live bildern und eben den saal
wir hören gerade im hintergrund
vielleicht wenn sie das mit derart nur
noch dass der sicherheitshinweis nochmal
erfolg zum einhalten der abstands und
hygieneregeln
der versammlungsleiter julian fleig hat
offensichtlich ein zeichen bekommen dass
die beschlussfähigkeit hergestellt wurde
ich will ihnen aber während wir diese
bilder hier noch sehen
von den delegierten die sich jetzt
langsam an ihre plätze gegeben
eine meldung nicht vorenthalten wonach
der vorsitzende der fdp
bundestagsfraktion alexander gauland
nach angaben von parteifreunden heute
morgen den parteitag verlassen hat aber
nicht weil er die politische dimension
oder die politischen inhalte nicht mehr
ertragen kann oder wie auch immer es
geht um einen gesundheitstag schon er
fühle sich nicht gut bestätigte er der
deutschen presse-agentur sei aber nichts
ernstes nach angaben aus parteikreisen
verließ alexander gauland das gelände
mit einem krankenwagen in begleitung von
zwei fahrzeugen mit berliner kennzeichen
wir wünschen an dieser stelle alles gute
gute besserung für alexander gauland und
denken dass jetzt in einigen sekunden
der versammlungsleiter julian fleig den
parteitag an einem zweiten tag eröffnen
wird
ja sie sehen auf dem podium dass der
bundesvorstand fast komplett bereits an
seinem sitzplatz sitzt sie sehen dass
die delegierten in den tischen oder an
den tischen platz genommen haben und sie
sehen dass an dem platz an dem alexander
gauland sitzen sollte eben der platz zur
zeit leer ist wir hoffen dass es nichts
schlimmes ist er hatte er am samstag
alexander dem ersten tag scharfe kritik
an der rede des parteivorsitzenden geübt
ja wie sie sehen der saal füllt sich
immer mehr das kann absolut nicht mehr
lange dauern dass julian fleig der
versammlungsleiter den zweiten parteitag
starten lässt
und das gibt mir die gelegenheit nochmal
zu erwähnen gestern hat es ja die wahl
beziehungsweise die wahlen schon gegeben
es wurde ein neuer schatzmeister
gefunden um gefahren in einer minute
fort und ich höre gar den hintergrund
julian fleig erzählt hat dass eine
minute der parteitag beginnt und als
ergänzung nur noch es wurde ein neuer
bundesschatzmeister kassenhüter gewählt
es wurde eine neue beisitzerinnen
gewählt die hatte mein kollege alexander
kähler heute vormittag schon ihnen im
interview vorgestellt und es wurde ein
stellvertretender bundesschatzmeister
rote folie und jetzt geht's los
ford ich darf sie ganz herzlich am
ersten advent ihr in kalkar begrüßen
auch diejenigen die vielleicht dazu
gekommen sind
es gab etwas verzögerung am einlass das
hängt damit zusammen dass wir auch
draußen auf muss das sicherheitsabstände
eingehalten werden
außerdem ist wie immer an einem zweiten
tag auch ein wenig nach akkreditierung
vorzunehmen
wir steigen gleich wieder in die
tagesordnung ein vorweg habe ich für sie
die informationen dass die anträge sn 1
antragsteller war da der landesvorstand
berlin ablauf rhetorische fragen und der
antrag sn zwei stichwort blaue ader
deutschland vom antragsteller
zurückgezogen wurden
diese beiden werden wir sie nicht
behandeln nachher sondern die sind
zurückgezogen
da ging es um die digitalisierung und
umweltfragen verfahren das können sie
bekommen gerne auf der bühne
auch das ist üblich bei parteitagen das
geschäftsordnungsanträge gestellt werden
die nach hoffentlich dem verfahren
ablaufen abgeschlossen und würden danach
gleich weitermachen noch ist kein club
aufgerufen
zum verfahren herr boote bitte sagen die
zuerst kurz was der inhalt des
verfahrens antrags den ist bevor sie
ihnen begründen sie haben das wort bitte
schön ja wie dank herford cdu
parteifreunde ich beantrage den sach
antrag sn 3 auf heute morgen vorzuziehen
ich möchte das begründen die begründung
ist ja da es sich ganz kurz ein antrag
auf jetzt vorzuziehen ist eine nicht
zulässige antrag also ich hatte das
gesprochen er vorsitzender natürlich
kann man einen tagesordnungspunkt
vorziehen
das ist ja das ist das ist was anderes
naja und am ort zu ziehen auch
vorzuziehen heute morgen also das
begründen
ich möchte ganz kurz ganz kurz erst
einmal horst führen was sie dort
beantragen weil sie beantragen dann den
den gesamten also den gesamten top sach
anträge vorzuziehen und auch das
vorziehen eines punktes ist nach
beschlussfassung über die tagesordnung
in dieser form nicht zulässig das
müssten sie
ich sags mal so etwas geschickter machen
wir haben das der vergangenheit auch
schon macht sie können
da gebe ich gerne hilfestellung sie
können natürlich beantragen dass wir
jetzt alle tops einmal aufrufen und dann
in diesen jobs nur jeweils keine
beschlussfassung vornehmen aber das
bräuchte ich dann tatsächlich bitte in
textform das haben wir vergangenheit
auch so gehabt habe ich erinnere an die
maßnahmen die notwendig waren um den
doktor bauland in korrekter form zum
ehrenvorsitzenden zu wählen auf dem
letzten parteitag ist es gewesen sein
ich brauche seinen antrag was genau ist
sie können nicht einfach nur beantragen
tag vorzuziehen
sobald die tag warum beschlossen ist ist
das ein unzulässiger antrag aber wie
gesagt hilfestellung gerade gegeben dass
bitte einmal kurz rein herrmann
wir haben jetzt als nächsten punkt die
rechnungsprüfer da
kriegen wir das sicherlich schnell
denkbar
ja das war ein antrag in dem es darum
geben dass dieser berühmte sn 3 in dem
es um die vorwürfe gegen jörg merten
geht dass er spielerisches gebaren an
den tag legte direkt jetzt zu beginn des
zweiten tages behandelt werden sollen
geplant ist ja diesen antrag zusammen
mit den anderen sachanträgen so ist der
formale begriff erst am schluss des
parteitages wenn über die bundes
befinden über den rechenschaftsbericht
und wenn über die satzung und
wahlordnung gesprochen wurde ganz am
schluss zu behandeln
man könnte das verfahren oder das den
geo antrag natürlich insoweit etwas
interpretieren als dass die debatte um
jörg leuten vor dem hintergrund der
dynamik seiner rede die er gestern
gehalten hat indem er kritik geübt hat
an verschiedenen funktionären in dieser
partei und vor allen dingen kritik an
funktionären in abgeordneten im
deutschen bundestag von der afg als
überraschungs coup gelandet werden soll
indem man jetzt sofort darüber abstimmen
zu einem zeitpunkt der mit sicherheit
unerwartet sein soll
offensichtlich wird jetzt per radschlag
ob dieser geschäftsordnungsantrag
zulässig ist oder nicht und inwieweit
damit verfahren werden soll
noch ist nicht klar julian fleig der
versammlungsleiter hat dies erst mal
nicht zugelassen im verfahren für den
beschluss der tagesordnung
fakt war ja dass die tagesordnung
gestern bereits in veränderter form
abgestimmt wurde und vom parteitag auch
abgesegnet wurde
jetzt geht es nur darum ob dieser
geschäftsordnungsantrag zulässig ist und
ob darüber abgestimmt werden soll ja
oder nein
und da mein satzungs wissen mit
sicherheit nicht das level von den
versammlungsleiter julian flackert von
der afg müssen wir einfach abwarten
inwieweit sich das gremium das sich da
oben gerade ein podium versammelt hat
entscheidet
fakt es nur es gibt offensichtlich eine
debatte
so wir haben dann den antrag hier
mittlerweile in textform vorliegen
und bevor wir dann gehen wir erst ein
geschäftshaus einfach der geht vorher
verletzung am mikrofon bitteschön die
einlasskontrolle noch etliche delegierte
draußen stehen und wir noch nicht
weiterführen können solange nicht alle
die möglichkeit haben wir endlich
abzustimmen und mitzudiskutieren
also ich hätte ihr chef von uns antrag
kurze unterbrechung bis ein großteil von
delegierten zumindest drin sind
dankeschön bestimmtheit wir brauchen
müssen sagen wie lange sie unterbrechen
so wir müssen wissen für wie lange wir
unterbrechen wir müssen dann können sich
andere bedingungen die wir von hier aus
nicht direkt sehen können anknüpfen
immer sagen wir mal 30 minuten weil der
erste reguläre zeit ja ist mir egal wie
nah wir wollen auch nach hause aber wir
müssen ihn delegiert die möglichkeit
bieten bieten dass er sich mit
einbringen können und durch die
kontrollen können sich leider nicht gut
daran einen geschäftsordnungsantrag auf
unterbrechung des parteitags für 30
minuten
und dass sie eine gegenrede zu ebenfalls
im blauen saal mikrofon bildschirm ja
guten morgen liebe kollegen ich war hier
um 9 uhr 15 völlig unproblematisch liebe
leute wenn ihr erst alle frühstück geht
und dann gleichzeitig jeden kommt können
wir www hier um neun uhr 59 sind nichts
dafür deshalb lasst uns jetzt weiter
machen und dem parteitag ordentlich
weiterführen wir haben jetzt hat
diszipliniert gearbeitet deshalb bitte
ich um ablehnung dieses
geschäftsordnungsantrag vielen dank sie
habe den geschäftsordnungsantrag ohne
gegenrede gehört wir kommen zur
abstimmung wenn sie den
geschäftsordnungsantrag folgen möchten
und jetzt für eine halbe stunde den
parteitag unterbrechen möchten bitte ich
sie um handzeichen mit der blauen karte
dankeschön wer das nicht möchte bitte
die rote karte
dankeschön enthaltung dann ist der
antrag abgelehnt und wieder hat sich
dennis lang ohne unterbrechung weiter in
schriftform sogar vorliegen der da
lautet dass die top 12 13 14 15 16 17
und 18 immer der reihe nach aufgerufen
werden dann offen gelassen werden immer
zum nächsten und dann der tod 19
aufgerufen wird das im top 19
der antrag sn drei behandelt wird und
wir danach den tages und kommt ebenfalls
offen lassen und zurück im top 12 gehen
und zur begründung des antrags erhält
für drei minuten maximal das wort
verbote bildschirm
vielen dank liebe parteifreunde worum
geht es sollte man gestern hat leuten
mit seiner rede die grundfeste dieser
partei erschüttern
und da ist es doch unsere pflicht als
parteitag diese rede zur diskussion zu
stellen
gestern hatte ermorden unsere partei die
bundestagsfraktionen unseren ehren von
sitzen am ende auch noch bismarck
angegriffen
hier darf der parteitag nicht
unwidersprochen das hinnehmen
daher gilt es diesen top aufzurufen ich
will mich gar nicht mit dem
antragsteller hier gemein machen
es wird ein änderungsantrag aus
brandenburg aber wir als partei müssen
wir heute ein zeichen setzen dass wir
dieses diese gilt diese rede von
erneuten so nicht stehen lassen müssen
und die sie zurückwerfen
vielen dank
stephan bothe der stellvertretende
landesvorsitzende von niedersachsen gmbh
rechten seite in der afc zuzuordnen
roten doch im roten saal mikrofon
bitteschön ist keiner dann am blauen
bitte schön so was kunst ist mein name
ich beantrage den antrag von der
tagesordnung zu nehmen ist nicht weniger
spalterisch als die rede von mulden
gestern ganz im gegenteil
also das ist ein antrag auf
nichtbefassung herkunft so bleiben sie
ganz kurz also die müssen kurz das ist
sie können kein antrag von der
tagesordnung nehmen aber sie können
nicht nur aus mit einem antrag der
antrag nichts zur fassung beantrage ich
hiermit mit dem antrag sn 3 gibt es dazu
eine gegenrede ebenfalls am blauen
mikrofon
die gegenrede zu dem antrag nicht
befassung mit dem unser landrat sn 3 ich
sage kurzes verfahren hatten dazu dass
wenn der antrag entfällt dann die frage
stellt ob der verfahren anfang noch
sinnvoll ist aber das ist eine andere
frage der würde sich dann vermutlich
erledigt haben
frau bis sieben bildschirme ja vielen
dank eine gegenrede bezieht sich darauf
dass unser landesvorstand brandenburg
gestern einen änderungsantrag zu sm-3
eingereicht hat wer sich mit der
thematik beschäftigt wie verbote ist
gerade beschrieben hat ich möchte daran
erinnern dass frau total gestern abend
dem parteitag damit beendet hat unsere
partei muss sympathischer werden und
deswegen liebe freunde werde ich dafür
dass wir sympathischer werden und
deswegen in zukunft solche reden nicht
mehr
diskutieren und eine aussprache zu
dieser rede durchführen vielen dank das
war eine
gegenrede zum abend fest nicht befahren
inflations vorsitzende
das ist dieser tag damit nicht gefasst
wer diesen antrag seine zustimmung
erteilen möchte bin ich um die blaue
stimmkarte die entschuldigung das war
eine falsche geschichten einander in
berlin passieren gehört eben zu fd in
brandenburg gegen gegenstimmen wieder
roten das machen wir mit elektronisch
vergessen ist stellvertretender
landesvorsitzender von bioland 3 wir
haben derweil einen aktuellen
akkreditierung stand erwartet uns zwar
sind um 11 uhr 11 483 stimmberechtigte
delegierte akkreditiert gewesen
vielen dank sodann für die dauer der
abstimmung darf bitte keiner mehr in den
saal wir haben sie haben ihre geräte mit
der einst können sie für nichtbefassung
stimmen mit der 2 können sie gegen
nichtbefassung stimme der nummer drei
können sie sich enthalten abstimmung ist
eröffnet für 30 sekunden bitteschön ja
dann kommen wir jetzt hier schon zur
ersten spannenden abstimmung in dem es
darum geht ob um die person des bundes
sprechers jörg nolte ist eine debatte
gibt oder eben auch nicht
sprechen wir gleich mal wieder ab
während der unterbrechung allerdings
bitte die tür geschlossen halten wir
sind einen weiteren gleichen wagen
einmal abbrechen weil es dort ein
problem in einem gerät gibt bitte hinten
einmal austauschen
es wird jetzt während während bis ich
jetzt sage wird niemand wieder in den
saal gelassen wir sind immer noch in der
abstimmung wir uns nur aus technischen
gründen einmal reset in ein neues gerät
ausgegeben
[Musik]
normalerweise läuft die abstimmung im
elektronischen verfahren bei der afg
fast immer reibungslos und ab und zu
gibt es jetzt wie hier ein kleiner
hänger dann ist in irgendeiner art und
weise die software überlastet oder muss
neu reset werden aber in der regel
klappen diese elektronischen
abstimmungsverfahren einwandfrei hier
bei dieser partei und bei diesen
parteitagen die ich jetzt in den
vergangenen jahren schon erlebt habe wo
ist das gerät schon ausgetauscht
ja gut kann dann kannst du dann losgehen
dann mit einem neuen wird die folie
einmal alles auf null stellen folie
wieder einblenden
mit der einst nichtbefassung oder 2
gegen die nichten fassung dem antrag
sn 3 das ist der antrag missbilligung
leuten nicht einfacher mit 1 gegen die
nichtbefassung mit der 2 und die drei
ist dann die enthaltung 30 sekunden die
abstimmung bitte jetzt eröffnen
ja 483 delegierte befinden sich im saal
das hat der mitarbeiter oder nein nicht
bei dem mitarbeiter sondern der der in
der crew für das quorum zuständig ist er
die versammlungen leitet und diesen
parteitagsregie die pathos regie
übernahm übernommen hat gesagt das heißt
sie sind beschlussfähig auch finden dann
warten wir auf die abstimmung und auch
das ergebnis 2 1 und dann die abstimmung
bitte schließen und ein ergebnis
einblenden
sodann ist der antrag auf nichtbefassung
abgelehnte geschäftsordnungsantrag das
heißt wir kommen jetzt zum verfahrens
antrag
das dürfte der erste leichte
genickschlag für die augen sein denn
dann muss ich nur seiner person und
seinem politischen inhalten in den
vergangenen monaten und für einen
gestern mittlerweile wieder verantworten
und wir haben einen antrag zur
geschäftsordnung herr lexam blauen
mikrofon bitte danke schön also es ist
ja eben glaube ich deutlich geworden
worum es hier geht
es geht darum das ist eben von den
anträgen haben ja auch gesagt von sie
haben eben ja im grunde schon eine
vorentscheidung getroffen indem sie
gesagt haben sie wollen sich damit
beschäftigen
ich glaube wir müssen jetzt nicht noch
lange darüber diskutieren ob wir darüber
diskutieren wollen sondern das abstechen
antrag auf direkte abstimmung gar dazu
zu dem antrag der eben von der boote
gestellt ist dass wir das heute
entsprechend vorziehen und die
diskussion hier abbrechen da kommen wir
weiter voran im tag und können es dann
unter dem geschäftsordnungs punkt inhalt
nicht dazu austauschen das wollen wir
jetzt nicht machen
dankeschön
[Applaus]
also zuallererst einmal werden wir
mindestens eine gegenrede verfahrens
anfang an nicht schlechter behandelt was
einen geschäftsordnungsantrag gleich zu
lassen
aber erst einmal eine ansonsten ist
einfach aber zusätzlich eine gegenrede
bitte zu den geschäftsordnungsantrag
ebenfalls am frauen seien betroffen
ja vielen dank ich glaube dass eine
beträchtliche anzahl der personen die
den nichtbefassung abgelehnt haben das
getan haben weil sie der auffassung sind
dass dieses thema diskutiert werden
sollte aber nicht weil sie der
auffassung sind dass dem antrag
zuzustimmen ist und deshalb sollte man
auf jeden fall jetzt die diskussion zu
lassen
ich bitte euch danke sehr so dann lassen
wir eine gegenrede zu zudem verfahrens
antrag dann kommen wir würden gleich den
auf jeden fall eine gegen jetzt
verfahrens antrag zu lassen wir kommen
jetzt zur abstimmung über den
geschäftsordnungsantrag auf ende der
debatte zum verfahrens antrag danach
würde verfahren antrag abgestimmt werden
ja wenn sie diesen geschäften man
annehmen darf nur eine gegenrede zu dann
kommen wir zur abschiebeverfahrens
antrag und dann je nach dem wie dort
entschieden wird geht es dann weiter
wenn sie diesen ablehnen dann läuft die
diskussion sowieso ganz normal zum
verfahrens antrag weiter dass sie wissen
worüber sie abstimmen
eine gegenrede am blauen saal mikrofon
gibt es jemanden wir hatten doch gerade
eine gegenrede gegen den geo antrag hat
pardon gerade selbst in den gedanken
gegen einmal gefangen also wir kommen
bestimmt jetzt möglichen
geschäftsordnungsantrag von der dr
blacks auf ende der debatte wer für eine
debatte ist bittet die bauer stimmkarte
gegenrede gegenstimmen mit der roten
karte
das machen wir die elektronisch
ende der debatte zum verfahren antrag
das ist ein geo antrag wichtig sodann
wird er die tür schließen und dann
können sie mit der einst für ende der
debatte stimmen mit der zwei dagegen
wieder drei können sich enthalten
dann bitte frei geben sie haben 30
sekunden ab jetzt so nochmal zur
klarstellung der parteitag stimmt jetzt
gerade darüber ab ob sie die debatte
über das neue verfahren dass stephan
bothe vorhin vorgestellt hat zum thema
sn 3 also zur kritik an jörg meuten ob
dieses debatten verfahren eingestellt
werden muss soll oder nicht
und danach geht es darum ob das
verfahren dass stephan bothe vorgestellt
hat so vom parteitag abgestimmt und
beschieden wird oder nicht aber erst mal
geht es um das ende der debatte 10 dann
bitte die abstimmung schließen und ein
ergebnis einblenden
das ende der debatte beschlossen wie
gesagt es wird eine gegenrede zu dem
verfahren antrag noch zugelassen das war
so angekündigt wenn es denn eine gibt an
einem der balkone das ja wohl mikrofon
ja mein name ist henning dornauf
nordrhein-westfalen rheinisch bergischer
kreis vorneweg ich bin ein großer fan
des reichskanzlers von bismarck
aber ich finde es absolut in farm dass
hier ein antrag aufgebaut wird in dem
unsere unserem sprecher herrn professor
meuten unterstellt wird er hätte in
irgendeiner art und weise die leistung
des reichskanzlers von bismarck arab
gewürdigt den mann wurde hervor wunder
rumgedreht
vielen dank wir kommen dann jetzt zur
abstimmung über den verfahrens antrag
von herrn rothe die top zwölf bis
achtzehn aufzurufen
ohne inhaltliche behandlungen offen zu
lassen und dann im top 19 den aufzurufen
den sach antrag sn drei zu behandeln und
danach zurück zu springen in den top 12
und mit einer ganz normalen tagesordnung
fortzufahren wer diesen verfahrens
antrag seine zustimmung erteilen manche
bitte um die blaue stimmkarte
gegenstimmen mit der roten karte
das wird etwas harmonisches elektronisch
sehen sie bestätigen kommt gerade vom
versammlungsleiter auch das sieht knapp
aus so wie auch gerade vorhin in der
ersten abstimmung um die frage soll
überhaupt über diesen antrag
rsn 3 also kritik an jörg nolte
debattiert werden ja oder nein sie haben
gesehen die entscheidung war denkbar
knapp das heißt wir haben wirklich eine
fast 50 50 prozentige auslastung hier in
für und wider auf diesem parteitag
noch fünf sekunden die abstimmung läuft
und ich denke ergebnisse denkbar knapp
21 und dann bitte ich die debatte die
abstimmung zu schließen
dann haben wir ein jahr 255 1924 und
damit ist dem verfahrens antrag
zugestimmt das heißt ich rufe auf den
tagesordnungspunkt 12 lasse ihn geöffnet
14.13 rufe ihn auf lasse ihnen geöffnet
kommen 10.14 rufin auflassen geöffnet 15
mit aufgerufen und offen gelassen 16 17
und 18
und wir kommen dann zum
tagesordnungspunkt 19 und 1019 rufe ich
auf den sachen antrag sm-3 dazu gibt es
danach auch noch einen änderungsantrag
der uns vorliegt der wird im anschluss
dann ebenfalls vorgestellt zuerst erhält
ein vertreter des antragstellers das
wort das ist der kreisvorstand freiburg
ich darf daran erinnern dass sie gestern
redezeiten vereinbart haben dass
antragsteller jeweils drei minuten und
alle weiteren wortbeiträge eine minute
sprechen dürfen
bis sie was anderes entscheiden gilt das
fort und dann bitte ein vertreter des
kreisvorstandes freiburg
ist unterwegs
nochmal kurz der text der
bundesparteitag steht in dem antrag
missbillige habe das spielerische waren
fand sprecher der beckenboden mikrofon
morgen nikolaus kramer ich beantrage zu
diesem tagesordnungspunkt die redezeit
auf sieben minuten hoch zu setzen für
den einbringe und mindestens drei
minuten für die debatte wir haben hier
gestern eine rede gehört die zum teil
doch sehr entsetzt gewesen ist und ich
denke dieser parteitag der hat es
verdient dass wir uns mit dieser rede
auseinandersetzen und das darf nicht
innerhalb von ein paar minuten nur
abgegolten werden sollen so mindestens
drei minuten können wir als begrenzt
wäre keine begrenzung von einem mindest
redezeit oder dergleichen
wir bräuchten damit eine klare ansage ob
07 minuten für antrag schon drei minuten
für alle weiteren volt patrick
beschlossen werden soll oder etwas
anderes er kramer
ich beantrage einführungsrede zeit
sieben minuten und für die debatte drei
minuten gut das ist ein zuseher antrag
sieben minuten für die einbringer von
für diesen tagesordnungspunkt ist das
beantragt 70 für die einbringung von
anträgen und drei minuten für gegenreden
wege für weitere wortbeiträge wir haben
eine gegenrede und war von bitteschön
also ich finde es ziemlich pana wenn
unsere beziehungsweise unsere kandidaten
für den bundesvorstand hier gestern sich
fünf minuten vorstellen durften wir dann
entschieden haben wir in den
bundesvorstand ist und für den antrag
über die man diskutieren kann
wer jetzt hier eine bühne von sieben
minuten geben wollen das finde ich grob
missbräuchlich und ich bitte dass bedard
zu leben wo sind wir
dankeschön
dann kommen wir zur abstimmung über den
geschäftsordnungsantrag die redezeiten
für diesen tagesordnungspunkt
hochzusetzen auf sieben minuten für
antragsteller und drei minuten für
weitere wortbeiträge wer diesen
geschäftsordnungsantrag seine zustimmung
erteilen möchte den bitte ich jetzt um
die blaue stimmkarte gegen rehden mit
erotischem gerade enthaltungen
das ist eine mehrheit dagegen dann
verbleibt es bei den gestern
vereinbarten redezeiten herrmann hielt
sie haben drei minuten für die
antragsbegründung bitteschön die presse
hatte ja schon über unseren antrag aus
freiburg berichtet er wurde dargestellt
als man den antrag als würde es hier um
eine persönliche fehde gehen in unserem
kreis vorstand sind auch liberale
mitglieder
aufmerksame parteikollegen die mit sorge
die entwicklung des bundesvorstands
beobachten
wir haben gesehen dass wir in der
wählergunst genau dann eingebrochen sind
wenn dieser bundesvorstand unter diesem
bundessprecher meuten sich distanziert
hat wenn er die eigenen leute
angegriffen hat erneuten arbeitet mit
einem kredit der nicht gedeckt ist
er behauptet wenn wir uns
möglichst scharf abgrenzen und die
eigenen leute attackieren
ich nenne jetzt mal die causa kallwitz
man kann von ihm halten was man will
aber gebracht hat es uns nichts die
verfassungsschutz beobachtung geht
weiter und sie arbeiten hier mit
prämissen die sich einfach nicht
bewahrheiten und sie lernen nicht daraus
sie machen einfach weiter
während die beobachtung voranschreitet
und das liegt eben nicht daran dass die
leute disziplinlos sein dass es blöd
sind wir haben es einfach nicht in der
hand unsere gegner sagen sie auch nicht
immer verfassungsschutz sagen sie doch
einfach die regierung die altparteien
die werden alle register ziehen egal wie
scharf sie sich abgrenzen
egal wieviel kurse wir bei gruppe
professor murswiek belegen und uns genau
anschauen was darf man denn jetzt sagen
und was nicht und wenn sie in die mail
reinschreiben hier wir klagen jetzt aber
wenn wir kein recht bekommen dann werden
wir einfach alles akzeptieren dann geben
sie unser schwert im meinungskampf aus
der hand und dann können wir nur
verlieren was wir hier haben ist ein
meinungskampf es geht nur darum in der
bundesrepublik die meinungshoheit zu
gewinnen und wenn wir einfach nur brav
immer sagen na gut wenn wir das nicht
mehr sagen wollen dann dürfen dann sagen
wir das einfach nicht mehr
dann geben wir diesen kampf auf und
deswegen muss von diesem parteitag ein
deutliches signal ausgehen
wir wollen auch alle mitglieder
einbinden aber doch bitte auf augenhöhe
ohne beschimpfungen und mit respekt und
diesen respekt haben sie missen lassen
herr läuten hören sie auf mit ihrem
sparkurs
ich denke das reicht vielen dank herr
mandl wir haben dann vorliegen einen
änderungsantrag von birgit bis ihn den
bitte ich einmal einzublenden
[Musik]
dazu haben wir verfahrensfragen zu sagen
was da im präsidium darüber beraten
der antrag das werden ist abgeändert
okay dann bitte ich einmal die
aktuellste fassung einzublenden
mit einmal den
aktuellen änderungsantrag von frau
pessin einblenden
wir haben den damen und herren ich würde
ihnen den antrag von landesverbänden
brook gerne vorlesen aber er liegt mir
nicht vor drei tagen das billig dass
spalterische gebaren von bonus und
seinen parteigängern er stellt fest dass
der absturz in der wählergunst im
zusammenhang von geändert werden jetzt
in der bundesparteitag in das belegt die
unterstellungen auf der begrüßungsrede
von professoren und weiß diese
unterstellungen zurück
ich weise darauf hin dass wir
üblicherweise antragsfristen haben die
sehr aktuelle erfassungen nicht
ermöglichen hier ist es aber aus sicht
des präsidiums noch im rahmen dessen was
man als änderungsantrag zu diesem antrag
zuzulassen hat und was zulässig ist
insofern habe jetzt fokussieren das wort
zur begründung ihres änderungsantrags
bitteschön
vielen dank das ist kein antrag von mir
als person es ist ein antrag über den
der landesvorstand brandenburg gestern
gemeinsam beschlossen hat wir beantragen
wie gerade vorgelesen dass die
unterstellung aus der brandrede wie die
presse sie zitiert von professor dr
meuten missbilligt und zurückgewiesen
wird
professor lothar morgen hat gestern hier
gestern hier sein rederecht missbraucht
brandrede wutrede morgan rechnet ab
meint frontalangriff dass die presse
reaktion auf unseren sozialstaat mit dem
wir ein zeichen setzen wollten dass wir
nach langer zeit endlich ein
rentenkonzept haben in der schwersten
zeit deutschlands
hätten wir gestern signalisieren können
wir sind für alle bürger da vorhang auf
für diejenigen die ihre freizeit um ihre
existenz bangen
ich kann verstehen herr professor doktor
leuten dass sie sich gestern geärgert
haben dass sie retten konzept nicht mehr
als fähig war
das war vorab zu erahnen aber das wird
man demokratie und ist zu akzeptieren
und es ist
und es ist nicht das erste mal dass
durch äußerungen des bundes sprechers
morgen im nachgang diskussion um die
spaltung unserer partei entbrennen das
ist schädlich für den fortgang unserer
erfolgreichen parteigeschichte presse
reaktion
erste reaktionen überlagern diese
wichtigen sozialen themen und damit
wurde dem ansinnen und des anspruchs
dieses bundes parteitages erheblich
geschadet der disziplin von der partei
fordert sollte das vorleben und diese
bühne nicht so abrechnung und über
parteimitglieder missbrauchen
und deswegen muss über diese rede
gesprochen werden die einheit unserer
partei hat oberste priorität denn eine
gespaltene fdp hat weder jetzt noch in
zukunft eine chance
wir sind volk verteilen attackieren
demokratischer draußen auf der straße
und professor doktor molke hatte sich
gestern mit hunderttausenden corona
maßnahmen gegen an verdorben
aber ich sage wir sind diejenigen die
diesen menschen draußen eine stimme
geben
die stärke der zu uns freilich stehen
lassen denn wir sind auf die verteidiger
unter grundrechte ich war 18 november
mit in berlin wie viele von euch
vielleicht auf ich stand neben den
wasserwerfern und ich habe gesehen dass
die menschen dort friedlich waren und
der professor doktor merken wenn sie in
brüssel zu weit weg sind von der warte
dann sollten sie öfter mal an der basis
teilnehmen
die mutig ist und die freundlich ist wir
wollen eine führung die er so
parteimitglieder 1 und motiviert wir
brauchen eine führung die unsere partei
und wählern zukunftsvision mit
zukunftsvisionen zusammenhält und das
fällt mir bei ihnen leider vielen dank
die wieder zeit ist verband gut dann
haben wir etwas sehen die
stellvertretende landesvorsitzende von
brandenburg eher dem rechten flügel
zugeordnet
[Applaus]
dabei kann richter ich bei anfrage die
nichtbefassung mit diesem antrag aus
gründen des schutzes unserer partei seid
ihr denn des bahn
eine debatte über den parteivorsitzenden
zu beginnen wo wir mit einheit rausgehen
müssen mit einem sozialkonzept mit
positiven nachrichten wenn wir jetzt 30
redner anhören mit kritik oder
irgendeiner verteidigung dann haben wir
nur diese diskussion in der presse und
dann denkt die leute denken die leute
über unseren corona park weiter dass das
hier eine reine katastrophe ist brecht
diese diskussion ab zum schutze unserer
partei über den parteivorsitzenden
werden wir uns intern debattieren müssen
und entscheidungen treffen wenn er zur
wahl steht ist es wirklich eine bitte
das jetzt abzubrechen danke so ganz kurz
herr klein sehr klein brauchen sie noch
nicht weg herr klein wetter noch nicht
weglaufen bitte also nicht befassung mit
dem antrag sm-3 ist das richtig ja ok
so keine gegenrede ebenfalls am laufen
sein mikrofon
meine damen und herren das ist
altparteien gehabe wenn wir was nicht
passt da macht man die kritiker mundtot
das ist schlichtweg der schaden und vor
allem hertlein west und das ist als
miese daran sie verdrehen hier die
schuld wenn ich als partei später
hingehen und unsere wähler beschimpfe da
muss sich dafür rechtfertigen und ich
darf nicht jetzt sagen ach nee wir
dürfen das nicht wieder gerade biegen
wir müssen noch unsere wähler die
müssten doch zu unseren wählern erklären
das war mist dass sie beschimpft wurden
sie können doch nicht einfach die leute
als co-piloten beschimpfen
das ist der schaden der entsteht wenn
sie nicht hingehen die rede mich darüber
jetzt wirklich statt
vielen dank dann kommen wir zur
abstimmung über den geschäftsgang und
antrag von herrn klein rechte auf
nichtbefassung
also heißt meine damen meine damen und
herren bitte hier die werden sie was
sagen wollen gehen sie bitte ans
mikrofon und melden sich aber aktuell
sind vier
wir sind aktuell jetzt in einer
abstimmung zu einem
geschäftsordnungsantrag sie können einen
weitergehenden geschäfts antrag stellen
ich erkläre ihnen einmal kurz wie die
rechtslage ist ja ein augenblick dann
können sie dann sind die zwischenrufe
vielleicht erklären sich dann vielleicht
also wir haben hier jetzt einen antrag
gestellt bekommen auf nichtbefassung mit
einem antrag diesen antrag kann man im
fortgang einer diskussion
selbstverständlich wieder stellt das ist
nicht ein verbrauch deren eintritt dass
man dann dieser antrag nicht mehr
stellen kann und es ist zwischen dem
antrag geben und jetzt ist diskussion
passiert sind unter anderem ein
änderungsantrag vorgestellt wurden und
so weiter das ist jederzeit zulässig
einen solchen änderung ist an solchen
antrag zu stellen missbräuchlich wäre es
dann wenn man ihn unmittelbar stellt
nachdem wir gerade abgestimmt wurde
das wäre missbräuchlich in dieser form
ist das einwandfrei zulässig deshalb
kommen wir da zur abstimmung über diesen
geschäftsordnungsantrag auf
nichtbefassung mit dem antrag es im 3
sie haben eine begründung gehört eine
gegenrede gehört wir kommen zur
abstimmung die blaue stimmkarte bitte
wenn sie sich mit dem antrag das sind
drei nichten fassen möchten danke die
rote stimmkarte wenn sie gegen die
nichtbefassung sind
wir machen das mit elektronisch also wir
haben gerade gehört dass über dasselbe
thema und über denselben inhalt laut
satzung und juristischen feinheiten
zweimal abgestimmt werden kann im laufe
eines verfahrens dieses ist jetzt das
zweite mal auch hier sind die
mehrheitsverhältnisse denkbar knapp und
deswegen lässt julian fleig elektronisch
abstimmen weil da zweifelsfrei jede
stunde und nichtbefassung mit dem antrag
sn 3 mit 1 können sie mit vier
ja-stimmen zwei können sie für nein
stimmen 3 können sich enthalten es geht
um den geschäftsordnungsantrag
nichtbefassung des m3 sie haben 30
sekunden zeit für die abstimmung ab
jetzt bitteschön so in der ersten
abstimmung jahren blick auf die
verhältnisse noch kurz zuvor 48 für
nichtbefassung noch 52 prozent jeweils
für die befassung jetzt im laufe des
verfahrens und der weiteren diskussionen
gibt es diese abstimmung schon wieder
sie sehen aber auf dem bild das sich im
hinteren teil etliche redner schon an
die mikrofone begeben haben um die
debatte mit ihren äußerungen zu befüllen
so ausgetauscht wurde dann bitte die
folie wieder einzublenden und die
abstimmung kann eröffnet werden 1 jahr
2003 enthaltung 30 sekunden ab jetzt so
die zweite abstimmung für die frage
sollen wir über das spalterische gebaren
dass in den sn drei vom kreisverband
freiburg steht abstimmen und eine
debatte darüber abhalten ja oder nein
herr mandl vom kreisverband freiburg hat
diesen antrag hier gerade noch mal
vorgestellt
über dieses verfahren wird jetzt noch
mal abgestimmt und das ergebnis gibt es
jetzt 321 lampe durch die abstimmung zu
schließen und das ergebnis einzublenden
wir befassen uns also weiter mit dem
antrag und die aussprache wird eröffnet
wir machen jetzt wir haben eine reihe
von leuten machen blau rot blau dann
haben wir fordern einen dann geht's
weiter und so weiter
bitteschön am saalmikrofon glauben ja
liebe parteifreunde als vor ungefähr
einem jahr in der bundesprogramm
kommission die fetzen geflogen sind und
wir uns über das konzept nicht einigen
wollten habe ich um die wogen etwas zu
glätten gesagt ich wünsche mir dass von
diesem parteitag ein zeichen der
einigung ausgeht und der geschlossenheit
und das hätte auch fast klappen können
wir haben nämlich heute ein sehr sehr
oder gestern einen sehr guten leitantrag
zur sozialpolitik beschlossen in dem
lösungen sind die keine andere partei
präsentieren kann
aber wenn ich heute in die presse gucke
dann lese ich dort nichts von einem
leitantrag ich rede sie nur das
vermeiden herausgefunden hat das die
querdenker rechtsradikal sind dass wir
in unseren eigenen reihen rechtsradikale
sind in dem kampf angesagt hat das liebe
parteifreunde
das ist parteischädigend da müssen wir
heute darüber abstimmen da müssen wir
eine klare absage erteilen dass das
nicht nochmal vorkommen
[Applaus]
gehts weiter im roten saal mikrofon wir
haben vorher vorne noch einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag am blauen
mikrofon bitte hör ich stelle fest dass
diese versammlung sich heute mit diesem
antrag befassen möchte aber ich möchte
nicht da für uns zwei stunden damit
befassen dass die gestellten antrag auf
ende der rednerliste also alle die hier
können noch sehr gerne aber nicht dass
es einfach ewig weitergehen danke also
ende der rednerliste ist beantragt wir
würden sie haben hier vorn aufnehmen
auch noch 22 wort melden kann von hier
aus nicht genau sehen wir dort hinten
ist ich würde aber dann einen der
kollegen bitten dort hinten einmal platz
da hinzugehen vorsichtshalber schon
einmal und haben jetzt eine gegenrede
zum ende der rednerliste ebenfalls am
blauen waren mikrofon
meine damen und herren wir haben es
gestern hier also die zwischenrufe und
den geräuschpegel den bitte ich jetzt
mal runter zu fahren und einzustellen
haben wir gestern einen ganzen tag lang
sehr diszipliniert hinbekommen das
schaffen wir auch heute so ich weiß
jetzt eine gegenrede zu ziehen
geschäftsordnungs andere auf ende der
rednerliste gibt es dazu eine gegenrede
bitteschön am blauen saal mikrofon
wir haben jetzt zweimal sn drei den
ablehnungsantrag abgelehnt jetzt kommt
der nächste antrag hört doch auf diese
blöden anträge zu stellen es n3 ist
zugelassen also wenn du auch debattiert
[Applaus]
so das ist im weitesten sinne eine
gegenrede zum schluss der rednerliste
wer kommt mehr zur abstimmung beantragt
ist die rednerliste zu schließen wer die
rednerliste schließen möchten wir jetzt
die blaue stimmkarte wer das nicht
möchte den ironisch staub nicht aus noch
mal die blauen stimmkarte bitte auch das
machen wir liegt chronischer
also noch mal elektronisch weil mit
einem förmlichen verfahren das sicherste
ist weil man das vom podium aus nicht
eindeutig zuordnen kann ob es da eine
mehrheit also der antragsteller hat
gerade gefordert dass die rednerliste
beschlossen werden soll damit es einen
überschaubaren zeitraum und auch im
barren argumentation austausch gibt und
danach ein schluss der rednerliste
erfolgen soll darüber debattiert der
parteitag beziehungsweise stimmt er
gerade ab
nichtsdestotrotz kann ich ihnen schon
mal sagen dass wir aus diesen gründen
weil die dynamik dieses vormittags uns
keinen anderen platz lässt uns dieses
verfahren weiter zu übertragen und den
parteien hat allerdings noch einen
presseclub entfernt sich frage einmal
herr prager die übersicht wer jeweils
das bitte einmal mir kurz bescheid geben
gleich wir haben
bitte geben sie ein frager und uns hier
einen augenblick wir müssen uns einmal
quartieren im roten saal mikrofon ist es
dem spanier gewesen
am blauen saal mikrofon martin reichert
und ob auf der bühne stefan brandner
wir haben hier oben haben wir schon drei
meldungen
also wir haben also jetzt hier einmal um
das kurz mit alle wissen dass wir hier
haben ich sehe dass wir da hinten winken
kündigungsschutz klarheit
das waren die jeweils letzten an dem
mikrofon die gemeldet worden
nicht die einzigen natürlich gut alle da
hinten sieht man an der schlange war der
letzte ist ganz kurz wer hier vorne noch
drauf ist was zusammen beobachten sich
gemeldet doktor alexander wolf professor
doktor york deutschen joachim paul und
stefan brandner dankeschön so wir sehen
auch das rote mikrofon mit einem
geschäftsordnungsantrag hinein schuldige
du hast mich nie gesehen
stellvertretende wahlleiter ihr habt die
festlegung vor der abstimmung getroffen
da herrscht ein browser letzte am roten
zahlen begriffen und erst danach könnt
ihr schließen hier können die verrat
stimmung sorgen schließlich ihr könnt
gehen und wieder und dann stimmt ja ab
das geht nicht das ist dass es
zutreffend so also dort hinten am
hinteren danke schön herr stein am
vorderen wäre
gut verwandtschaft kommt dahin und
kontrolliert ja da gibt es natürlich
auch innerparteiliche um die frage wer
hat am besten argumente am schluss oder
in der dynamik des prozesses der
diskussion am überzeugendsten
parteistrategen werden mir recht geben
wenn das natürlich sozusagen strategisch
günstig für den ein- oder für die andere
richtung sein kann so ich darf sagen
jetzt einmal kurz stellvertreter bleibt
peter am hinteren mikrofon und wenn der
wahlleiter sich am vorderen mikrofon
darauf aufpasst dass sich dort keiner
mehr an stellt im auge hat ist man hat
das ja eben auch alles dort gesehen das
ist dann dort das ende der rednerliste
so wir hatten jetzt gesagt überhaupt
eine reihung wir machen blau-rot vorne
blau-rot vorne und arbeiten das ganze
dann ab es geht los am blauen saal
mikrofon bitteschön keine minute ist
jahren ja vielen dank liebe freunde wir
haben schon gestern abend glaube ich
über die rede von jörg motten viel
diskutiert das ist auch glaube ich der
richtige ort dafür und was war die
kernaussage die kernaussage war mehr
selbstdisziplin weniger
selbstdarstellung ich glaube das können
wir alle unterschreiben ja man konnte
mit einigen
man konnte mit einigen spitzen war
vielleicht nicht zufrieden habe ich
glaube es ist ein schlechter stil wenn
wir künftig jede rede des bundes
sprechers dann nochmal zur eigenen einem
eigenen top machen und lange diskutieren
wollen wir auch den abbruch der des
interviews mit frau weiter jetzt
diskutieren
leute ich bitte euch die dass die kirche
im dorf zu lassen und bei allen
folgenden diskussionen jetzt ruhe zu
oder ein bisschen abzurüsten ja solche
reden müssen auch mal brennen und zackig
sein
genau dafür ist herr morgen gewählt
worden um zu führen
das ist im jahre lang vorgeworfen dass
er nicht führt jetzt führt einmal und
mehr führen möchte sollte bitte sprecher
im bundesvorstand bleiben dazu es die
angerufen das sollte er tun aber nicht
dann hier im nach mitternacht treten
danke danke schön dann geht's weiter im
roten saal mikrofon
ja liebe liebe freunde der hermann und
das mikrofon
hallo der manager gestern derjenige der
die presse ausschließen wollte und keine
unschönen bilder zu machen
heute stellt er einen antrag um den
bundesbanker zu beschädigen dem hatte
der mann ist die person lieber hermann
nitsch ist die person die behauptet es
gibt ja keinen großen unterschied
zwischen npd afd
der mensch ist derjenige der ein
tanzendes video gemacht hat wo der
erneute zu grabe getragen wurde
bei twitter im frühjahr leute lasst uns
auch nicht von solchen leuten trägern
hier klar gesagt wir brauchen disziplin
und solche leute wieder mangelt zeigen
geben dass wir nicht in mithaftung
genommen werden belegt wenig mit so
jemanden in mithaftung genommen werden
der uns mit der npd vergleicht und dass
diese versicherungen gesorgt hat und hat
die akteure der aussage gewissen deshalb
wichtig ist bringen ablehnung dieser
anlage ist angezählt
danke schön da machen wir hier vorne
weiter doch so wolf erhält das wort als
nächstes
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren hervor die jetzt
nicht ja liebe mitglieder jörg leuten
hat gestern eine wichtige grundsatzrede
gehalten da ist nicht da es nicht
entscheidend ob man jede einzelne
formulierung daraus mitträgt ich hätte
zum beispiel die bismarck kritischen
worte weggelassen
aber was ist die kernbotschaft ist dann
eben schon an die kernbotschaft ist mehr
disziplin
die kern botschaft ist wir stehen an
einer entscheidenden situation unsere
partei in der die altparteien versuchen
uns mit dem verfassungsschutz kaputt zu
kriegen und da gilt es klug zu sein
nicht sich zu verbiegen aber er hat
gesagt wir dürfen unser projekt der
partei nicht kaputt machen lassen von
wenigen querulanten spinnern und karten
darum geht es und diese rede ist nicht
spaltbares sondern diese rede print dann
ein für die große mehrheit unserer
bürgerlich feierlich konservativen
partei spalterisch sehr viel hängen die
erneuten hier dafür jetzt kritisieren
wollen die un ein mitarbeiten
herr dr wolff vielen dank alexander wolf
aus dem bundesvorstand der a8 erinnern
dass die bitte laute zwischenrufe
unterlassen das mit akteuren die die
akustik ist schwierig genug so wie sie
es mit der blauen kuh phone die nächste
rede
ja liebe freunde wir haben gestern das
erlebt was wir jahrelang nicht hatten
nämlich führung und dafür bin ich heute
erst mal dankbar
das war nämlich völlig richtig wasser
gemacht
wir sind im moment in einer unter 10%
blase
da kann man sich drauf auf keinen die
toll system opposition wir sind das
bringt aber dem land nicht weiter
wir sind ab heute wieder wählbar draußen
wir sind ab heute eine wirkliche gefahr
für die altparteien weil nur so wenn wir
weber werden und an die 20 prozent dran
kommen sind wir eines für diesem
parlamentarischen demokratie wirklich
für die etablierten eine gefährliche
partei wenn wir so weiter machen wir
jetzt mit manager wandern dann haben wir
das verarscht dann haben wir es vergeigt
der kommen nach hause gehen liebe
freunde das war führung und für diese
führung bin ich professor dr görg leuten
dankbar dankeschön dann geht es am roten
saal mikrofon weiter tun danke jürgen
pohl bundestagsabgeordneter
sozialpolitiker hier geht es um die
arroganz von professor doktor holten wir
arbeiten seit drei jahren an einem
sozialplan
wir arbeiten dafür dass uns die
politiker die arbeitnehmer wählen und er
spricht von vertonung das kann ich sein
erschwerend nach hause das kann ich sein
und das ganze hat methode
wir hatten die jogginghosen fraktion wir
hatten niemand will die eine partei
spalten wir hatten ein
ausschlussverfahren dass wir uns nicht
mehr halten können
diese zeiten
ist vorbei vielen dank dann als nächstes
herr paul damen und herren es gibt mir
die gelegenheit nochmal der presseclub
entfällt und nachgefragt hören sie auf
wdr 5
also sorgt ganz klar wir sind doch keine
versammlung von schneeflöckchen die man
jeden tag auf die schulter klopfen muss
und sagen muss ihr seid toll alles in
ordnung macht so weiter zur führung
brauche ich doch gar nicht liebe freunde
und natürlich ist es richtig ich bin
auch ein bewunderer von bismarck aber
wir erleben eine zeit in der alles um
gefügt wird stichwort industrie 4.0 wir
erleben eine neue tägliche revolution
wir müssen noch eine moderne partei sein
wir müssen doch die begriffe um
übergriffe hoch office wie geht es mit
innenstädten weiters können wir doch
nicht mit der alten konzepten lösen wir
sind nicht die partei der rückwärts
müssen nach vorne schauen und dafür
steht heute die querdenker bewegung ja
es ist richtig ist es richtig das sind
viele viele menschen dabei ganz normale
menschen die sich an diesen maßnahmen
stören die ein problem damit haben dass
ihre grundrechte immer weiter
eingedampft werden aber es ist eben auch
eine bewegung von attila hildmann und
anderen konzerten und ich bin nicht der
parlamentarische arm dieser konsorten
ich bin der parlamentarische arm der afg
und sonst keiner bewegung eine
parlamentarische arbeit und dem einsatz
noch und wenn ich den herrn man die
schüler fällt mir fällt mir geht dann
begriff 1
inschallah ich kann ja eh nicht viel das
ist eine rede an jede politik so meine
damen und herren wir werden den
fdp-parteitag hier jetzt weiter
übertragen der ard presseclub ist in der
ard zu sehen und wieder nachgefragt
im wdr 5 dass er integrativ ist das ja
konstruktiv ist dass er vermittelt dass
er moderiert
ausgleichen wird wirkt und brücken baut
und lieber herr de erneuten das haben
wir erst nicht nicht erst seit ihrer
jetzigen rede gehört sie haben diesen
integrativen kurs bereits seit beginn
dieses jahres verlassen und ich bedaure
das zutiefst denn ich war mal ein großer
fan und unterstützer von ihnen aber
offensichtlich werden sie mit dieser
partei so wie sie sich darstellt nicht
mehr glücklich
sie wollen eine andere partei sie wollen
nicht dass wir hier ausgleichen dass
alle gemeinsam an einem strang ziehen
sondern sie sind offensichtlich zu der
erkenntnis gelangt dass ein ganz
erheblicher teil dieser partei nicht
mehr zu ihr gehört und deshalb würde ich
mich freuen sie haben ja vielleicht auch
selbst noch mal ein wortbeitrag
angemeldet wie es uns als partei weiter
helfen soll wenn nach ihrer gestrigen
rede und den entscheidungen die wir
getroffen haben ihre fans in den
sozialen netzwerken unter anderem
schreiben der kurs wäre jetzt klar man
das große schlachten würde jetzt
beginnen und selbst wenn wir 40 prozent
unserer mitglieder und avaya folge im
osten verlieren würden dann wäre es das
wert leuten hat den stau gegeben das
kann es doch wohl wirklich nicht sein
dankeschön vielen dank die nächste
wortmeldung kommt vom roten saal
mikrofon bitteschön im roten saal
mikrofon
hallo ja man hört sich ja
die antragsteller die sprechen immer von
einigkeit welcher einigkeit meinen die
das ist die einigkeit einer bewegung wie
es die antragsteller aber auch viren
hacker immer sagen das ist die reinigung
die einigkeit der neuen rechten bewegung
und da sind päda querdenkern usw
das harmlose das andere sind npd neue
rechte und so weiter diese einigkeit
brauchen wir nicht wir brauchen die
heiligkeit der partei
der alternative für deutschland und
dafür steht führte und dafür danke ich
ihm
vielen dank dankeschön
dann geht es jetzt vorne weiter mit
herrn rentner ja aber sie haben noch
nicht das wort ist es jetzt hab jetzt
sofort herr brandner
herr brandner hat das wort
stefan brandner der
bundestagsabgeordnete der afd
liebe freunde ich so die puls
runterfahren habe ich glaube ich habe
gar keinen puls mehr nach dem verlauf
dieser debatte gestern der tag wie fing
er an mit einer bombastischen rede von
tino gruppe hat ein programmparteitag an
bord parteitag eingeleitet ein
programmparteitag mit dem wir das signal
senden wollen wir sind die experten eine
sozialpolitik in der rentenpolitik und
in der wirtschaftspolitik ist super an
und was kam dann ein torpedo von jörg
neunten er hat das torpediert medial
überlagert er hat schweren schaden
unserer parteien diese partei zugefügt
welche motive haben ihn geleitet
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß es nicht aber
es sind keine guten motive der weg den
jurorinnen im märz dieses jahres wird
spaltung debatte eingeleitet hat führt
er unbeirrt vorliebe york dieser weg ist
ein irrweg dieser weg ist falsch du
spalt ist die partei kommt zu uns zurück
du hilfst habe ich nur den altparteien
es ist nicht gut für diese afd
es schadet der afg es hilft nur den
altparteien york kommt zurück in unsere
familie vernehmen ich auch gerne wieder
auf vielen dank dankeschön
die erste wortmeldung und wir haben
einen geschäftsordnungsantrag am blauen
bayern mikrofon bitteschön
schönen dank nach dieser brandrede
vorher im brandner meine ist ja auch
schon fast alles gesagt aber natürlich
sollte auch erneut noch zu wort kommen
und deswegen beantrage ich herrn malt
jetzt noch zu wort kommen zu lassen eine
minute und dann schluss der debatte
beantragt der antrag ist in der debatte
mit der mit dem zusatz verfahren das er
heute noch das wort bekommt steht auf
der rednerliste sowieso drauf gibt es
dazu eine gegenrede am neuen wall
mikrofon ebenfalls ja ich möchte mich
gegen den antrag aussprechen
jetzt haben ihn alle möglichen leute
zehn minuten 20 minuten lang beschimpfen
dürfen und erbeuten soll jetzt eine
minute antworten dürfen
das ist wohl etwas einseitig dieser
antrag und deswegen bitte ich darum den
abzulesen vielen dank so dafür ist die
gegenrede wir kommen jetzt zum antrag
der da lautet ende der debatte wobei
erneuten noch seinen redebeitrag
vortragen kann wenn sie diesen antrag
zustimmen möchte wieder die bau
stimmkarte gegenstimmen der roten
stimmkarte enthaltung das waren gut
deutliche mehrheit gegen diesen antrag
dann machen wir weiter und zwar am
blauen saal mikrofon da ist müssen wir
nach vorne gewandert das ist ja lucassen
liebe freunde was jedoch alle verlangen
rollen und verlangen müssen ist dass
diese partei ausrichtung und reibe kommt
dass sie geführt wird und vor allen
dingen dass auch klartext gesprochen
werde ich meine das licht in der genetik
von patrioten auch klartext zu sprechen
wo genau das hat unser bundessprecher
gestern getan und denn
und wenn dann schon die antragsteller
bis hin und landet auf die presse
verweise und die reaktion der presse und
darauf verweisen was die
umfrageergebnisse anbetrifft dann führen
wir uns doch bitte mal vor augen das
hört leuten genau das angesprochen hat
was letzte woche im bundestag passiert
ist dem nicht dass sich einzelne
abgeordnete aus rein populistischen
gründen haus rechtswidrigen motiven
heraus eben in die ziellinie begeben
haben und genau das hat er angeprangert
und das ergebnis haben wir wenn wir
schon umfrage von zitieren wollen
gestern in forsa gesehen da liegen wir
nämlich auf 7 prozent das ist die
realität und mit solchen auswüchsen in
unserer partei die uns allen schaden
muss schluss sein
das hat angefangen und wir raten wir von
einem bundesrichter
vielen dank
dann machen wir am roten saal mikrofon
weiter liebe parteifreunde
ich kritisiere die rede von herrn leuten
weil ich nicht glaube dass diese
diskussion unsere partei einig nein sie
spaltet sie noch weiter und weil die die
sind diese diskussion schon
angeschnitten worden ist möchte ich noch
zwei punkte ansprechen die ihr zur
debatte stehen das eine ist die frage
des umgangs mit dem verfassungsschutz
und ich sage ganz klar der
verfassungsschutz hat sinnvolle aufgaben
aber wenn wir uns in die logik des
verfassungsschutzes zur beurteilung und
politischer parteien hineinbegeben dann
haben wir verloren wir dürfen uns diese
einschätzungen niemals zu eigen machen
und der zweite punkt betrifft den umgang
mit der querdenker bewegung politik ist
vor allen dingen auch stimmung im land
die menschen die heute auf die straße
gehen sind die mutigsten menschen in
diesem land es sind nicht die die auf
dem sofa sitzen wie querdenker bewegung
muss selbstverständlich unser partner
auf der straße sein alles
er erwähnt an den etablierten ludwig von
der volkspartei
vielen dank als nächstes professor jörg
martin
[Musik]
da haben ein geo antrag am bahnhof und
den nehmen wir noch schnell bitte ja ich
würde beantragen das verbeugen aufgrund
der rede die gegen beziehungsweise für
diesen antrag gehalten wurden auch eine
längere regel sei das nur 1 minute
bekommen sondern drei minuten
beantragt ist die redezeit werden morgen
auf drei minuten festzulegen in seiner
gegenrede mit gegenrede kommt gerade
doch noch in sein mikrophon meine damen
und herren das eben gesehen die
organisierten unterstützer voller
wollten haben eben sofort die mikrofone
her geflutet sie haben sich hier
angestellt so die standen hier
entsprechen
sie haben das eben bei den gegenreden
gesehen hier ist es glaube genug
propaganda führen heute neben gemacht
worden
das können wir uns ersparen dankeschön
so dann haben sie eine gegen jähriger
der geschäftsordnungsantrag hier lautet
die redezeit für den leuten festzulegen
auf drei minuten währt diesem
geschäftsjahr auf antrag folgen markt
mit dem die blaue stimmkarte die rote
karte war dagegen ist und das machen
will ektron ischen
doch bitte eine folie fortschreitende
redezeit jungen leuten mit drei minuten
ist die abstimmung jan 1 enthaltung sind
die möglichkeiten mit der einst jahr mit
der 203 enthaltung ob die redezeit auf
drei minuten festgelegt werden soll
halbe minute abstimmung ist eröffnet
fünf sekunden 3210 dann bitte ich die
abstimmung zu schließen und dann haben
wir drei minuten redezeit für herrn
leuten die sie dann ab sofort haben ja
danke schön ich danke zunächst für die
gewährung von drei minuten
ich finde das angemessen weil es geht
hier um meine rede und mich und da
möchte ich hier drei minuten gerne auch
nutzen um gegen rede halten zu können
was hier geschieht ist eine gezielte
ideologisch motivierte verdrehung meiner
rede von gestern
habe mich ich habe mich weder weder
gegen otto von bismarck als bedeutende
figur der deutschen geschichte
ausgesprochen sondern ich habe gesagt
dass die rezepturen für das morgen
nichts gebaut sind ist es völlig anderes
schon gar nicht nehmen wir vorher schon
gar nicht habe ich mich gegen die
querdenker bewegung ausgesprochen
sondern dann schauen sie sich die rede
an sie ist ja verfügbar sondern ich habe
sogar gesagt dass da sehr viele sehr
vernünftige menschen ihre berechtigte
kritik vorbringen dass ihr
demonstrationsrecht anspruch nehmen dass
sie das dürfen müssen was ich angemahnt
habe ist eine kritische distanz zu den
nicht seriösen personen die es da auch
gibt weil die uns gut ansteht weil es
unseren schade liebe freunde ich habe
mitnichten mich mit nächten gegen die
querdenker bewegung im ganzen
ausgesprochen
und jeder kann das kontrollieren es ist
ja frei verfügbar schauen sie sich an
und sie werden sehen das habe ich nicht
getan
schon gar nicht habe ich mit meiner rede
zu irgendeiner form von spaltung
aufgerufen
denn die ist überhaupt nicht immer im
interesse sondern sondern liebe freunde
ich habe eine neue einheit in disziplin
angemahnt und das erscheint mir
tatsächlich dringend notwendig
gebrauchen
disziplin
[Applaus]
und das ist auch heute noch richtig wir
stehen vor einem großen war ja wir sind
durch diese ganzen disziplinlosigkeit
mittlerweile es wurde eben erwähnt in
der forsa umfrage auf sieben prozent
abgerutscht
das ist unmittelbare auswirkungen dessen
was zb im bundestag am 18 11 passiert
ist ich will liebe freunde
neben freunden dafür bin ich gewählt ich
will mit ganzem herzen den erfolg
unserer partei und 2021 hat ein
entscheidendes war ja aber diesen erfolg
werden wir und das ist das was sie zu
dieser rede veranlasst hat diesen erfolg
werden wir nur mit seriösem auftreten
erzielen nicht mit den aktionen vor
funkhäusern nicht mit dem antrag die
pässe auszuschließen
das geht so nicht wir müssen und dafür
stehe ich hier wir müssen eine
bürgerliche partei seien eine partei
bürgerlicher vernunft die seriös
auftritt nur damit können wir erfolg
haben dass alleine das alleine meine ich
an und lassen sie mich noch folgendes
sagen dafür bin ich gewählt und das
völlig aus ich sehe das als meinen
auftrag ich mache das nicht zum
persönlichen vergnügen sondern ich
meinen eltern tief und
verantwortungsgefühl
wem das nicht behagt der möge einen
abwahlantrag stellen ds zu diesem
parteitag nicht gestellt können sie ja
gerne zum nächsten parteitag machen
müssen zumindest völlig frei aber
bitteschön ich tue das wofür ich gewählt
bin von knapp 70 prozent der mitglieder
das sorgen dass nur wir hier dieses land
repariert können liebe freunde nur mir
und niemand sonst und nur mit shirt und
vielen dank die redezeit ist vorbei
[Applaus]
und wir machen weiter am blauen saal
mikrofon redezeit eine minute weiter
einmischen
vielen dank ja ich glaube es sehr gut
dass wir diese debatte führen meine
damen und herren
und dass wir uns mal aussprechen vorhin
war der bande hat von familie gesprochen
vielleicht ist das jetzt mal ein
bisschen familientherapie für uns dass
es gut dass man sich offen ausspricht
das haben viele von ihnen heute gemacht
das haben viele leute vom flügel heute
gemacht oder vom ehemaligen flügel und
das hat herr meuten gestern gemacht
meine damen und herren
und komischerweise wenn es die eine
seite macht es immer wunderbar in
ordnung da darf jeder kritisiert werden
darf dürfen wir jeden haltungsnoten
verteilt werden aber wenn es die andere
seite macht oder wenn es unser
bundessprecher macht dann ist es
plötzlich 1 kanal dann kommen die
schneeflöckchen raus dann wird hier auf
und ab gelaufen und gebrüllt vielleicht
hätten sie statt brüllen gestern mal
lieber die rede angehört und hätten was
gelernt meine damen und herren
das ist unser bundesparteitag das ist
unser höchstes organ und hier sprechen
wir uns aus und dann hören wir uns auch
die anderen meinungen an meine damen und
herren fielen das ist auch gut so vielen
dank dann geht's weiter abendrot in sein
mikrofon
ja liebe parteifreunde als das antrags
früh veröffentlicht wurde und ich den
antrag gelesen habe war meine erste
reaktion ist kommt einen antrag auf
nichtbefassung und ich werde den antrag
zu stimmen die meinung habe ich gestern
geändert nach der rede von herrn leuten
es ist angebracht an haben kritik zu
äußern und ich wäre gegen den antrag
ursprünglich gewesen weil es klar ist
diese debatte überlagert die
berichterstattung über das eigentliche
thema des parteitages unser papier zur
sozialpolitik aber der erneuten hat zum
wiederholten male die rede
als vertreter des bundesvorstandes dazu
missbraucht hier ganz massiv gegen
wesentliche teile der partei zu schießen
und gegen teile unserer wählerschaft zu
schießen
es kommt nicht darauf an wie man seine
rede vielleicht auch auslegen kann
sondern wie sie draußen aufgenommen wird
und das meist einen erneuten auch vorher
und da kommt an die querdenker sind
rechte spinner und die können nicht
einmal genau daraus denken und noch
ergänzen
erneut machen sie sich gedanken von
wegen sie dein bundesvorstand
unterstützt werden
da werden leute weder zeigen tegernau
vorbei wie herr paul und
herbert fragt mir gerade bollwerk dem
schreiben seiner burschenschaft von 611
2020 leidenschaft reden verlag augsburg
so das war deutlich überzogen jetzt
versucht also danke zweiter im blauen
saal mikrofon in sein mikrophon bitte ja
ich bin schon fast dankbar dass dieser
antrag von unserem lieben freund hermann
nitsch kommt denn besser kann man die
geist dieses antrages überhaupt nicht
beschreiben
wir haben bereits gestern erlebt was es
bedeutet und ich kann sagen für den
großen teil dieser partei der sieht
bürgerlich fühlt der das lebt und fühlt
was in unserem grundsatzprogramm drin
steht dieser teil der partei fühlt sich
seit jahren im grunde betrogen von
denjenigen die ihre eigene agenda
versuchen diese partei einzubringen und
die gesamte partei diese richtung zu
bringen
dafür stehen wir als bürgerliche
konservative und vor allen dingen als
diejenigen die dieses land wieder vom
kopf auf die füße stellen wollen nicht
zur verfügung und es war überfällig dass
von seiten des bundesvorstands damit von
unseren sprecher das deutlich gemacht
wurde und im ergebnis haben wir gestern
erlebt dass eine medienlandschaft auch
und gerade die öffentlich-rechtlichen
hier über diesen parteitag vielen dank
und objektiv berichtet hat das ist das
verdienst von erneuten und dafür stehen
wird vielen dank
dann geht es weiter im roten saal
mikrofon
sie kommen vom roten nein jetzt hat das
rote sagen mikrofon das wort ja
mein name ist petra federer ich bin
kreisvorsitzende der landeshauptstadt
schwerin ein großes politisches vorbild
ist dr gauland nicht zuletzt weil er die
worte geprägt hat seid einig einig einig
und professor morgen wenn ich ihre
kolumnen im lese ich kann da fast immer
jedes wort unterschreiben
deswegen war ich gestern so enttäuscht
mein herz hat wirklich fast geblutet ich
bin rausgegangen
ich konnte ihr redet nicht mehr ertragen
und an dieser stelle ein dankeschön an
herrn pofalla angst vor weide die ebenso
wie dr bauland für die einigkeit diese
partei stehen
danke der nächste wort matra kommt vom
blauen saal mikrofon das ist richtig das
heer tischer vor ihnen war dort ja der
krieg das wort claudia mikrofon von hier
vorne
ja liebe freunde parteifreund leuten
wissen sie was sie tun
sie sorgen mit ihrem sparkurs und mit
ihren wortmeldungen mit der rede gestern
dafür dass die umfang den keller gehen
und dann geben sie denen die sie dabei
aufhalten wollen bei ihrem
zerstörungswerk die schuld beraten
das ist unredlich dass sich in ordnung
und was was tun sie noch sie übernehmen
das narrativ der medien wir würden immer
extremer wie er seinen haufen spieler
das stimmt doch nicht das von der bild
ich sehe 16 landtagsfraktionen also
nicht mehr erst ja leider hauptzugang
ein paar ich sehe die bundesfraktion ich
seh professionalisierung auf allen
ebenen übernehmen wir also bitte nicht
das narrativ der medien so dass eine und
dann wenn das führung heißt das sie hier
vorführen
war der begriff kann ja häufig vor heute
wenn doch führung ist lieber leuten dann
sind sie ein führer ins nichts
[Applaus]
dann haben wir einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag am blauen war
mikrofon bitteschön
ich denke es jetzt alles gesagt zwar
noch nicht von jedem wir sollten jetzt
über diesen antrag abstimmen und zu ende
der debatte ist also beantragt gibt es
eine gegenrede auch im blauen saal
mikrofon lg geräte gibt es das ist eine
hitzige diskussion und es ist irgendwie
bezeichnet dass eine bestimmte seite von
weit von diesen zwei beiden dazu neigt
immer wenn einer ihrer redner gab eine
gute rede gehalten hat oder wo sie
glauben dass die rede gut wird zu sagen
jetzt beenden wir die debatte sowohl das
letzte wort das ist schön
das war eine gegenrede
wir stimmen ab über ende der debatte wer
für ende der debatte ist bitte die blaue
stimmkarte die rote stimmkarte wer
dagegen ist dann die enthaltung dann ist
der antrag abgelehnt wir machen weiter
und zwar am roten saal mikrofon
bitteschön die bevor liebe freunde herr
professor 9
sie haben besser an den spargel gestellt
ob wir genug zu sagen
inhaltliche über ein zusammen politik zu
machen
meiner erinnerung nach haben wir gestern
einen leitantrag beschlossen mit 88
prozent zustimmen
wir haben gestern bewiesen dass wir
zusammen politik machen können und dass
wir zusammen politik machen wollen und
es wäre ihre aufgabe gewesen dieses
zeichen nach außen auch zu verkaufen und
stattdessen haben sie ein anlass geboten
für dieses spektakel heute morgen und ja
sie haben das recht und sie haben auch
die pflicht dieser partei ins gewissen
zu reden aber das kann man machen wie
herr dr gauland letztes jahr
beispielsweise in braunschweig mit
gewählten worten oder man kann es machen
wie sie gestern die hälfte der partie
müller einig für dankeschön
dann geht es weiter in sein mikrofon ja
liebe freunde mein name ist hainer gab
ich bin stellvertretende sprecher des
kreisverbandes dortmund wir haben zu
besten sinn deshalb sehen müssen wie
proleten nicht proletarier durch den
bundestag liefern und dort politiker
beschimpften was ein unsägliches bild
für uns abgaben
was heißt das das heißt
hier gab es zu wenig führung alexander
gauland ich schätze ihn sehr hat eben
hier keine führung gezeigt im vorfeld er
hat da sehr versagt haben und sich jetzt
einfach zu entschuldigen
ja das war dann ebenso so kann man das
nicht machen
ich bin seit 2013 in unserer partei
schon beim bundesparteitag in berlin
damals seit dieser zeit hat es unserer
partei auf unterschiedlichen gliederung
ebenen immer an führung gemangelt immer
wir hätten immer mehr führung und immer
mehr disziplin eigentlich gebraucht
hatten wir aber nicht und wenn ich dann
das seltsame interview vom höheren
hübner vielen dank
hörte da muss ich sagen der hat auch
nicht verstanden denn er per morgan
haben ihre führung gezeigt mit weniger
gefordert und das im besten sinn
vielen dank dann geht es am roten wagen
mikrofon weiter rotes ok meine verehrten
damen und herren jetzt legen gibt mal
was ihr von manch okay dann scheinen wir
technische probleme zu haben das hat
sich eben gar schon angedeutet mit dem
roten saal mikrofon dann kommen herr
hügel kommen sie sonst einmal kurz nach
vorne ans blaue das dann fangen wir mal
an ich weiß nicht ob die technik da
einmal schauen kann ob damit dem roten
mikrofon
ob das irgendwie wieder funktionstüchtig
geschätzt werden kann so und dann herr
möge so lange jetzt jetzt ja wir hören
hier ständig einigkeit einigkeit
einigkeit aber kann es vielleicht sein
dass manche mitglieder nicht alle aber
manche mitglieder den begriff einigkeit
dazu verwenden jegliche kritik am
personen abzuwälzen und beispielsweise
auch zu sagen wir brauchen einigkeit zu
jedem preis
nein wir brauchen einigkeit nicht zu
wir brauchen ein
in der sache wir brauchen einigkeit auf
sachlicher ebene aber wir brauchen
einigkeit nicht wenn es darum geht
sämtliche extremistische meinungen die
unter anderem auch hermann tisch
vertreten hat denn erinnern wir uns er
hat mal gesagt wir unterscheiden uns von
der npd weniger durch inhaltliche wie in
sachen sondern mehr durch unser
bürgerliches wählerspektrum dass meine
damen und herren das bürgerliche wer
noch spektrum sind wir gerade dabei zu
verlieren wenn wir heute hier abschießen
die müssen uns luft oder nein
kommentaren richtig noch dazu abgeben
einen letzten check kommentar sagen wir
noch gestattet wenn ich anschaue dass
hermann nitsch die einigkeit um er
forderte aber dann die es den
klassischen verteidigungsmaßnahmen schon
durchlaufen hat und mittlerweile sogar
eine eventuelle gegen ihn fragen hat
dann hat er doch wie sieht das erneute
gerede zeit ist deutlich überschritten
vielen dank
dann geht es weiter am blauen saal
mikrofon einigkeit freunde einigkeit das
ist das ist der kern unserer partei und
das brauchen wir auch vorher nach
draußen
das heißt natürlich auch dass der streit
im innen zu lassen aber jetzt müssen wir
mal gucken wer hat wo die einigkeit
gefährdet es gab eine unter den
bundestagsabgeordneten wurde mir gesagt
gab es eine absprache was man macht als
es gegen diesen dieses gesetz ging mit
den masken
da gab es nach strache man hat sich auf
etwas geeinigt einige sind rausgegangen
haben sich haben darauf gepfiffen haben
leute rein geholt die da ein minister an
angesammelt haben und das ganze ist uns
fürchterlich um die ohren geflogen und
das in der zeit vor der
verfassungsschutz geradezu die messer
gegen und setzt einigkeit einigkeit ja
das ist richtig aber das was wir von
denen einfordern
die sie permanent brechen um sich danach
dahinter wieder zu verstecken
das sind jene das sind jene leute hier
auf einem satz von herrn wolken tanzen
das sind jene leute die sich nicht um
hip hop mogul sehen wollen das sehen die
meisten von uns nicht und das sind jede
heute die parteifreunde ausschwitzen
wollen und das dürfen wir nicht zulassen
vielen dank
so eine kurze technische durchsage ich
habe hier eben gerade die nachricht
bekommen dass das rote trikot von
momentan ausfällt die hochdruck daran
gearbeitet dass das wieder funktioniert
das heißt ich bitte jetzt diejenigen
wenn das dort machbar so im
reißverschlussverfahren dass die vorne
einsortiert werden können wir fahren
also mit der debatte jetzt
ausschließlich am blauen saal mikrofon
fort die kollegen prager und wald sind
dort und kümmern sich darum dass das
geordnet vonstatten geht die nächste
wortmeldung bitte unter mikrofon so
liebe freunde ich bin sehr stolz darauf
dass wir eine partei sind in der sich
polizisten wohlfühlen in der sich
soldaten wohl fühlen und sämtliche
beamten durch alle behördenwege hinweg
darauf können wir stolz sein und dankbar
dass wir diesen menschen eine stimme
sein dürfen
doch
das zeigt gleichzeitig dass wir aber
auch als partei weiter cdu kartell diese
menschen über jahre hinweg
vernachlässigt hat dass wir als partei
eine ganz besondere verantwortung
übernehmen muss die verantwortung
definiert sich darin dass wir nicht
zulassen dürfen und auch nicht ein
bisschen futter liefern dürfen dafür
dass diese polizisten
wieso soldaten vielleicht eines tages
nach hause kommt ihren kindern erzählen
muss ja ich wohne suspendiert bei gehalt
um 50 prozent gekürzt weil einige wenige
idioten einheit punkte liefern dass sie
gestern du genau in diesem thema
geblieben sind und uns zeigen wollten
wir müssen haben sie mir das zu beheben
jetzt sagen wir müssen verantwortung
übernehmen für diese person die wir
brauchen hilfe geben wie fielen dann die
redezeit ist vorbei die nächste
wortmeldung mein name ist martina bloß
weil ich bin kreisvorsitzendem breisgau
hochschwarzwald und zudem 18 11 kann ich
ganz konkret beitragen
wir diskutieren hier uns gerade immer
weiter auseinander und deswegen als
allererstes der drv land hat mit den
vorkommnissen vom 18 11 nichts zu tun
gar nichts bei erneuten auf nicht und
die diskussion wird hier in einer art
sippenhaft geführt weder herr gauland
noch erneuten ich habe jetzt beides mal
den doktor weggelassen ist dafür
verantwortlich wenn auf irgendwelchen
seiten entgleisungen passieren
am 18 elfter sind wir gebeten wurden
rebekka sommer einzuladen ich habe das
höchstpersönlich abgelehnt und sie hat
einen weg gefunden über petrus tron in
den bundestag zu gelangen
petra wistron ist überfallartig von der
dame angerufen worden und sein
mitarbeiter diese dame sebastian schulz
in die obhut gegeben und genau in diesen
zehn minuten ist alles das passiert was
uns prozent gekostet hat fielen durch
habe ein bisschen den 1
dass diese diskussion jetzt hier in der
folge geführt wird das ist mir zum ende
kommen wir müssen wirklich einig sein
dankeschön die nächste wortmeldungen
liebe parteifreunde patrioten
ihr habt an so vielen stellen schon
intelligenz bewiesen das allererste mal
als wir in diese partei eingetreten sei
und jetzt lasst euch nicht an dieser
entscheidenden stelle von wenigen
querulanten hinter die fichte führen und
lasst uns dieses schiff nicht zu einem
narrenschiff machen diesen menschen die
eben internet schmutzkampagne nach
schmutzkampagne gegen unseren
vorsitzenden und andere fahren ihm geht
es nicht um die einheit der geht es
letztlich nur darum ihre eigenen
tschechien ist zeugnisse bringen mir
geht es nur darum dass sie auf dem
rücken der hfg weiter ihre ideologie
verbreiten können die wir alle so nicht
mittragen wollen hier geht es nicht im
gegenteil
hier gilt es einige wenige gegen 19
vielen dank
[Applaus]
die nächste worten im blauen saal
mikrofon direkt spanien landesverband
baden württemberg mitglied der
bundestagsfraktion
liebe freunde das was sie hier machen
ist kein spiel
hier geht es um etwas sehr wichtiges und
es muss uns allen klar sein einheit ist
tatsächlich das oberste ziel aber
einheit entsteht nicht dadurch dass ich
jemand verordnet einheit kann man nicht
beschließen einheit entsteht durch
vertrauen und fairness und ja es gehört
dazu dass ein bundessprecher kritische
themen anspricht aber er muss sie so
ansprechen dass sich 40 bis 50 prozent
dieser versammlung nicht vor den kopf
gestoßen fühlt und das ist das was sie
sich wirklich auf die fahne schreiben
müssen erneuten und ein wichtiger punkt
ist aber auch der andere
wir müssen kritische fragen über den
kurs der partei nicht über die medien
spielen die stimmen wir ab und wenn wir
das hier abgestimmt haben
dann machen wir das und dann muss unser
bundessprecher auch diesen weg gehen und
alle anderen akzeptieren diesen weg dann
ja auch so entsteht einheit und fairness
und da müssen wir dran arbeiten und wenn
wir das schaffen dass hier über
abstimmungen den kurs der partei
bestimmt ein bisschen von
pressemeldungen dann sind wir da wo wir
hin wollen und dann gewinnen wir auch
das vertrauen der wähler da draußen
vielen dank vielen dank so die nächste
wortmeldung von blauen drei mikrofone
ist nach vorne kommen herr pollinger war
vor ihnen richtig dann herr bolliger
bitteschön ja vielen dank die hamborner
stellvertreter landesvorsitzender
rheinland pfalz zu nenne ich mal loben
sie haben eben gerade gesagt dass die
querdenker die mutigsten menschen in
deutschland seien die mutigsten menschen
deutschland sitzen hier gerade die fdp
wieder die sieben jahre lagen sich alle
anfallenden lasten für unser land das
sind die motive menschen in diesem land
ist die rede von den leuten betrifft
glauben mit der grundrichtung dass wir
nur als disziplinierte und seriöse
partei erfolgreich sein können wird
jeder übereinstimmen ich war auch mit
einigen spitzen nicht einverstanden und
ich bin dankbar dass er das gerade eben
richtig gestellt hat aber immerhin
darüber kann man streiten aber es ist
doch widersinnig wenn sich hier einig
beschweren dass eine solche diskussion
wenn herr wollten sie führt zu
spaltungen und schlechten medien führen
würde
und jetzt leiht sich das als eigenen
punkt hier auf die tagesordnung setzen
damit ist medial alles noch mehr
überlagert und noch mehr betont wird sie
müssen sich endlich kommen wenn man zum
thema verfassungsschutz kommen dass eine
noch da können wir schlau oder dumm sein
entweder wir begreifen die innere logik
und machen uns nicht angreifen hat sie
getan und selbst den strick an dem sie
uns aufhängen das sollten wir nicht tun
vielen dank vielen dank dann geht es
weiter am plan mikrofon
[Applaus]
bitte liebe liebe mitstreiter ich weiß
udo stein den landtagsabgeordneten baden
württemberg ich habe also eine gewisse
erfahrung was spaltungen angeht york ich
möchte zu deiner rede gestern folgendes
sagen du hast uns dort in gewisser weise
in ein schlechtes licht gerückt ich
hab's dir gestern persönlich auch gesagt
und ich habe die bitte an dich höher auf
über die stöckchen zu springen die dir
die presse inhalt sei es die situation
unserer abgeordneten in berlin sei es
die situation was einzelne und nicht die
mehrheit hier drinnen ständig von sich
geben hört einfach auf immer über diese
presse stöckchen zu springen und dann
können wir unsere themen spielen und die
dringen dann nach außen und das ist der
wichtige punkt
vielen dank der nächste wortbeitrag am
blauen mikrofon
mein name ist eine tester vom
kreisvorstand bad dürkheim
es war hier ein ist ein antrag
angestellt worden der eine absolute
spaltung bedeutet dass ziehen sagte wir
sollen für sympathien werden so nicht
denn vermeiden hat einen antrag hatte
seine rede mit guten worten für
einigkeit gemischt und er ist in der
öffentlichkeit bei den wählern um die
geht es uns ja alle
der frontmann das weiß ich weil ich an
jedem infostand tätig bin und diese rede
hier ist eine dieser antrag ist als
absolut parteischädigend wir haben hier
ein unglaubliches programm zu arbeiten
dazu brauchen wir erneuten vermeiden
machen sie weiter für uns alle
vielen dank die nächste wortmeldung am
blauen mikrofon na klar lieber staehler
der antrag mit dem vorwurf der
spalterischen des spalterischen gebarens
ist wochen alt dieser antrag ist
gestellt worden völlig unabhängig von
der rede von gestern die rede von
gestern wird instrumentalisiert für
einen personalen kampf der geführt wird
seit monaten und seit jahren und er
nichts mit politischen inhalten zu tun
hat sondern personen krieg ist liebe
freunde
ich war mit jörg wollten in der
rentenfrage wie bekannt ist
unterschiedlicher meinung
wir haben uns zusammen diskutiert und
jörg leuten hat diesen antrag mit der 34
mit der dreiviertelmehrheit ja in der
bundes programmkommission mit beschossen
das war integrative arbeit von dem
kollegen der von ganz woanders her kam
zu beginn dieser diskussion
und das machen wir jetzt wir machen hier
zensur der hatten doch war die idee der
freien rede
jetzt machen wir zensur auf die rede
eines spitzenpolitikers dieser partei
bezogen
das kann doch nicht richtig sein wer
lässt sich hier ist momentan ihren die
die die ihn dabei dass sowohl der mekong
und gestern als vorwurf über einen
neunten als trainer übernehmen
dass ihnen die die sie heute hier ist
schon metallisierten lassen vielen dank
mit weiten blauen saal mikrofon hallo
liebe afd
einen schönen guten tag mein name ist
nikolaustag o'polo ich komme aus dem
kreis ludwigsburg baden-württemberg den
landtagskandidat für die landtagswahl
2021 im märz ich bin hier groß geworden
in deutschland mit den deutschen
tugenden leistungsträger zu sein das
heißt fleißig zu arbeiten zu streben
geld zu verdienen zu sparen und
disziplin zu haben
ganz wichtig das hat auch otto rehhagels
griechen nationalmannschaft bei der
asien meister 1014 wurde 2004 worten mit
disziplin erreicht man auch vieles nur
dessen was deshalb betrifft dann zu der
rede des erneuten herrmann hat viele
sachen angesprochen erneuten hat gesagt
disziplinen damit hat er recht wenn wir
prozent gewinnen wollen wir die
kommunale ebene der parteien zu
einzelnen bürgern die uns aufrecht
dieser sachen im bundestag mit der
stören
im bezug bringen verlieren wir die
prozente das ist doch klar und deutlich
aufgrund des damit die prozente verloren
und mich auch wirklich andere sagen
soviel dazu
dann dankt die redezeit es auch
abgelaufen milch hat aber gestern habe
ich darauf hingewiesen am main hat gegen
gleiche freiheit vorgehen wollen müssen
sie um im dvb t auch dafür angerufen
also die redezeit ist vorbei vielen dank
der nächste mittel und der nächste ist
nach vorne gekommen nimmt seinem
rederecht von hier vorne in anspruch
bitteschön andreas ott ich bin
hauptamtlicher bezirk stadtrates
bisheriges berlin-spandau bin aktuell im
landesvorstand und bin
bezirksvorsitzender von spandau meine
damen und herren strategie und taktik
auf der politischen ebene
frau b sehen welche strategie und welche
taktik verfolgen sie die strategie ist
die organisierung der entsprechenden
einzelaktionen nämlich der taktischen
einzelaktionen die am ende des tages zum
erfolg dieser partei führt aber es sind
ja nicht nur sie frau biss ihn oder man
dies ist der hacker wo ist er überhaupt
zeigen sie sich mal hier
sie sind der strippenzieher im
hintergrund der strippenzieher im
hintergrund
das sage ich hier ganz klar und deutlich
der die große hört die neben dazu das
ist die kultur hier im hause der nicht
entscheiden kann und er nicht weiß was
politische kampfkraft und geopolitische
gefechts fährt ist wir haben eine große
kampfkraft gemeinsam der gefechts wert
ist gleich null wenn sie ihre bataillone
im sumpfigen gelände stehen lassen und
in ihre redezeit ist vorbei in unserem
bundessprecher ich kann ihnen hier
nichts verordnung nur eins um 1 bitte
ich sie ganz eindringlich haben sie
haltung backe vielen dank dann geht es
weiter am blauen saal mikrofon am blauen
saal mikrofon liebe parteifreunde mein
name ist robert lambro ich bin der
landessprecher der afg hessen
ich sehe dass sich viele parteikollegen
von der rede von jörg nolte gestern
persönlich angegriffen fühlen ich kann
das verstehen york leuten hat hier aber
am saalmikrofon heute einige dinge
klargestellt ich bitte das auch zur
kenntnis zu nehmen
grundsätzlich stehe hinter tino
propeller und ich stehe hinter erneuten
wir wollen alle deutschland wieder auf
kurs bringen und retten das werden wir
nur zusammen schaffen
im moment bricht hier gerade etwas auf
was seit langem schwelt unkontrolliert
die presse feiert orgien es wird alles
live übertragen
wie kriege auch nachrichten auf meinem
telefon was macht ihr hier gerade in der
halle ihr zerlegt euch diese
diskussionen sind wichtig sie müssen
geführt werden die einheit der partei
liegt uns allen
herzen aber ich glaube nicht dass wir
das auf diese art und weise wie es im
moment machen hinbekommen deswegen bitte
ich sie beschädigen sie weder kino
copala noch jörg moll und lesen sie
diesen antrag ab über die rede wird zu
reden sein von jörg nolte fielen aber
bitte nicht vor den augen der
öffentlichkeit und der presse damit
erledigen wir uns wir wollen deutschland
retten und uns nicht zerlegen
dankeschön dann geht's am blauen das
mikrofon direkt weiter guten tag liebe
parteifreunde mein name ist hanno
bachmann bezirksverband pankow aus
berlin um geht es eigentlich bei diesem
antrag das ist nicht nur eine billigung
sun tag sondern das ist ein geplanter
abwahlantrag das sollte uns allen klar
sein
ich hätte mir gewünscht die
antragsteller hätten um gehabt dann auch
ein abwahlantrag zu stellen
sollte sich das gehört es ist glaube ich
in der debatte deutlich geworden dass
teile der partei sehr unzufrieden war
mit der gestrigen rede das haben sie zum
ausdruck gebracht aber ein
parteisprecher ist eben dafür gewählt
auch mal den finger den finger in die
wunde zu legen das hat er gemacht er
seiner aufgabe nachgekommen
sie haben ihr know how unmut darüber zum
ausdruck gebracht aber überlegen sie
sich bitte genau die tragweite ihrer
entscheidung und lehnen sie diesen
antrag deshalb ab vielen dank
vielen dank dann der nächste am blauen
saal mikrofon jacobi ich möchte der
versammlung gerne eine buchempfehlung
ans herz legen
das ist das buch die torheit die
regierungen ist zeigt an einer reihe von
historischen fallbeispielen wie staaten
regierungen organisationen zu grunde
gehen und zeigt auf dass das immer dann
der fall ist wenn diese organisationen
die fähigkeit zur selbstkritik verlieren
ja und das ist unsere größte große
schwäche momentan wir gehen nämlich auch
diesen weg jetzt könnte ich aus dem
stand ungefähr fünf oder mehr punkte
aufzählen aus der rede von erneuten
gestern die mehr raum detail nicht so
besonders gut gefallen haben
über die man reden muss die vielleicht
auch fehl am platze waren ja
insbesondere über einzelne vokabeln zu
räsonieren und da die kritiker zu machen
ob welche vokabeln verwenden davor da
nicht das muss nicht sein
aber ein kernpunkt war da drin und bei
dem habe ich auch applaudiert und das
war der kernpunkt das für die fähigkeit
zur selbstkritik da wo etwas entgleitet
wo etwas schief läuft erst noch finden
müssen
wir haben regelmäßig wenn etwas schief
so lang und wenn kritik und auch
sanktionen angebracht werden den ruf
nach einigkeit um diese krise hinter dem
rücken oder abzubrechen und der antrag
über den wir jetzt hier verhandeln hat
wieder genau dasselbe ziel die müssen
die prinzip kommen die nötig ist zu
unterbinden und deswegen ist dieser
antrag bitte abzulehnen nicht krank ich
appelliere ganz dringend nein
dann geht's am blauen saal mikrofon
weiter ja meine lieben parteifreunde wir
haben wir zünden gerade unser eigenes
haus an
ich war auch gestern mit vielen punkten
von j neues rede nicht einverstanden
insbesondere den bezug auf das thema
querdenker und otto von bismarck
allerdings disziplin ist der deutsche
tugend wenn das der parteivorsitzende
fordert ist das nichts schlimmes
und man muss sich hier auch die frage
stellen der ursprüngliche antrag war
nicht gestellt bevor die rede gehalten
worden ist warum wurde denn keinen
abwahlantrag gestellt das wäre auf recht
gewesen dann hätte man hier mit offenem
visier kämpfen können und nicht mehr
finde ist gut wenn in unserer partei mit
offenem visier gekämpft wird wir müssen
unsere parteivorsitzende kritisieren
dürfen egal aus welcher richtung die
auch immer ich habe auch viele dinge die
mich an jörg meisten stören ich habe
viele dinge die ich gut finde
aber was wir hier gerade machen es wir
weisen uns einen bärendienst es gibt
dinge da muss darüber diskutiert werden
vergesst nicht nächstes jahres
bundestagswahl letztes jahr ist die
landtagswahl in baden württemberg in
sachsen anhalt und in vielen anderen
bundesländern und wenn wir jetzt hier
die bude anzünden da können wir gehen
wir letztes jahr können wir froh sein
wenn man bunte locken prozent sind
deswegen lehnt diesen antrag bitte ab
vielen dank
dann haben wir ein
geschäftsordnungsantrag am blauen saal
mikrofon kritisch zur geschäftsordnung
hallo ich denke wir sollten jetzt
langsam wieder das tun wofür wir
hingekommen sind also ich bitte das
jetzt zu beenden
ende der debatte ist beantragt so eine
gegenrede das sehe ich nicht keine
gegenrede formal dann stimmen wir ab
gegen redet dort ja am saalmikrofon
gegenrede
ich weiß nicht was das soll so viele
anträge auf abbruch jetzt müssen wir das
wirklich mal in ruhe weiter diskutieren
wobei die betonung darauf liegt in ruhe
und nicht strahlen ja wohl ganz genauso
und ganz in ruhe stimmen wir über diesen
geschäftsordnungsantrag auf ende der
debatte ab wenn sie die debatte an
dieser stelle beenden möchten dann bitte
ich sie jetzt um die blaue stimmkarte
wenn sie die debatte nicht beenden
wollen für die rote stimmkarte nochmal
die blauen bitte das machen wir wieder
elektronisch
soja wenn sie erzählt habe ist das
ordnungsamt indem man die debatte
beendet werden soll die zweite oder
dritte der versuch jetzt dieses kapitel
zu beenden und eine abstimmung über
diesen antrag herbeizuführen ist jetzt
in der abstimmung es war grad versucht
worden per handzeichen und stimmkarte
das abzustimmen aber es war kein
eindeutiges ergebnis also der
versammlungsleitung betragen und noch
mal elektronisch schleifen die waffen
einen hinweis vom ordnungsamt noch drei
sekunden für die abstimmung 21 und dann
bitte ich die abstimmung zu wenden und
dann ist ende der debatte beschlossen
freuen sie sich also wir haben
änderungsantrag ein
denn peter katis gerade beschlossen dass
die debatte beendet werden soll
aber es gibt weitere geschäftsordnungs
anklänge an fragte hier als
änderungsantrag zugestellt ist bei dem
aber nicht klar ist was der eigentlich
genau will der ist von stefan
matuszewski dewis der möge bitte nochmal
am antrags tisch das präzisieren was
denn gemacht werden sollen und dann gibt
es soll es auch einen weiteren
änderungsantrag geben von deinem seitz
der liegt mir aber noch nicht vor
also sobald ich das jetzt verstanden
habe soll die debatte beendet werden und
es änderungsanträge zu diesem berühmten
sn drei der ja als fachbegriff
heutzutage in aller munde ist also zu
diesem antrag nehmen so spalterische
gebaren gegen von jörg merten geht so
wird angeworfen thomas zeitz 2 des
antrags entfällt ersatzlos
der antragsteller erhält das wort zur
begründung im blauen saal mikrofon
die debatte die jetzt hier geführt wird
wird ausschließlich zu diesem
änderungsantrag geführt dass der zwei
des antrags ersatz für ein feldherr sei
zwischen liebe parteifreunde
es geht hier um kritik an unserem
bundessprecher die halte ich für
begründet deswegen habe ich mich auf
holen für den antrag ausgesprochen
allerdings in satz 2 des antrags wird
das verhalten von hamilton in kausalem
zusammenhang mit wahlergebnissen oder
wahlprognosen und umfrageergebnissen
gestellt die frage der kausalität kann
niemand von uns objektiv beantworten es
gibt jeden von uns erkennt leute die
sagen wir wählen die parteien nicht
wegen leuten oder kennt leute die sagen
wir wählen die afg nicht wegen manager
oder wegen höcke beides ist nicht
repräsentativ
außerdem unterliegt die favela zuspruch
großen schwankungen und ist in großen
teilen auch was umfragen angeht
fehlerbehaftet deswegen plädiere ich
dafür diesen satz zu streichen weil wir
darüber in der tat keine aussage treffen
können und niemand soll gehindert werden
seiner kritik an herrn neunten ausdruck
zu verleihen nur weil er sagt aber dass
er dafür jetzt auch in prozenten
verantwortlich gemacht werden kann dafür
davon will ich mich nicht überzeugen
danke herr der satzung dem es geht heißt
er stellt fest dass der eher der
bundesparteitag stellt fest dass der
absturz in der wählergunst kausal mit
dem gestalterischen getan damit
zusammenhängt der soll gestrichen werden
herr mackowski drewes wir haben von
ihnen ja auch ein änderungsantrag hierzu
da sind sie irgendwie einmal das
mikrofon kommen ans mikrofon einfach
daran glauben dann wird das schnell so
ich habe hier einen antrag vorliegen sn
3.2 da fehlt der editier befehl mit dem
sie über den sie gestern mit herrn was
war passiert haben nein also der der
edith tier befehl lautet nur das zu
beschließen alle kunden dritte streichen
und nur darauf setzen
ok dann bitte ich den antrag sn 3.2
einzublenden und danach halten sie das
wort zur begründung und danach machen
wir dann über diese beiden
änderungsanträge
neben verbundene aussprache zu diesen
beiden punkten herr matthias greve ist
erhält das wort zur begründung seines
antrages der ist die eingeblendet ich
lese immer einmal während er auf dem weg
zum rednerpult ist vor eine erfolgreiche
partei arbeit ist nur mit disziplin in
der innen und außen darstellungen
möglich damit eine sache orientierte
parlamentarische arbeit geleistet werden
kann
alle funktionäre und strömungen der
partei sind aufgerufen sich innerlich in
diese parlamentarische arbeit
einzubringen um unseren wählern
alternativen zu bieten
das soll den antrag hier ersetzen hat
sich das getriebe sie haben das wort zur
begründung
jetzt haben sie liebe parteifreunde
ich komme aus gefahren bin im kreistag
ich bin im stadtrat ich bin leitender
arzt
wir haben jetzt hier erfolgreich ein
bisschen dampf abgelassen was sicherlich
gut ist das interessiert jedoch unsere
wähler
mitnichten unsere wähler interessiert
will die straßen ausgebaut gibt es
hebammen vor ort wie sind die schulen
jeder von uns hat dafür eigene ideen
jeder kennt die probleme vor ort was
führen wir hier auf wir führen das auf
was die medien wollen
die nachricht ein hund beißt ein
postboten wird nicht veröffentlicht
jeder weiß ein postbote weist ein hund
das wird veröffentlicht es gibt hier
ganz viele die ihr persönliches
narzisstisches gefühl befriedigen wollen
damit müssen wir auch vor wir müssen
endlich diese kraft in uns finden und
mit sachthemen zu beschäftigen
das wofür sie eigentlich hier sind
nämlich und asozial parteitag unter
programm was wir hier beschlossen haben
gestern mit großer disziplin das zu
verkaufen
von daher habe ich den antrag gestellt
um diese diskussion die wir hier geführt
haben wieder dahin zu bringen was der
wähler von uns will nämlich sacharbeit
dafür ist jeder aufgefordert in jedem
landesverband dann mitzuwirken
deswegen bitte ich sie unsere diskussion
die wir geführt haben wieder zu einem
positiven ende zu bringen und uns zu
bekennen zu einer gemeinsamen ich betone
gemeinsamen sacharbeit darum geht es
vielen dank vielen dank dann haben wir
einen geschäftsordnungsantrag am blauen
sein mikrofon
er liebe partei von ich glaub haben das
thema jetzt wirklich erschöpfend
behandelt
wir sollten die debatte jetzt nicht über
änderungsantrag durch die anträge durch
interview wieder aufmachen
deswegen beantrage ich nicht befassung
mit allen änderungsanträgen und ab
sofortige abstimmung über den
hauptantrag beziehungsweise den ersten
änderungsantrag geht ja da nicht okay
dann beantrage ich nicht befassung mit
allen änderungsanträgen und abstimmung
über den hauptantrag an dieser stelle
und bitte auch gleich mit elektronischen
stimme so dann darf ich einmal kurz
sagen wir haben aktuell 3 kommt eine
gegenrede
wir haben aktuell drei änderungsanträge
das sind die änderungsanträge von frau
beziehen von herrn seitz und informatik
und herrn matschie chef getriebes
gegenrede zum antrag auf nichtbefassung
am blauen saal mikrofon kritisch
ja gegen rhede und zwar aus formalen
gründen der eine antrag der hat sich
thematisch überhaupt nicht mit unserem
antrag aus freiburg befasst der fonds
hat ein bisschen verbessert ich mache
mir den antrag von brandenburg zu eigen
und stimme diesen zu vielen dank das ist
ein antrag der heute noch eingebracht
wurde und der sich auf die rede von jörg
nolte von gestern bezieht
so also das ist
ja also ich habe sie so verstanden
herman densch dass sie den
änderungsantrag von frau beziehen
übernehmen einfach kurz in ihren antrag
richtig love ja meinen nicht
zurückziehen weil ja alles daran hängt
deswegen zu treffen gut sie also dann
bitte ich einmal dann fährt man auf dem
stand sind und gleich wissen wo wir
abstellen dass wir einmal da haben wir
gleich auf der nächsten folie einmal
kurz mit den antrag einblenden dsm 3.1
der ist jetzt übernommen in den
hauptantrag das heißt das ist kein
aktiver änderungsantrag weshalb wir
haben jetzt hier einen antrag auf
nichtbefassung mit den änderungsanträgen
3.2 und 3 punkte 3
das ist einmal von thomas seith dass da
zwei des antrags ersatzlos entfällt und
einmal von herrn matschie travis wie
gerade eben vorgestellt so mit diesen
beiden anträgen ist jetzt die
nichtbefassung und beantragt und wenn es
da kann also großen widerstand gebe ich
hoffe sparen etwas zeit wenn wir es
gleich elektronisch machen wird eine
folie vorzubereiten
wir haben nicht befassung mit sn 32 und
33 das ist hier der geo antrag den bitte
ich vorzubereiten und dann können wir
das gleich elektronisch abstimmen
ja nichtbefassung heißt dass sowohl die
änderung in dem hauptantrag und das
komplette ersetzen durch einen anderen
antrag antragstext den sie gerade vorhin
von julian fleig vorgelesen bekommen
haben überhaupt nicht behandelt werden
darum geht es jetzt in dieser abstimmung
so dann haben wir die folie auch gleich
auf dem schirm mit der einst könnte für
ja stimmen der 24 9 uhr 30 enthalten
nicht befassen mit den änderungsanträgen
sn 32 und 33 von herrn seit und herrn
matschie chef geht drewes das ist die
stimmung bitte einmal die folie
einblenden dankeschön
dann haben sie jetzt 30 sekunden für die
abstimmung zwischen
manche verstehen
also die frage ist ob dieser 3.3 antrag
in dem es im grunde genommen darum geht
dass der ursprüngliche antrag komplett
zurückgezogen wird und gar nicht
verhandelt so gar nicht abgestimmt
werden soll und stattdessen eine andere
formulierung gewählt wird überhaupt
behandelt wird 3 oder nicht 210 bitte
die abstimmung beenden und einblenden
dann ist die nichtbefassung mit diesen
beiden änderungsanträgen beschlossen
heißt darüber natürlich nicht wir waren
sehr nett ende der debatte für den
hauptantrag der wird bei eingeblendet
weil dort ihr was übernommen wurde dass
sie auch alle wissen worüber sich hier
gleich abstimmen
sobald das bereit ist bitte einblenden
der antrag lautet jetzt wie folgt der
bundesparteitag möge beschließen
der bundesparteitag dies belegt dass
spalterische gebaren von bundessprecher
jörg merten und seinen parteigängern er
stellt fest dass der absturz in der
wählergunst causa genau damit
zusammenhängt der bundesparteitag
missbilligt die unterstellung aus der
begrüßungsrede von professor doktor
moden und weist diese unterstellungen
zurück das ist jetzt die
abstimmungsfrage ich denke ich das ist
genau richtig so zur geschäftsordnung
irgendjemand aus dem plenum hat gerade
das hatte ich mit einem so gehört
falsche rufen auch wirklich nur zur
geschäftsordnung die debatte geschlossen
hatten naja so wie ich es verstanden
hatte und wie gerade gesprochen haben
übernimmt er den antrag des
landesvorstandes brandenburg und der
enthält einen satz also also die frage
können wir ja sehr leicht also hermann
ich wollte denen eben übernehmen und der
antrag beinhaltet eine idee befehl dass
es ergänzt werden sollte so habe ich das
verstanden aber hermann nitsch hermann
das kann sich ja einmal kurz erklären
dort
ich wollte den antrag von brandenburg
übernehmen wenn das so möglich ist wenn
sie mir sagen wenn ich ihn komplett
übernehmen dann hängt man eigentlich
antrag gar nicht mehr und dann dürfen
nicht mehr abstimmen dann mache ich das
nicht wenn es so möglich ist so wie es
mir erklärt habt dass ich einfach den
übernehme dann möchte ich dass man dann
wird der text ersetzt ja also ersetzt
also sie wollten nur den blauen dunst
oder blaue teil ja das klären wir aber
kurz wenn das möglich ist heißt im
grunde genommen eine zuspitzung des
parteitages die in der person jörg
merten zuzuordnen ist denn der antrag um
dem ist jetzt geht und die
formulierungen denen es jetzt geht heißt
dass es in diesem abzustimmen den antrag
nur um die rede von jörg leuten von
gestern geht soweit ich das jetzt
verstanden habe und die
versammlungsleitung steckt gerade noch
mal die köpfe zusammen um zu überprüfen
ob das konform mit den satzungs und mit
den juristischen feinheiten so
kompatibel ist und so auch abgestimmt
werden kann
derweil sie sehen dass zwei hände hoch
heißt bei der partei der afg immer ich
möchte einen antrag stellen also einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag der zum
verfahren im laufe des parteitags führen
soll
die frage ist zurzeit sie merken es
vielleicht an der leichten spannung
natürlich hoch politisch weil so meine
damen und herren jetzt erst mal das
ergebnis wir wären so weit aber beim
ersten antrag zur geschäftsordnung am
blauen war mikrofon ich weiß nicht wer
von ihnen beiden zuerst war aber ich
glaube das kriegen sie gehen wir schauen
was mal herzlich danke lieber sagt zur
geschäftsordnung zum verfahren
es kann ein änderungsantrag
definitionsgemäß nur eine zustellung
seien zu einem stamm antrag an das ist
begrifflich gar nicht möglich und
deshalb kann ich nicht durch einen
änderungsantrag den stamm antrag
ersetzen
darum gehe ich denn die die frage ob der
tagesordnung stand oder ich haben sich
aber zur geschäftsordnung gemeldet sie
müssen den geschäftsräumen japan chef
des geschäfts sollen weil sie waren bei
der verfahrens frage was er jetzt
abzustimmen haben und dazu diesen
verfahren rede ich und sage
änderungsanträge setzen ein starker
voraus punkt der klage und alle anderen
auch also grundsätzlich werde sich zur
geschäftsordnung melden dann müssen sie
mit einen antrag stellen dass er denn
wir sind schon andere debatte weil wir
die debatte als solche ansonsten beendet
haben einen augenblick die die botschaft
ist angekommen
einfach gesagt soll der antrag mit
abgestimmt werden in dem es um das
spalterische gebaren von bundessprecher
york leuten geht das ist der sozusagen
der erste antrag der sollte im grunde
genommen ersetzt werden durch einen
änderungsantrag im wort und im inhalt
durch den antrag der stellvertretenden
landesvorsitzenden birgit pessin in der
es nur um die rede von jörg leuten geht
von gestern in dem antrag von ihr steht
das missbilligen es heißt ja nochmal es
der bundesparteitag möge beschließen
dass die unterstellungen aus der
begrüßungsrede zu missbilligen sind und
die frage ist ob dieses zulässig ist
oder nicht im verfahren so sie sehen die
hände wieder oben noch einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag
frage wollte ich nur vorhin noch
abschließend sagen denn die frage ist
natürlich was passiert eigentlich wenn
dieser antrag mit mehrheit angenommen
wird vom parteitag
ja
ja wir hatten kann ich ihnen derzeit in
der gesucht wird nach einem ordentlichen
verfahren um diese änderungsanträge auch
in allen juristischen einwandfreien
verfahren einzubringen oder auch nicht
noch mal sagen es gab eine lange debatte
um das für und wider es gab unterstützer
von jungen leuten es gab redebeiträge
die sich mit ihm kritisch
auseinandergesetzt haben und wir haben
dagegen war blauen saal mikrofon
bitteschön
liebe freunde die debatte müsste uns
eigentlich alle wie sie jetzt gelaufen
ist betroffen machen
ich dachte eigentlich wir wollten besser
sein
zusammen als die sozialdemokraten heute
haben wir es geschafft in dieser
diskussion das niveau einer spd nach
unten hin zu unterlaufen
deshalb stelle ich den folgenden
geschäftsordnungsantrag weil wir uns
glaube ich in der debatte jetzt auch
noch technisch verlaufen haben und damit
eine öffentlichkeitswirksamkeit
herstellen wollen ich bin nämlich der
meinung von albrecht glaser und um das
jetzt vielleicht in würde und vernünftig
damit wir hinter den kulissen damit
unser bundesvorstand und vielleicht auch
andere gremien reden können stelle ich
den antrag nichtbefassung absetzung
dieses topfes lassen uns dieses
unwürdige spiel an dieser stelle hier
noch beenden
[Applaus]
und geht damit allen personen die
möglichkeit mit gesichtswahrung aus
dieser debatte auszutreten daraus zu
lernen wir haben auch viele positive
aspekte gehört und lasst uns bitte nicht
dass wirklich geile resultat von gestern
jetzt heute kaputt machen ihr habt ihr
jetzt noch die chance deshalb absetzung
des sports und lasst uns weitermachen
bitte kurze nachfrage herr gottschalk
nicht weglaufen nicht weglaufen
gottschalk eine kurze nachfrage der
antrag lautet ihr dort jetzt sofortige
absetzung hätten das tier dort habe der
top da sind auch noch alle anderen sache
anträge drin es wäre dann die
nichtbefassung mit dem antrag oder
zentral genau dieser nun außerdem der
extra genau ganz januar also ist nicht
der topf in den pop sind noch andere
sachen anträge mit drin aber die
nichtbefassung dann wäre der techniker
begriff ein lehman ii fragt es in drei
eindringlich an alle lasst uns nach
diesem freitag die hand geben jetzt habt
ihr die möglichkeit an tischen lasst uns
politisch vernünftig an langanke
dankeschön eine gegenrede zu diesem
geschäftsordnungsantrag ebenfalls am
blauen saal mikrofon
liebe freunde ich bitte euch zu bedenken
dass es nicht das erste mal ist dass er
mir gestern veranstaltet hat wir haben
die fraktions spaltungen gehabt wir
haben eine ganz üble rede zu einem
parteitag inhalten halb der genauso
begangen übergangen hat begonnen hat wie
gestern hier in dem er die hälfte der
mitglieder beschimpft hat ich bin auch
dafür dass wir wirklich hier sacharbeit
machen aber er muss der erneuten muss
endlich mal begreifen dass er so nicht
weitermachen kann ohne dass er die
hälfte der partei verliert und deshalb
müssen wir in irgendwie ermahnen oder
was auch immer aber erkannt und darf so
nicht weitermachen
sonst ist das denn das ende der stehe
deshalb bitte lasst uns darüber
lasst uns darüber abstimmen vielen dank
dafür eine gegenrede zum
geschäftsordnungsantrag auf nicht weiter
befassung mit diesem antrag sn 3
wir sind in einem
geschäftsordnungsantrag
er bot willkommen ist die abstimmung
darüber danach danach müssen wir ihren
geschäften verkauft erstmal bearbeiten
wir diesen hier zu ende und das machen
wir gleich elektronisch so bitte ja eine
folie vorzubereiten nichtbefassung mit
dem antrag sn 3 wird eine folie
vorzubereiten
nichtbefassung mit dem antrag sn 31 jahr
29 3 enthaltungen sie haben eine halbe
minute zeit die abstimmung ist eröffnet
zwei stunden lang ungefähr hat die
partei über diesen tagesordnungspunkt
debattiert der versuch ist nun das ganze
nicht zur abstimmung zu lassen denn eine
abstimmung in welche richtung auch also
in die eine richtung wäre im grunde
genommen für die partei eine krise die
sie dann zur richtigen hetze durch die
abstimmung zu schließen ein ergebnis
einzublenden
dann ist nichtbefassung mit diesem
antrag beschlossen gemäß antrag sehe ich
jetzt aktuell nicht mehr dann gemäß des
verfahrens anfangs bote von heute morgen
gehen wir jetzt zurück in den
tagesordnungspunkt 12
damals hat der showdown nicht
stattgefunden
es gab keine entscheidungen die der
parteitag fällen müsste denn das will
ich ihnen noch nachtragen
hätte es eine mehrheit für diesen antrag
gegeben wäre es für die politische
zukunft von jupp leuten sicherlich
schwierig gewesen sein amt weiter
auszuführen
nach diesem hoch emotionalen und sehr
tief geführten programmpunkt verlassen
jetzt hier sehen ist verlassen einige
delegierte den saal
das gibt mir gelegenheit zu alexander
keller zu schalten der im saal ist und
die ganze debatte von weit weg oder mit
mit akustischen signalen direkt von vor
ort verfolgt hat
ja wir sind im pressesaal direkt neben
der halle wo dieser parteitag
stattfindet ihr ein denkwürdiger
parteitag der jetzt gerade so ein
bisschen ja ausgeronnen ist es ist ein
unglaublich dramatische ablauf hat sich
aufgebaut in der frage ob jörg merten
durch spalterische bahn die der partei
geschadet hat oder nicht und ob er damit
auch kausal mit verursacht hätte dass
die kfd in der wählergunst regelrecht
abgeschmiert wäre jetzt am ende moment
sei es ja so aus als gäbe es vielleicht
sogar eine mehrheit für diesen antrag
den parteichef natürlich enorm schaden
zugefügt hätte jetzt plötzlich gab es
eine mehrheit für eine nichtbefassung
mit diesem antrag das heißt darüber wird
jetzt gar nicht gesprochen die auf dem
fdp-parteitag objekten seiner eigenen
partei schaden zugefügt hat
offensichtlich war vielen der über 500
delegierten die diskussion jetzt die wir
in den letzten anderthalb stunden hier
am stück übertragen haben einfach zu
viel es war alles gesagt so und jetzt
muss ich höre ich dass wir noch einen
saal geben sollen weiter zu hören
langs gesundheitszustand
wir als fraktionsspitze wünschen diesem
parteitag ihnen allen ein weiteres gutes
gelingen und lassen sie mich noch eins
sagen aus meiner erfahrung in der
führung einer nicht kleinen fraktion
wir müssen uns alle irgendwo am riemen
reißen uns konzentrieren auch
sachdebatten und in diesem geiste
streiten in der sache persönlich im ton
sollten wir auch diesem parteitag
weiterführen
in diesem sinne alles gute
[Applaus]
das waren die worte die alice model im
auftrag von alexander gauland an den
parteitag gerichtet hat alexander
gauland ich habe es vorhin erwähnt
fühlte sich nicht gut musste den
parteitag verlassen und wir wünschen
noch mal an dieser stelle alles gute für
seine gesundung aber das gibt mir jetzt
die gelegenheit zurück zu alexander
keller zu geben
jetzt sind wir zurück hier im auf dem
parteitag im pressesaal in kalkar neben
dem parteitag sword der messehalle hier
in kalkar ich hatte gerade gesagt da hat
sich jetzt in dieser diskussion um
hubert görg leuten und die frage ob er
tatsächlich der partei schaden zugefügt
hat eine enorme welle aufgebaut die
jetzt etwas sozusagen am strand aus rind
also es gibt jetzt keine entscheidung
darüber ob jörg leuten der partei
schaden zugefügt hat und wir wollen zu
diesem zu dieser diskussion zu der frage
um die rolle von jürgen otten dem
vorwurf der schon vor dem parteitag
bestand dass er spalterisch tätig sei in
der partei spaltete schutz gebannt zeige
aber auch die gestrige rede die das für
viele noch einmal unterstrichen hat dass
er hier in der partei offensichtlich
versucht seine position durchzusetzen
gegen positionen die er nicht möchte wie
zb die des flügel mannes björn röcke
also eher als konservativ gemäßigter
gegen eine klare rechtsauslegung von afd
mitgliedern delegierten auch mandats und
funktionsträger dass darüber jetzt noch
mal abgestimmt werden sollte in einem
antrag und jetzt hat der parteitag doch
entschieden sich damit nicht zu befassen
möglicherweise auch um den
parteivorsitzenden zu schützen
wir wollen über diesen vorgang ganz
kurzen gesprächen mit alexander kissler
von der neuen zürcher zeitung
er ist berliner korrespondent früher
journalist beim cicero herr kessler
diese entscheidung die jetzt etwas
ungewöhnlich war also keine keine
abstimmung auf dem parteitag die
möglicherweise sehr knapp ausgegangen
wäre
über das so genannte gestalterische bahn
von jörg leuten stärkt das jetzt den
parteivorsitzenden schwächt es ihnen
schlecht in diese diskussion die über
ihn geführt worden ist er hat ja auch
noch mal das wort ergriffen wie es
dieser vorgang jetzt zu bewerten auch
unter dem aspekt dass wir ja gerade
erlebt haben
man will sich jetzt doch nicht nach so
langer diskussion mit dem antrag
befassen
ja dem man sich jetzt auf den
verfahrensweg entschieden hat diesen
antrag auszubremsen abermals sehr knapp
wie alles auf diesem parteitag 53 47
prozent für eine nichtbefassung
und in dem man sich für diese
nichtbefassung entschieden hat mir ja
faktisch diesen antrag abgelehnt
das ist im prinzip das gleiche ergebnis
dass man mutmaßlich gehabt hätte wenn
man gefragt hätte hat herrn eugen durch
sein verhalten zur spaltung der afg und
damit zu den schlechten wahlergebnissen
beigetragen insofern lässt sich im
prinzip das fazit von gestern wenngleich
unter gewissen dramatischeren vorzeichen
noch einmal aufrufen
die abstimmungen laufen knapp zu gunsten
des alten lagers er hat knapp die hälfte
gegen sicherheit knapp die hälfte für
sich er wollte diese offenen
auseinandersetzung er wusste dass dieser
antrag vorliegt da wurde vor seiner
gestrigen rede gehalten er hat die
abstimmung wenn auch auf dem
verfahrenswege bekommen und er hat sie
knapp gewonnen insofern könnte er
eigentlich zufrieden sein
die partei ist nicht explodiert aber
implodiert hier wurde gebetsmühlenartig
ein begriff ständig immer wieder von
allen lagern benutzt einigkeit kann ein
parteivorsitzender der knapp mehr als
die hälfte der delegierten hier hinter
sich hat denn eigentlich eine partei
integrieren kann er einigkeit herstellen
kann er als akzeptierter respekt hierbei
parteivorsitzender überhaupt im amt
bleiben das ist sehr sehr schwierig
formal wird sich natürlich im amt
bleiben
zumal vor dem superwahljahr 20 21 klar
ist natürlich wenn man sich hier die
vertretungen nach den landesverbänden
angeschaut hat dass er wirklich keine
schnitte macht keinen stich macht bei
den brandenburgern den thüringern vor
allem das hat man gemerkt obstruktion
ablehnung bis hin zu berufen rote karte
etc
andererseits muss natürlich auch sagen
dass beispielsweise landesverband
thüringen ungefähr so viele auf den
mitgliedern uhr hat wie allein der
regierung bezirk köln in nordrhein
westfalen als um rein mengenmäßig ist
thüringen ein kleines land und die 23
bis 23 prozentiger rücke der stolz
aufruft sind für die gesamtpartei
gesehen relativ wenig das heißt aber
dass höckel lager nennen wir es mal so
hier auf dem parteitag hat zumindest
akustisch ziemlich viel rabatz gemacht
absolut ist das trotzdem dass da eine
lautstarke minderheit versucht hat den
parteitag sozusagen zu pionieren also
sozusagen für sich zu
instrumentalisieren kann man das so
sagen
die lager waren natürlich sehr laut hat
abbas gemacht das darf natürlich letzten
endes auch es hat dadurch natürlich auch
eine eine schein größe inszeniert die
ist auf die gesamtpartei bezogen nicht
hat ist ein sehr geschlossenes lager an
sehr klar
rechtsaußen positioniertes lager da sind
natürlich die fronten derart verhärtet
nach der rede von leuten dass ich da
überhaupt keine versöhnung auch nur
denken kann man muss eigentlich sagen
zweitens taktik war oder strategie war
gewisse landesteile gewissermaßen
aufzugeben größte landespartei teile
aufzugeben und zu hoffen dass die
gemäßigten in anderen parteien eine so
starke mehrheit gewinnen das vielleicht
dies zu vernachlässigbaren größe wird
das was gerade passiert ist ist ja nicht
nur im klassischen tv bei phoenix
übertragen worden sondern auch in den
livestream social media kanäle
möglicherweise haben jetzt mehrere
millionen zugesehen ist das für die
partei eigentlich gut stärkt das die afg
sie den mut hat hier vor versammelter
mannschaft vielen zaungästen wie der
jetzt zu gucken sich so zu entblößen
aber gleichzeitig auch zu sagen das muss
jetzt sein da muss jetzt ein reinigen
der diskussionsprozess rein und
letztendlich stark dass auch das
selbstbewusstsein der partei oder geht
das in die andere richtung zu sagen also
jetzt irgendwann mal hier ist die
sollbruchstelle schon der erste haar ist
zu sehen im gebälk und irgendwann mal
knackt
wir haben jetzt schon mehrere haarrisse
gesehen wie stark das gebälk ist um in
ihrem bild zu bleiben das ist die frage
erneuten hat jetzt auf die mutmasslich
gemäßigten teile noch einmal etwas beton
eingegossen in der hoffnung dass der
herr ist sich woanders entlädt
kurzfristig würde ich sagen nutzt ist
der afg nicht sich hier vor versammeltem
großem publikum hier gegenseitig
übertragen gesprochen an die wäsche zu
gehen aufeinander einzuschlagen
auch mit teilweise sehr erregten
lautstarken äußerungen
mittelfristig könnte es schon sein dass
ich vielleicht leser durchsetzt lieber
ein reinigendes gewitter vor großer
kulisse als jahrelanges hinterzimmer
kugler
ich muss da manchmal nachdenken an dem
parteitag von 199 bei den grünen als um
die frage in radikal pazifismus oder
nato einsatz zustimmen
das wollte vor großer bühne verhandelt
und hat kurzfristig vielleicht nicht
aber mittelfristig den grünen doch sehr
sehr stark genutzt
und vielleicht ist mittelfristig hier
auch eine positive wirkung eines solchen
reinigen gewitter zu sehen das müssen
wir
mit blick auf die bundestagswahl in zehn
monaten haben aber einige hier gesagt so
eine diskussion die müssten wir
eigentlich scheuen wie der teufel das
weihwasser das schadet uns eigentlich
wenn sie jetzt sagen im moment nutzt es
der afg nicht könnte es trotzdem die
partei wieder konsolidieren wir das
nichtvergessen nächstes jahr nicht nur
die bundestagswahl auch sechs
landtagswahlen in vielen bundesländern
die da zur wahl stehen hat die afd ja
beim letzten mal sehr gut abgeschnitten
hat sie auch eine menge zu verlieren
was könnte das jetzt auch die projektion
war jahr 2021 bedeuten also wir haben ja
zunächst auch noch mal dann die
listenaufstellung parteitage das wird
sehr sehr spannend und auch der wirt
hamburg auch immer holz mit sinkenden
umfrageergebnissen zwischen 7 und 8
prozent nur werden natürlich auch die
listenplätze immer umkämpfter immer
wichtiger mancher wird dort seine
karriereträume beerdigen müssen das
heißt man wird nun auf der ebene sehen
müssen welche linie sich durchsetzen die
afg kann nur froh sein dass nicht schon
am gerne mal februar wahlen sind sondern
das glaube ich erst im märz los geht und
sich dann bis in den herbst hinein zieht
jetzt wird natürlich jede landtagswahl
wird zum seismografisch ein gradmesser
für die eine oder andere richtung
es kommt natürlich darauf an wie die
gesamtpartei und da würde ich auch die
fraktionsführung in berlin die momentan
keine allzu gute figur macht ein
beziehen sich verhält man muss nur die
richtigen worte finden das richtige
personal tableau auch da gibt es große
fragezeichen dahinter
und dann muss ich dann vor allen dingen
einigen was sind die programmatischen
schwerpunkte dieses reinigende gewitter
kommt immer zu einem falschen zeitpunkt
immer und vielleicht war es gut dass es
jetzt ergangen ist und nicht noch näher
an bundestagswahlen aus fdp sicht aber
muss das wirklich abraten es ist auf
jeden fall klar dass die afg in sehr
schwerem fahrwasser sich gelegt worden
hatte jetzt ein endgegner das messer auf
die brust gesetzt er hat ja vorhin
gesagt wenn ihr euch traut
dann stellt auch gefälligst den
abwahlantrag wenn er mich loswerden
wollte die nummer hat er nicht exklusiv
das hatte annegret kramp karrenbauer
beim letzten cdu-parteitag letzten
dezember schon mal gemacht wenn man
jetzt die zukunft der afc betrachtet
glauben sie dass er im nächsten jahr als
vorsitzender wiedergewählt wird wieder
gewählt werden kann das war ja der
anfang der frage bei der ersten frage
hier
interview dass das möglicherweise sogar
gestärkt hat also ich glaube dass er
nächstes jahr keine schlechteren
aussichten hat wiedergewählt zu werden
als jetzt sie waren vorher schon knapp
aber es war eine relative überwiegende
wahrscheinlichkeit dass erschossen hat
man hat jetzt auch am applaus gemerkten
auch unter reihenfolge der wortbeiträge
dass ich von wortbeitrag zu wollte
eigentlich das pendel etwas mehr in
seine richtung bewegt hat der hat auch
am anfang einige über griffigkeit seiner
gestrigen rede zu korrigieren versucht
es war ein hohes risiko es war auch
momentan auf den ersten blick gesehen
sehr uns strategisch sehr sehr unklug
hier so frontal die breitseite zu wählen
gegen die parteiinternen kritiker ich
halte es allerdings für nicht
ausgeschlossen
dadurch dass sich nun auch die gegner
offen haben zeigen müssen bis auf herrn
hüppe wie gesagt er eben ne stunde die
ganze zeit dabei saß das auch nun sich
sie positionieren müssen und einer
partei kann es immer nur gut tun wenn
man eine solche tat offen geführt als
über soziale medien eine frage noch der
sich visuell verkriechen der
gegenspieler von jörg heute nämlich
blöcke wird er noch von der af de wer
dennoch froh und wahrhafte ja ja er wird
in seinem typischen thüringischen
landesverband froh bleiben also
gewissermaßen der der der kleine könig
kalle wirsch sage ich mache meine kinder
kinderstück aus der augsburger
puppenkiste aufzugreifen
er kann dort mehr oder minder schalten
und walten wie er will er hat diesen
diesen landesverband sehr hart unter
kontrolle mit einem sehr scharf rechts
ausgelegten programm
dadurch wird der in thüringen und auch
über thüringen hinaus nie anschlussfähig
werden für andere parteien
er kann eigentlich nur also in der
opposition seiner macht stärken aber er
ist weiter denn je entfernt von jeder
politischen gestaltungskraft abseits der
oppositionellen
insofern glaube ich dass die die provinz
oder regional karriere des planegger
eigentlich zementiert ist also thüringen
als hocker reservat
ich bedanke mich bei alexandra weil
alexander kissler neue zürcher zeitung
so ist es korrekt chor wir über vielen
dank dass sie dabei so meine kamera ist
hier und wir geben zurück zu thomas
müller
vielen dank alexander keller sie sehen
an den tischen dass nach diesem doch
sehr dramatischen und emotionalen
tagesordnungspunkten der iss um den
bundessprecher leuten ging und um dessen
äußerungen gestern und auch als die
haltungen vergangenen monaten etwas
leerer geworden ist es gab einen antrag
auf unterbrechung des parteitages um
diese debatte erst einmal zu verdauen
die ja knapp an einem existenziellen
wahlverfahren der es darum ging ob man
darüber abstimmen soll oder nicht vorbei
geschrammt ist debattiert wurde zwei
stunden lang jetzt sind wir in der
debatte nicht in der debatte sollten
dann in der wahl von rechnungsprüfern am
pult steht eberhard aus baden
württemberg der seine wahlrede für den
rechnungshof erhält wir haben die
finanzen als achillesferse
wenn wir da nicht wenn mir war zu sagen
dann haben wir 50 prozent der miete
kaputt und das zweite ist was mir als
achilles ferse haben ist der der frieden
innerhalb der partei aber ich sage ihnen
noch mal was zum rechnungsprüfer wir
haben das risiko wenn die nicht stimmen
und da gibt es eine neue rechtsprechung
vom bundesverfassungsgericht dass der
bundestagspräsident uns in toto
ausschließen kann von der staatlichen
parteienfinanzierung die wissen wir zum
schluss kommen und wenn dieser fall
eintritt an 54 prozent der einnahmen
deshalb ist es von zentraler bedeutung
dass wir die finanzen in ordnung haben
und die auch in zukunft regelmäßig
prüfen
so und jetzt sage ich ihnen noch etwas
persönliches zu mir ich bin bereit
obwohl es ja die zeit kostet wir haben
das bisher ja auch schon so gemacht in
baden württemberg in niedersachsen aber
in bayern landesverbände zu prüfen wenn
die das möchten
herzlichen dank herr brett ihre redezeit
gibt es fragen an den kandidaten die
gibt das bitte ich die
kollegen das vorzubereiten
drüben müssen die karten eingeworfen
werden liebe freunde das ist jetzt schon
zu spät
wir lassen das jetzt noch diese
tagesordnungspunkte wahl von
rechnungsprüfern sind im gegensatz zu
dem was heute vormittag auf dem
parteitag das hier ist sozusagen
schwarzbrot und das gibt uns die
gelegenheit nochmal zur constantia
bratzke ins studio zu schalten
ja ich habe das natürlich gespannt
verfolgt wird professor schröder wir
haben ja wirklich dran gehangen an
dieser debatte
das war außergewöhnlich das war in der
chef hatten sie das erwartet
in dieser form habe ich es nicht
erwartet weil eigentlich war ja alles
auf sozialpolitik auf einheit
konditioniert und dann erleben wir das
was wir von der af deser 2013 kämen
offene saalschlacht der
unterschiedlichen gruppen gegeneinander
und aus meiner sicht war das neue dass
sich das läuten lage sehr gut
organisiert präsentierte und damit ja
fast 80 prozent der redebeiträge 80
prozent zustimmung organisierte
währenddessen hatte der eigentliche
gegner unsichtbar war
ich stehe hinter hast also es gab eine
rednerliste die wurde schon relativ früh
geschlossen und da gab es zwischendurch
auch mal den vorwurf dass das wollten
lager sozusagen diese rednerliste
gekapert hätte aber ist das ein schiefes
bild was ich da jetzt übertragen hat
weil es war also überwiegend waren waren
waren das buch reden die dort kamen die
gesagt haben gute pace hat uns letztlich
anders gefallen was er morgen gesagt hat
aber es musste jetzt auch mal raus und
das geht so nicht und wir wollen ja
keine entweder die 2.0 sein hat zum
beispiel einer auf keinen fall ein
schiefes bild man muss sich immer klar
machen die laut starken die
aufmerksamkeit erreichenden ost
landesverbände machen so etwa 15 prozent
der mitglieder aus dh das überwältigende
crowe ist in landesverbänden organisiert
die er den neuen kurs mittragen es auf
baden württemberg ja die sind alle ein
bisschen gespalten das ist schon klar
aber die grundorientierung ist eher
richtung leuten und insofern ist das
neue was wir jetzt erlebt haben dass der
parteivorsitzende wirklich
führungsstärke bewiesen hat dass er hier
eine linie vorgegeben hatten der preis
dafür wird sein dass die ost verbände
und dass die etwas radikaleren kräften
jetzt doch in eine defensivposition
gekommen sind wie wir sie bisher nicht
erlebt hat eine klare positionierung
auch ost gegen west ganz klare
positionierung ost gegen west alle ost
beiträge hier im plenum waren gegen
leuten gewesen und die mehrheit der west
beiträge ganz klar für wollten dafür
dass dann hinten kann man das zu ende
denkt dann heißt es eigentlich dass die
partei sich sich hier den ersten
wirklich den ersten schritt zu einer
spaltung getan hat ja aber die haben
dieses dilemma seit 2013 aber es ist
immer wieder es immer wieder schafft zum
tragen gekommen insofern haben wir da
gar nicht so eine neue situation die
neue situation scheint mir darin zu
bestehen das bauland bald gehen wird und
das wollten ja nicht nur gegen die ost
verbände und gegen die radikalen
geschossen hat sondern gegen die
bundestags fraktionsspitze und das ist
schon eine spannung die nicht ganz
uneitel ist weil das zentrum der afg ist
eigentlich die bundestagsfraktion die
haben die ressourcen die haben die
kameras auf ihrer seite
und insofern ist die spannung zwischen
der parteispitze und der fraktionsspitze
ist ein problem wenn man an das
superwahljahr 2021 wie wollen sie denn
dann überhaupt dass es war nicht
bestehen wenn wenn es da diesen dissens
gibt und jetzt auch noch auch noch dass
wir auch noch sagen dass natürlich kino
kubala und houston jetzt auch nicht ein
herz und eine seele sind absolut jetzt
mal in der inhaber der auseinander haben
das relativ früh jetzt gemacht das muss
man ja aus sehen wir sind jetzt im
november und das superwahljahr wird so
ab mai juni ins rollen kommen in den
landesverbänden schon etwas früher weil
die landtagswahlen ja schon im märz sind
aber man hat eine gewisse distanz dazu
und die afg wird nicht gewählt weil sie
einheitlich ist und weil sie konstruktiv
ist sondern sie wird gewählt weil sie
gegen das establishment ist und da ist
übrigens eine zweite linie und das ist
durchaus eine gefahr dass die ganze
corona debatte
hier hatten klare worte gefunden wie wir
sie bisher vom spitzenpersonal der afg
nicht gehört haben dass er gewarnt hat
vor dem verfassungsfeindlichen vor den
radikalen positionen der korona dass ich
heute ganz auch einige die dagegen
gehalten habe und haben gleich gesagt
also das kannst du nicht machen weil wir
sind der verlängerte arm der straße
und wenn du hier unsere akteure auf der
straße beleidigt kritisierst dann
schneelast du unsere wahlmöglichkeiten
das ist eine spannung die man schon
sehen die un mit dahinter muss man ja
sehen es gibt ja die hoffnung dass man
mit corona wieder eine ähnliche welle
und ähnlichen rückenwind organisieren
kann wie mit der debatte gegen die
migration 1 fangen auch immer mit das
war der verfassungsschutz der die partei
beobachtet und wo er war ja dass das die
klare angriffe auf jack morton war das
hat ja auch alexander gauland gestern
schon gesagt das ist mir zuviel
einknicken zuviel kotau vor den
verfassungsschutz da kam immer wieder so
sachen zurück na ja wer
wir müssen halt wissen was wir sagen und
wie wir sagen aber meinen ton tun wirst
dann doch anders
die debatte schon manchmal etwas
komischen dreiklang kann das hat ein
geschmäckle weil selbst die leute wo man
den eindruck hat die gehören zum
gemäßigten flügel die erweckten dann in
ihren statements sind also es geht
eigentlich nur um stilfragen es geht um
wortwahl
es geht darum dass man nicht alles sagen
sollte was man denkt und das lässt
natürlich wieder neue unklarheiten
aufkommen wie verfassungstreue sind die
überhaupt die hier als gemäßigte
auftreten also das war auch eine sehr
heikle gratwanderung die da einige
versucht haben hinzulegen aber klar ist
verfassungsschutz wird die afg im jahre
2021 so beschäftigen wie kaum eine
andere geschichte weil die
landesverfassung dienste haben
angekündigt dass sie scharf drauf
schauen und damit ist natürlich die
wählbarkeit der partei im bürgerlichen
lager sehr stark eingeschränkt da gab es
ja auch ein ganz starken ganz starken
hinweis so redebeitrag von einer jungen
frau darf
dazu die definitiven augen den
fraktionen solchen der
bundestagsfraktion sind schon leute
ausgetreten weil sie befürchteten dass
ihre berufliche karriere dadurch
eingeschränkt wird man also das muss man
alles mit berücksichtigen und dann kommt
der vorwurf der kritiker von leuten die
sagen ja der instrumentalisiert den
verfassungsschutz und eigentlich kann
man dadurch nicht erkennen dass wir
größere chancen haben
also sollten wir doch lieber die bisher
radikale spielart beibehalten weil die
uns unterm strich doch mehr
mobilisierungs möglichkeiten einräumt
und das ist das dilemma es gibt für die
seitenlinie keine wirkliche
erfolgsgarantie
also es nicht so wenn man sagt wir sind
jetzt auf dem boden der fdp und die
verfassungsschützer lassen uns außen vor
dass dann also der weg der afg zu einer
erfolgreichen partei gebannt ist sondern
das gegenteil könnte der fall sein dass
sie enorm verlieren und ihre
mobilisierungskraft in den
straßenkämpfen und in den
bewegungsorientierten zonen dadurch
eingeschränkt das liegt daran dass die
motten linie nicht das thema hat und und
sondern eine ganz normale partei arbeite
eigentlich machen wir auf diese
zuspitzung selbst ein guter punkt weil
sie wollten ja eigentlich hier renten
parteitags sozialpolitik parteitag
und es hat sich in der debatte um das
rentenpapier gezeigt dass wirklich
einige ganz solide sicher eingearbeitet
haben aber das waren ganz wenige es ist
keine richtige debatte aufgekommen und
das was sie jetzt erreicht haben in der
rentenpolitik bleibt ja weit hinter dem
zurück was alle anderen parteien im
bundestag seit 30 jahren bereits
aufgearbeitet haben also da ist kein
spirit rauszuziehen da ist kein neues
thema mit dem sie wirklich realisieren
können sondern das ist ein stück weit
normalität dass sie jetzt akzeptiert
haben wir haben das umlage orientierte
system und da kann man an diesen und
jenen stellschrauben drehen das ist
technik das ist aber kein emotionales
wirklich in die grundlagen der
gesellschaft hinein führen das thema mit
neuen mobilisierungs möglichkeiten
also neue mobilisierungs möglichkeiten
sind gesucht haben für die afg ist
könnte querdenker sein es könnte corona
sei aber gesagt aber so wichtig was
bietet sich nach wie vor nicht nein auf
keinen fall im gegenteil bei den neuen
themen ist er die spaltung linie wieder
interessant wir hatten das ja schon ein
paar mal berührt hier wenn es so ist
dass die hälfte der afg sympathisanten
auch der auffassung ist dass der
regierungskurs in fragen von corona okay
ist dann ist es gefährlich auf diese
karte zu setzen das war bei der
flüchtlingsfrage anders da war es ein
ganz klare position
so wird denn jetzt der debatte um das
ich sag jetzt mal anführungsstrichen
weil das sollte ja mehrfach gesagt
parteischädigendem verhalten von jörg
morton weitergeführt überall oder hinter
den verschlossenen türen gibt es eine
nacht der langen messer im
bundesvorstand
also ich würde vermuten das wird überall
geführt werden da gibt es keine
sonderzone die dafür vorbehalten sein
wird weil mit dem öffnen der büchse der
pandora also wenn der vorsitzende so
ausgeht wie er das gemacht hat dann
eröffnet er eine debatten lage die sich
nicht mehr eingrenzen lässt und
gleichzeitig hat er aber heute
führungsstärke bewiesen und das ist der
deutliche unterschied zur hacke harke
ist eigentlich unsichtbar und man hat ja
sogar im interview mit phoenix den höcke
degradiert den mann gesagt es ein
provinzpolitiker aus thüringen ich hätte
in einer blase lebte aber auf der
bundesebene keine relevanz hat insofern
muss man sich mit ihm gar nicht
beschäftigt das ist natürlich nicht ganz
richtig weil der hacke ist über die
provinz hinausgehend schon eine referenz
für die radikaleren kräften aber er
repräsentiert keine afd
die zukunftsthemen angeht sondern er ist
natürlich derjenige der die
vergangenheit der das romantische der
das radikale des extreme verkommt da
muss die afg wenn sie sich denn dazu
entscheidet die verhältnisse klar zu
stellen auch ganz klar adressierung und
sagen wie viele wie viel und macht und
wie viel einfluss ein eindeutiges lager
hat in ihrer partei und was was sie
wirklich wollen also das ist dann ja
auch wirklich wohl schwieriger angaben
also insofern gab es keine alternative
eigentlich zu dieser auseinandersetzung
die heute geführt worden ist das dilemma
für die partei ist nur es gibt
keine konstruktive auflösung erst mal im
gegenteil ist wird vermutlich
schwieriger werden weil die konflikte
haben eher zugenommen die emotionalität
hat zugenommen und es bieten sich jetzt
auch nicht so richtig viele personen an
die noch mal so als puppenkleider
gegenüber den in erscheinung treten
können die man auch dabei haben will
die man aber disziplin ihren wird das
wort disziplin ist ja sehr häufig
gefallen einen entspannten des forschers
dass gerade in dieser partei eine solche
korrektur hat professor schon da vielen
dank an dieser stelle der parteitag da
geht ja noch ein bisschen weiter aber
die debatte die wird noch sehr sehr viel
weiter genutzt
hier ist glaube ich gelernt doch ist
müller wo ist denn der parteitag im
moment ja auch in der debatte aber mehr
in die debatte um eine um die wahl von
rechnungsprüfern wir haben gerade vorhin
und die beiden reden von den beiden
bewerbern gehört sascha schlösser und
brett und es gibt eine elektronische
abstimmung über die wahl dieses ersten
rechnungsprüfers mit diesen beiden
kandidaten und die abstimmung läuft
elektronisch zu schließen und die wahl
zu eröffnen für 45 sekunden
sie sehen beide kandidaten gerade vorhin
in der auf dem screen auf der großen
leinwand die werden beide auf diesem auf
der wahl des ersten rechnungsprüfers mit
gebucht das heißt die der parteitag kann
sich entscheiden oder kann nein zu allen
sagen
mit wahlen wird es auch noch weitere
rechnungsprüfer und die wahl von
richtern und ersatz richtern des bundes
schiedsgerichtes auch noch auf der
tagesordnung steht
es steht auch noch an dass der bericht
des bundesvorstandes für das jahr
2009/10 abgehalten wird
aber jetzt haben wir erstmal auf das
ergebnis sascha schlösser hat die
notwendige einfache mehrheit der
abgegebenen stimmen erreicht er
schlosser nehmen sie die wahl an
herr schlösser nimmt die wahl an
herzlichen glückwunsch zur wahl
[Applaus]
meine damen bekommen zur wahl des
zweiten gleichberechtigten
rechnungsprüfers es steht zur wahl der
kandidaten hat brad sie können mit nein
stimmen oder sie können sich der stimme
enthalten ich weise darauf hin dass sie
noch einmal abstimmen können wir hatten
vorhin uns für eine möglichkeit der
offenen wahl ausgesprochen wer für den
kandidaten eberhard brecht stimmen
möchte der meldet sich bitte jetzt mit
der blauen stimmkarte
danke schön wer ist gegen die wahl des
kandidaten eberhardt brett mit der roten
stimmkarte danke stimmenthaltungen mit
weiß dankeschön wir sind uns im
präsidium einig dass es eine große
mehrheit für die wahl des kandidaten war
harry bad brad hat damit die mehrheit
der stimmen erreicht herbeth nehmen sie
die wahl an
herbert betz ich kann sie nicht sehen
nehmen sie die wahl an
ja ich sehe ihn hat die wahl angenommen
herzlichen glückwunsch soweit gut damit
meine damen und herren haben wir
tagesordnungspunkt 12 der beschlossenen
tagesordnung
wir haben zwölf abgearbeitet und kommt
uns tagesordnungspunkt 13 die wahl von
richtern und ersatz richtung des
bundesschiedsgerichts bevor wir in die
debatte über die wahlmodalitäten
einsteigen was wir hier erst mal
feststellen wie viele richter überhaupt
zu sehen sind ja und über allen wahlen
bei der afg steht wenn sich personen zur
wahl stellen für die eine oder andere
funktion oder das eine oder andere
mandat brauchen sie fünf unterstützer
die den antrag des jähnigen der sich zur
wahl stellen will mit tragen also haben
sie diese fünf unterstützer nicht dann
kann derjenige auch nicht sich um dieses
amt oder diese funktion bewerben
das können sie auch so machen dass die
fünf dann optisch also quasi von vor ort
pult des ist versammlungsleitung stehen
und damit dokumentieren ja wir
unterstützen diese wahl
ich hätte ihnen die zahl derjenigen
bundeswahl richterbundes schiedsrichter
die an dieser wahl teilnehmen können
oder die zahl auch gerne gesagt aber ich
will ihnen keine falsche zahlen nennen
und ich warte einfach ab
auf wieviel bewerbungen der
bundeswahlleiter der bundeswahlleiter
der versammlungsleiter kommt und diese
auch verkündet
ja offensichtlich gibt es dann da doch
einige hürden und hindernisse um die
genaue zahl zu ermitteln denn vorhin
hieß es bei der bahn muss man keine
fehler machen glock noch zustimmen
position heute zu wählen sind
ja meine damen und herren wir warten
auch im haus die genaue anzahl aber wir
können ihn schon mal auf jeden fall 1
ankündigen dass wir in europa noch
interviewen möchten um sein fazit und
sein analyse zudem das gestern und heute
vormittag auf dem parteitag passiert ist
so bist du neu zu hören
das ganze gegen ungefähr 13 50 bis dahin
versuchen wir noch herauszufinden wie
die wahl der bundesrichter nach der
bundesrichter der bundesrichter verläuft
und wer sich der zur wahl stellen wie
sie sagt bis zu fünf schiedsrichtern im
bundesschiedsgericht wählen und bis zu 9
ersatz schiedsrichter
die erfahrungen der letzten monate und
jahre zeigen doch dass es immer sinnvoll
ist vielleicht so viele schiedsrichter
wie möglich zu wählen
und wir würden daher ihnen gerne was das
wahlverfahren und die vorstellungs
modalitäten angeht den folgenden
vorschlag unterbreiten wir möchten ihnen
den gleichen vorschlag unterbreiten wie
er auch bei der wahl des
bundesvorstandes zur anwendung kam also
fünf minuten vorstellungs zeit für jeden
kandidaten bis zu drei fragen an jedem
kandidaten die fragezeit die frage
beträgt 30 sekunden die antwortzeit die
frage eine minute jeder kandidat kann
sich unter diesem top nur einmal
vorstellen
die reihenfolge der kandidaten
vorstellungen würden wir auslösen und
sie werfen in bewährter form denn wenn
sie eine frage anmelden möchten im
scheckkartenformat ihren
mitgliedsausweis oder in anderen
geeigneten ausweis in die ohren
ich darf ihnen darüber hinaus
vorschlagen weil das bei schiedsrichter
wahlen immer sehr sinnvoll ist dass wir
jeden kandidaten bevor er sich hier zur
wahl stellt befragen darüber ob er die
befähigung zum richteramt besitzt damit
wir da auch einen überblick machen haben
und ihn entsprechend auch
sie sozusagen wissen ob sie auch hier
einen volljuristen in schiedsgericht
wählen oder nicht es ist ich weiß aber
natürlich ausdrücklich darauf hin sie
müssen kein volljurist sein um sich zum
schiedsrichter wählen zu lassen es ist
sogar fast üblich dass einige der
beisitzer halt keine volljuristen sind
und schließlich darf ich auch noch mal
darauf hinweisen wir würden ihnen das
herkömmliche einzel wahlverfahren
vorschlagen
wir würden jetzt aber nicht im vor so
meine damen und herren an dieser stelle
werden wir die wahl zu den wir später
wieder kommen erst mal verlassen und
haben die japaner den bundessprecher am
set von alexander keller und der ist
tatsächlich da der co vorsitzende timo
copala der ja gemeinsam mit jörg deuten
die partei führt und begrüße sie das war
vielleicht gefühlsmäßig für alle da eine
achterbahnfahrt heute vormittag das ist
ja ein bisschen anders abgelaufen als
man sich das eigentlich dachte das
vorziehen
dieses antrages der missbilligung des
spalterischen gebannt ihres co
vorsitzenden kollegen darüber haben wir
gestern ja schon gesprochen wenn die
partei einen der beiden vorsitzenden
derartig in den schwitzkasten nimmt
schade dass der partei oder ist das
auszeichnung einer großen
diskussionskultur zunächst einmal keller
wir haben gestern in renten konzept
verabschiedet mit großen votum mit über
88 prozent der delegierten da freue ich
mich erstmal darüber dass wir auch
programmatisch endlich mal ein schritt
weiter gekommen sind
und natürlich gab es diskussionsbedarf
wir sind die sehr lebendige partei das
hat man heute gemacht ich denke das war
vielleicht auch angebracht gewesen
das muss man derzeit nachteil zu
billigen es wollten viele mitglieder die
diese debatte leider hat das natürlich
jetzt ein bisschen das programmatische
verschoben muss man ganz ehrlich sagen
gut also nun hat man ja gestern gemerkt
ich glaube viele delegierte wenn man
sich mit programmatischen befasst dann
ist das richtig viel schwarzbrot da ist
nicht emotionen drin da muss man
stundenlang sitzfleisch zeigen wir haben
das ja auch am stück ununterbrochen
gezeigt heute war wieder etwas mehr
emotionen etwas mehr stimmung in der
bude das kann man wirklich sagen
nochmal das was jetzt ihrem kollegen
vorsitzenden jörg leuten widerfahren ist
auf dem parteitag hatte das beschädigt
oder hat ihn das gestärkt programmatik
ist immer natürlich viel arbeit warmes
jahr in polen das programm kommission
vorher in den fachausschüssen haben
viele partei und natürlich auch
delegierte die hier waren viel arbeit
und schweiß reingesteckt über drei jahre
haben wir für diesen leitantrag
gearbeitet da muss man erstmal zunächst
sagen diesen froh dass wir das
umlageverfahren gestärkt haben dass wir
auch für die familien mehr investieren
wollen auch gerade was die rente angeht
das ist keine armutsrenten ergibt
sondern wohlstands renten dass die
rentner nach 40 jahren arbeit auch damit
zurechtkommen
und natürlich wurden solche und werden
solche debatten mit mit anderen dingen
dann überlagert das ist natürlich für
die medien immer sehr interessant aber
insgesamt bin ich sehr zufrieden das ist
auch so konzentriert hier abliefert
sie haben ja gesagt haben diesen blinden
fleck renten und sozialpolitik damit
überzogen mit einer mit einer klaren
programmatischen aussagen will ich ganz
gerne dabei bleiben weil das natürlich
jetzt auch die zuschauer wahrscheinlich
heute am meisten in bann gezogen hat
diese frage um jörg morgen nochmal die
frage ist eher geschädigt oder geht er
geschädigt aus dem parteitag hervor oder
sogar gestärkt so wie er das jetzt hier
heute vormittag auch gezeigt hat und
letztendlich gegen die sache jetzt zu
ende mit einer nichtbefassung eines
antrags über den stundenlang diskutiert
wurde
ja ich fand es auch gut dass es nicht
mehr befasst wurde wir haben wie gesagt
noch andere tagesordnungspunkte die sehr
wichtig für uns als partei sind wir
müssen noch nach meinen dass die
schiedsgerichte angeht also das weite
auch gut dass diese debatte beendet
wurde
alle anderen fragen muss herhalten
selber beantworten wir haben jetzt einen
dazu bewährten und neuen größeren
bundesvorstand ich freue mich darauf die
arbeit auf die zusammenarbeit wir haben
eine wichtige bundestagswahl vor der tür
darauf werden wir uns jetzt intensiv
vorbereiten dass wir das auch mit einem
ordentlichen ergebnis natürlich
abschließen können also solidarität mit
ihrem kollegen an der parteispitze hört
sich ein bisschen anders an wenn sie
sagen das muss jetzt jürgen heute selbst
erledigen
ich hab nicht wieder gelingen kann dazu
kann man sich selbst äußern
vielleicht unterstütze sie ihnen dabei
auch bei der konsolidierung es geht ja
auch darum dass nach dieser diskussion
die partei beieinander bleibt das wurde
ja immer wieder in dieser diskussion auf
dem parteitag erwähnt dass die bayern
da bleibt dass die spitze sich einig ist
dass sie versucht einigkeit herzustellen
dass sie als vorbild solidarität
untereinander zeigt natürlich absolut
unterstütze ich ihn dabei das ist meine
aufgabe haben zwei bundessprecher und
ich denke das hat in der vergangenheit
wenn es auch kleine
meinungsverschiedenheiten inhaltlicher
art magath das ist ganz normal dass auch
wichtig für uns aber ich werde da
weiterhin unterstützen auch wenn er
jetzt die unterstützung braucht werde
ich ihn natürlich dort auch gerne helfen
sie hatten ja gestern ganz
unterschiedliche akzente gesetzt
bei den räten sie haben gesagt die afg
es war ja so etwas wie ein opfer der
machenschaften der altparteien und der
behörden sie haben besonders den
verfassungsschutz da sicherlich im auge
gehabt werden jungen leuten ja kritik an
der verhalten vieler parteimitglieder
funktionsträger geübt hat gesagt hier
öffnen wir türen zum beispiel für die
beobachtung des verfassungsschutzes war
dass so ein spiel mit verteilten rollen
wie er die linie der steckten
inhaltlichen ausrichtung und er auf der
anderen seite die kritik an manchen
auswüchsen der afg oder sind sie sich da
dort doch nicht einig in diesen fragen
wie man sich nach außen zeigt wie man
mit dem verfassungsschutz umgeht wie die
afg ihre treue zur verfassung die sie
jetzt auch noch mal beschlossen hat am
freitagabend zeigt sind sie da gespalten
oder ist das ein spiel mit verteilten
rollen
ich finde man muss die frage stellen was
interessiert den wähler den wähler
interessiert die programmatik der partei
so will die partei hin was ist ihre was
sind ihre ziele das haben ja hier ein
auf diesem parteitag neu definiert und
insgesamt sage ich immer wieder
natürlich gibt es
meinungsverschiedenheiten noch innerhalb
der partei aber dreckwäsche wäre
spannend zu hause und nicht in der
öffentlichkeit das nur interessant für
die medien nicht für die wähler und
dieses bild sollten wir nach außen nicht
geben gut sie hat mir gerade jetzt
ausführlich über das renten- und
sozialpolitische konzept gesprochen es
gehört natürlich auch dazu wie sich die
partei nach außen zeigt und das sind
personen das sind sie das ist der
co-vorsitzende das ist der
bundesvorstand da gibt es ja eine ganze
reihe die schon eine gewisse politische
prominenz erreicht haben
wie glauben sie denn mit dem thema
corona das hier ja eine wichtige rolle
gespielt hat nicht nur wegen der hier
vorhandenen masken pflicht wie glauben
sie denn wie das für die partei
als thema in zukunft brauchbar ist das
ähnlich in ähnlich helfen wie bei eur vj
bald migration wie bei klima werden sie
das seien ganz vorne auf die agenda
setzen gerade auch im sich jetzt
entwickelten bundes und landtagswahl
kampf gewinnen corona alle ernst genauso
wie wir das tun aber wir zeigen
natürlich die missstände auf die mit
corona in verbindung sind also wie hier
freiheits und grundrechte eingeschränkt
werden jedoch teilweise der mittelstand
die hotel und gastronomie ist hier zu
nennen
natürlich stark darunter leidet wir
haben eine riesige welle von
folgeinsolvenzen die vor uns her die wir
vor uns herschieben es wird im märz wenn
das insolvenzrecht ausgesetzt ist
wahrscheinlich ein anstehen
das müssen wir dazu müssen wir antworten
finden und wir legen den finger in die
wunde
das müssen wir als oppositionspartei das
macht keine andere oppositionspartei so
deutlich wie wir in unserem politischen
system gibt es ja so genannte
vorfeldorganisationen also die
gewerkschaften gelten da als
vorfeldorganisation der spd oder
gehalten das jedenfalls lange zeit die
kirchen auch lange zeit für die union
ist in die vorfeldorganisation der afg
sind das die querdenker die haben
verschieden was jetzt
vorfeldorganisation in diesem bereich
wir sind so der anschluss an die ahv hat
so sind ja auch ein stück weit auf den
straßen bewegung groß geworden und wir
wollen diesen bezug zur straße zum
bürger weiterhin pflegen das ist unsere
aufgabe es ist tue ich auch selbst weil
damit hat man den kontakt zur
bevölkerung und das ist ja das was wir
auch vielen altparteien vorwerfen dass
dieser bezug nicht mehr da ist dass man
eigentlich völlig realitätsfremd
mittlerweile auch im bundestag
argumentiert weil die wirklichen
probleme und der üppigen dinge über die
wir diskutieren müssen die finden
natürlich zu hause stattfinden am
arbeitsplatz statt und da müssen wir hin
und das wollen wir als auf die auch
weiterhin tun
teilen sie die meinung von jörg morden
der gesagt hat die querdenker da sind
auch eine ganze reihe von bedenklichen
elementen dabei ist unterstellt
unterstützt zwar die korona proteste
aber bei den querten tauchen auf
rechtsextremisten da tauchen auf
verschwörungstheoretiker leute die
eigentlich mit diesem politischen system
mit der verfassung mit der freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung gar nichts
zu tun haben wollen und die müssen wir
da sozusagen isolieren ist das auch ihre
meinung wissen sie bei diesen ganzen
straßen organisationen und bei großdemos
egal welcher couleur auf linker seite
auf rechter seite oder das eigentliche
bürgertum wozu ich im übrigen die
querdenker zielle
es sind unterschiedliche politische
akteure unterwegs aller verschiedenen
gesellschaftsschichten da mache ich mich
mit niemanden gemeint die ich gehe und
schaue mir an für welche werte und
welche grundrechte diese menschen auf
die straße gehen und ob ich mich damit
solidarisiere das ist immer noch meine
persönliche entscheidung ich vergleiche
das immer gerne mit dem fußballstar denn
da gibt es auch personen die mir nie
gefallen auf den rängen trotzdem mache
ich mich mit denen ich gemein da muss
jeder selbst verantwortlich natürlich
auch agieren und wenn shops strafbare
handlung stattfinden dann ist es ein
fall für die polizei für die
justizbehörden das ist nicht die aufgabe
der afd
das heißt sie sehen schon auch bei
dieser demonstration am 18 november in
berlin dass das demonstrationsrecht von
den wertingen missbraucht worden ist
denn die demonstration wurde aufgelöst
nach mehrfacher missachtung der auflagen
und danach wurde es gewalttätig 50
verletzt zum teil schwer verletzte
polizisten sprechen da eine deutliche
sprache also würden auch schon sehen
dass querdenker auch das
demonstrationsrecht dass er in der
verfassung verankert ist missbraucht das
muss aufgearbeitet werden muss man sich
auch genau anschauen anschauen natürlich
das tue ich auch persönlich gewalt lehne
ich generell ab aber auch insgesamt ich
hab's ja selbst erlebt ich war kurz mal
draußen hat mir das auch angeschaut und
auch den kontakt zu haben den bürgern
ich fand aber auch eine insgesamt sehr
aggressive polizei dort vor dem haus
auch ich weiß ich auch nie welche
anweisung der von herrn geisel der ist
ja ein vergangenheit schon mit ähnlichen
dingen aufgefallen
dem innensenator von berlin gegeben hat
also es hat mich ein bisschen sehr
irritiert wie doch sehr provokant die
polizei davor angefangen also nach
deeskalation saß mir nichts aus ich habe
viele familien gesehen viele ältere
menschen und dass man dort wasser war
verein einsetzt bei einer veranstaltung
wohl nicht 20 30.000 da waren das hielt
ich ein stück weit für überzogen also
das hat mir nicht gefallen
ich denke da hätte man deeskalierend
wirken können letzte frage führen sie
mit jörg menten gern die afd
ich freue mich jeden tag heute
ich finde diese konstellation dass wir
einen bundessprecher aus dem westen
haben einen bundessprecher aus dem osten
das ist ja genau das was als klammer
unserer partei dienen sollen ich denke
das werden wir auch das nächste jahr
noch gemeinsam tun und ich freue mich
auch auf eigentlich jeden tag auf die
arbeit um die partei nach vorn zu
bringen
vor allem programmatisch das ist uns
gestern gelungen und das ist auch mein
ziel s weiterhin zu tun
soweit die yoc gruppe
bundessprecher also parteivorsitzender
co parteivorsitzende ralf dem phoenix
interview
danke dass sie dabei sehr gerne so und
wir geben jetzt noch mal zurück an nach
zu doris müller und zu den letzten
minuten des fdp-parteitags ja vielen
dank alexander keller ja ein paar
minuten mehr wird der parteitag
sicherlich noch dauern
der parteitag befasst sich jetzt gerade
mit der neuwahl von fünf richtern und
neuen ersatz richtung das ist ein
relativ sehr prozess sie wissen ja dass
das bundesschiedsgericht der afg immer
wieder einige knifflige fälle zu
entscheiden hat der letzte prominente
fall war ja der von herrn kalbitz fällt
mir jetzt gerade der vorname nicht ein
andreas natürlich und der letzte fall
den das bundesschiedsgericht zu
verantworten hatte war der rauswurf von
den bundestagsabgeordneten frank
busemann der auf antrag oder auf
beschluss des bundes schiedsgerichtes
auch die partei verlassen musste ihm
bleibt jetzt auch nur noch der gang vor
ein ordentliches gericht um diese
entscheidung zu widerrufen
der parteitag wird sich noch mit diesen
diesen wahlen beschäftigen es steht noch
an dass es ein tätigkeitsbericht der
partei verantwortlichen für das jahr
2009 10 gibt ein rechenschaftsbericht
und dann wird es ganz am ende des
parteitages noch ein paar sachen anträge
geben in denen es unter anderem auch
noch mal um das thema verfassungsschutz
geht all das werden wir ihnen natürlich
in einer zusammenfassung nachreichen
oder nachrichtlich auch noch zukommen
lassen wie das ausgegangen ist was
bleibt vom parteitag es wurde ein
rentenkonzept beschlossen in dem das
umlageverfahren mit eindeutiger mehrheit
als zukunftsmodell verabschiedet wurde
mit 88 prozent
es gab eine turbulente zweite sitzung in
der es um die personalie von jörg
wollten ging es wurde in dieser debatte
haarscharf an einer
abwahl oder an einem rücktritt der dann
automatisch die folge gehabt hätte wenn
es um diesen antrag eine mehrheit
gegeben hätte von jörg nolte gegangen
all das ist zum glück kann man ja sagen
für die partei nicht passiert denn die
konsequenzen wären dann in der tat sehr
nachdenklich geworden so ist es so
gewesen dass sie ob leuten eine kritik
an bestimmten aktionen vor allen dingen
an die bundestagsfraktion gerichtet hat
es wurde debattiert aber es wurde nicht
um seine person abgestimmt
die partei steht vor einen großen
herausforderungen sie steht bei den
umfragen nur noch zwischen 7 und 9
prozent sie muss suchen das sie für den
wähler nicht als zerstrittener haufen in
das wahljahr 2021 geht da bleibt genug
arbeit für diese partei wir werden sehen
wohin die reise geht und einstweilen
gebe ich ab bedanke mich für ihr
zuschauen für diese zweitägige
übertragung aus kalkar vom
fdp-bundesparteitag und gebe ab zu
konstanz sawatzki und ich sage vielen
dank den kollegen die diese präsenz der
parteitag mit begleitet haben die fdp
hat sich im präsenz getroffen andere die
machen